Hallo und herzlich willkommen zur Freakshow Nummer 299.
Unaufhaltsam rückzieher.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Vielleicht sollten wir einfach vom Dezimalsystem auf irgendein
anderes System umstellen und dann haben wir das Thema nicht mehr.
Aber egal, es ist wie es ist. Ich bin Tim Britlaff. Hallo, herzlich willkommen zur Freakshow.
Und wir haben aus gutem Grund noch eine Woche später gesendet,
als wir das ursprünglich vorhatten.
Und zwar mit all den Stimmen der Jugend, die wir zu bieten haben.
Zum Beispiel Reifsstimmen, die ihr schon gehört habt.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Nicht wahr? So als Berufsjugendlicher hat man auch echt ganz schön was zu tun.
Also es ist ja auch noch keine Ablöse in Sicht. Stimmt's, Roddy?
Ich mache den Job seit Jahrzehnten.
Das ist mich jetzt genauso. Das ist auch irgendwie belastend.
Immerhin, was mich qualifiziert, ich habe hier auch heute Abend in dieser Runde
die wenigsten grauen Haare.
Das stimmt. Wie heißt die Tönung?
Das werde ich auf dem Abi-Treffen auch immer gefragt. Das sei doch alles wieder die Natur.
Aber nein, da bin ich mit Genen gesegnet.
Okay, du bist so naturschwarz sozusagen, ja?
Ich fürchte.
Aha, okay. Naja, gut. Wie auch immer. Aber so im Bad irgendwie?
Ja, es kommt langsam. Ich hätte ja gerne graue Schläfen. Da würde ich also einiges
für tun, um mal so distinguierte, damit ich jetzt mal ernst genommen werde, so in meinem Job.
So wie ich, oder was?
Aber, naja, passiert nicht.
Aber da gibt es Produkte, mit denen man dann nachhelfen kann.
Ja, Luxusprobleme, würde ich sagen.
Luxusprobleme. Gut. Wir haben kein Luxusproblem, denn wir haben hier noch ein
Upgrade mit dazu eingeladen und zwar den Jens. Jens Ohlig. Hallo.
Hallo.
Herzlich willkommen zurück, muss man sagen, in der Freakshow.
Ich habe jetzt natürlich vorher, wie es meine Pflicht gewesen wäre,
nicht nachgeschaut, wenn du das letzte Mal da warst.
In der Freakshow weiß ich gar nicht.
Ja, warst du aber.
War ich auch mal, ja.
Ja, da haben wir dich hier direkt von der Straße, glaube ich,
rekrutiert, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Oh, das ist aber schon eine Weile her.
Ich freue mich auf jeden Fall, heute Abend unter alten Männern zu sein,
denn wenn man ehrlich ist, bin ich auch ein Arm.
Wow, ich glaube es ja überhaupt nicht. Das ist zehn Jahre her, mein Freund. Nein, elf.
Ja, genau.
Die Welt dreht sich.
War das die einzige Sendung wirklich ernsthaft? Ich bin total überrascht.
Ich dachte, du wärst zweimal da gewesen.
Mit Jan Dehnhardt. Kannst du dich daran erinnern?
Wie auch immer. Ihr bist auf jeden Fall richtig. Genau.
Denn wir wollen über einiges reden, womit du ja immer viel zu tun hast.
Spoiler. fängt mit Vicky an und mit diversen Dingen hört es auf.
Mit Versum hört es auf.
Mit Versum hört es auf, genau. Und ja, das interessiert uns ja hier brennend.
Jetzt, wo es eigentlich ja aufs Jahresende zu rollt und das ist ja dann vor
allem immer Kongresszeit, ne?
As we speak dürften jetzt schon alle restlichen Tickets verkauft worden sein.
Wir starten hier gerade kurz nach acht, naja, halb neun, um ehrlich zu sein.
Und um acht ging so der letzte Badge los und ich bin gespannt,
wie viele Sekunden es gehalten hat.
Also sprich unsere Viertelstunde ungefähr.
So lange?
Ja.
Oh, wow.
Wir sind jetzt die Trostshow für alle.
Die keins gekriegt haben.
Genau, die Hörer schafft es entweder himmelhoch jauchzend oder zu Tode betrübt.
Ja, naja gut, also ich meine, auf den letzten Metern gibt es ja dann doch immer noch was, ne?
Nicht vergessen, es gibt ja noch Corona und Grippe und all diese ganzen Sachen.
Leute werden krank und schmeißen dann ihre Tickets auf den Markt.
Also es gibt immer eine Möglichkeit noch dazu zu stoßen, wenn man es denn wirklich will.
Das ist natürlich wichtig, es wird auch abgefragt.
Von wem? Das war ein Witz.
Achso.
Keiner interessiert das. Ja, ja, der Kongress und wir werden,
genau, da müssen wir noch ein bisschen Werbung machen, denn es wird auch wieder
ein Sendezentrum geben.
Und das Sendezentrum ist ja so ein bisschen die Podcast-Gemeinde,
die sich dort auf dem Kongress sammelt. wieder auf im Bereich X und.
Wie letztes Jahr.
Du musst jetzt sagen, vormals Twitter. Das ist der Witz.
Der zieht jetzt, glaube ich, schon lange nicht mehr. Ja, der zieht es durch. Das geht langsam durch.
Vormals Reiter oder was?
Genau, also in X.
Wer nennt das echt X?
Nein, das CCH nennt das X.
Wir können da nichts führen.
Es gibt da einen Bereich X.
Wir nennen das Sendezentrum.
Es gibt auch einen Bereich Y und Z gibt es, glaube ich, auch.
Ja, ja. X, Y, Z, das sind ja diese neuen Dinge, die sie da nach dem Umbau eingebaut haben.
Also Z ist oben, wo nochmal der Saal ist und X und Y sind so die erweiterten
Community-Bereiche. Genau.
Und wenn ihr entweder Podcast macht oder Podcast hört, dann würden wir euch da gerne sehen.
Wie im letzten Jahr, wenn wir dort einen Raum haben, in dem Podcasts live on
stage sind oder auch Podcast relevantes Zeug in kleinen Vorträgen und Workshops.
da sammeln wir gerade auch noch,
Bewerbungen das heißt wenn ihr dort was vortragen möchtet oder wenn ihr dort
eure Show on Air aufnehmen wollt, dann könntet ihr das tun den Link dazu,
den tun wir mal hier gleich in die,
Shownotes rein und dann könnt ihr euch da sozusagen mit bewerben,
und dann kriegen wir da schon irgendwie alles hin,
Genau, und wir haben auch beschlossen, dass wir so mit der Freakshow auch vor
Ort sind und das ist auch, sagen wir mal, so eine kleine Idee,
wenn ihr mit eurem Podcast dort sein wollt und mit Hörern, wie sagt man, verbinden,
jetzt gibt es noch ein modernes Wort dafür, ne?
Gruscheln.
Jetzt haben wir unsere Jugendhaftigkeit nachweislich unter Beweis gestellt.
Genau, also wenn ihr mit Hörerinnen und Hörern gruscheln wollt,
dann wäre das auch eine Gelegenheit.
Und hier mal eine Idee dazu, die dürft ihr uns auch klauen.
Die ist nicht exklusiv, sondern ist einfach eher so eine Anregung.
Das heißt, Reif und Roddy und ich, wir werden da also sein und werden da zu
irgendeinem Zeitpunkt eine Show machen.
Aber das wird jetzt nicht so wie hier. weil wir sind ja nicht hier und auch nicht.
So wie früher in Riesenseelen.
Ne, auch nicht so wie früher und so weiter also so populär sind wir ja auch
nun wirklich nicht mehr aber die paar verbliebenen Hörer dürfen gerne dazukommen
und ihr dürft euch das anhören, aber ihr dürft vor allem, und das ist der Sinn
der ganzen Sache wie bei Clubhouse,
auch mit auf der Bühne ruf das heißt, ihr macht die Sendung mit uns und ihr,
setzt die Themen, das heißt, wer Lust hat ein Thema auf die Bühne zu tragen Vielen Dank.
Darf das dann gerne machen und dann holen wir euch auf die Bühne und dann seid
ihr sozusagen mit dabei und dann sind wir mal gespannt, worum es geht.
Das heißt, wir reden dann sozusagen über eure Themen.
Genau, also was wir schon immer all die Jahre völlig vernachlässigt oder völlig
falsch dargestellt haben.
Ja, ihr könnt auch mit Sendungskritik kommen, könnt ihr so hochkommen und sagen,
ihr alten Säcke, ihr habt ja eh keine Ahnung und hier ist das Erata der letzten fünf Jahre.
Aber der entscheidende Spin dabei ist, für den Zeitpunkt, wo ihr dann da auf
der Bühne seid, seid ihr dann auch die Hosts der Sendung.
Das heißt also, ihr müsst uns dann auch durchmoderieren.
Genau, ihr werdet dann nicht irgendwie interviewt oder so und sag mal,
wer du bist oder so, sondern dann wollen wir natürlich auch was sehen.
Genau.
Ja, jetzt rennt wahrscheinlich schon wieder die Hälfte so innerlich irgendwie schreiend davon.
Also wir kriegen das schon irgendwie auch gemeinsam hin. Also wir bleiben ja auch eure Co-Hosts.
Und wir sind ja gutmütig.
Das auch.
Meistens.
Einen Podcast selber editieren, also sozusagen einen Wiki-Podcast.
Einen Gruschel-Podcast.
Kann man so reingruscheln. Was
auch immer dieses Wort jemals gemeint haben könnte. Wir wissen es nicht.
Ja, ja. Ich finde das gar keine schlechte Idee.
Wir wissen noch nicht ganz genau, an welchem Tag wir das machen.
Das hängt jetzt so ein bisschen von den anderen Bewerbungen ab und wann wie wo was ist.
Aber das Programm wird dann kurz vorm Kongress auch rausgehauen werden.
Und wenn ihr dann vor Ort seid, dann seid ihr dabei.
Und W kommt nicht, weil dann sind wir nämlich total enttäuscht.
Und dann machen wir das nie, nie wieder.
Ja, oder wir erzählen halt das übliche Zeug, ne?
Nee, ich will ja jetzt kein... Das übliche Zeug, was für ein übliches...
Also ich bereite da keine Themen vor. Ja, vielleicht eins.
Kein Elixier? Kein AI?
Ja, ich meine, das gibt es ja sonst immer so. Ich meine, wir können uns natürlich
auch über einen Kongress unterhalten, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das so trägt.
Ich finde, ihr solltet mal wieder über Max reden.
Das stimmt. Dann sollte Apple sich mal bemühen, da was zu machen,
dass es sich auch mal wieder lohnt, über Max zu unterhalten.
Ja.
Gruppen kuscheln, kuscheln, ja. Ja, haben wir noch irgendwie eine Anmerkung dazu?
Also, wie gesagt, fühlt euch motiviert. Wir haben da einfach Raum.
Achso, genau, und es gibt nicht nur diesen Raum, sondern es gibt,
wie immer, auch den Podcast-Tisch.
Das heißt, wenn ihr einfach nur eine Sendung aufnehmen wollt,
Also wenn ihr irgendwie vom Kongress, wenn ihr so einen Podcast-Urge habt,
kennt man ja manchmal, jetzt eine Sendung aufnehmen, wie geil wäre das denn.
Also um diesen Move auch noch zu bedienen, könnt ihr euch dann auch eintragen
und sagen, hier Podcast-Tisch, wir wollen das auch für das selbe Anmeldesystem,
wir wollen da irgendwann mal eine Sendung aufnehmen. Und da könnt ihr damit bis zu...
Ich glaube sogar bis zu sechs, sieben, acht Leute sitzen.
So viele nicht, aber fünf, sechs sollte gehen.
Naja, wir haben das große 8-portige Teil da vor Ort und genug Headsets finden
sich meistens immer irgendwie zusammen.
Auf der Bühne ist jetzt glaube ich das Limit des sechs.
Nee, es ist sechs, geht glaube ich auch. Müssen wir nochmal gucken.
Das hängt so ein bisschen davon ab, wie viele Headsets den Weg auf dem Kongress finden.
Also das Achter-Setup hat ja auch den liebevollen Namen für Rudel-Podcast.
Was auch ein bewährtes Modell ist, ist, dass dort mal so ein Podcast-Team-Crossover stattfindet.
Wo also zwei Podcast-Crews zusammen eine Sendung machen, die sich schon immer
irgendwie ganz cool fanden.
Also auch dafür ist dieses Setup gut geeignet.
Das stimmt. Das finde ich eigentlich auch gut.
Ja, ihr müsst geplant genug sein, euch da vorher einzutragen,
damit ihr auch einen Slot abkriegt.
Aber eigentlich sind gerade gegen Abend- und Nachtstunden dann auch Dinge frei.
Und auch tagsüber.
Auch tagsüber, ja.
Der Nachmittag und der frühe Abend, der ist immer...
Ja, das stimmt. Also der Podcast-Tisch ist nicht so heftig ausgebucht normalerweise.
Genau. Beim Podcast-Tisch kann man dann wahrscheinlich auch einfach zuhören.
Also wenn man sich da so dazusetzen will, dann gibt es noch so Zuhöroptionen.
Aber da geht es primär darum, dass man das einfach aufnehmen kann.
ohne jetzt Equipment mitnehmen zu müssen und dann wird alles gut.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob Podcasting überhaupt noch jemand interessiert oder ob
wir uns nicht was Neues einfallen lassen müssen.
Irgendwas mit Video.
Jol, was ist denn so dein Take zum Kongress? Hast du noch Spaß dran?
Ich habe noch Spaß dran, ja. Ich habe auch dieses Jahr was eingereicht,
das ist leider nicht ins Programm gekommen, weil es gab wohl ganz viele andere
tolle Sachen so im Programm.
Und da lohnt es sich auch nicht böse zu sein, wenn man dann sieht,
was alles andere des Tolles da drin ist.
Genau, ich habe jetzt eine längere Pause gemacht und dieses Mal gebe ich mir das jetzt.
Eine längere Kongresspause? Von wie vielen Events?
2018 war ich das letzte Mal da.
Nein!
Also vor Corona, also nach Corona nicht wieder eingestiegen.
Genau.
Ah, und wie war das so?
Ich habe viel auf dem Sofa gesessen und mir den Stream angeguckt.
Okay, also hast du es jetzt nicht so komplett ignoriert, du warst nur nicht vor Ort?
Genau.
Okay, und weißt du nicht, Macht das was mit einem? Also kriegt man dann so,
ist das so ein FOMO-Akkumulator?
Natürlich, FOMO. Und deswegen bin ich auch dieses Jahr wieder dabei.
Okay, aber es hat ja dann lang gedauert.
Ja, sagen wir mal so, irgendwie das erste Mal nach Corona war es mir noch nicht
so ganz geheuer. Dann das zweite Mal habe ich es irgendwie verpeilt.
Und zack, sind schon wieder zwei Jahre oben.
Wann war der nochmal der Kongress? Das ist schon wieder vergessen.
Ja, okay. Ich meine, dann hast du ja nicht sozusagen die die gloriose Wiederkehr ins CCH erlebt.
Ja, aber ich kenne das ja noch, das CCH.
Ja.
Nein.
Ist halt auch noch.
Ist schon anders. Alles neu und renoviert.
Ist es ein bisschen größer als das Eilstädter Bürgerhaus?
Nicht das Hamburg. Du warst auch schon vorher im CCH. Aber dass es jetzt so
umgebaut ist, was sie ja mitbekommen haben.
Hast du es nicht mitbekommen? Hast du mitbekommen?
Ich habe davon gehört, ja.
Du hast davon gehört, okay. Ich bin gespannt.
Da bin ich ja sehr gespannt auf deine Sachen. Ja, was so, dann wollte ich nochmal
eine Reiseaktivität ankündigen, weil das hat immer sehr gut funktioniert,
muss ich sagen, hier in der Freakshow.
Das hat mich motiviert, das auch ein weiteres Mal zu machen.
Ich bin jetzt gerade so ein bisschen in meiner Winterreisenplanung.
Und es sieht sehr danach aus, dass es mich nach Südafrika verschlägt.
Wo denn Südafrika?
Ja, so Kapstadtregion, da werde ich da so ein bisschen rum homebasen und von
dort aus strahlenmäßig schauen,
was die Region so für mich in petto hat.
Wein und Pinguine, habe ich gehört.
Wein und Pinguine. Im Süden gibt es Pinguine.
Man kann in Südafrika Pinguine gucken. Und dieses Fleisch, dieses getrocknete Fleisch.
Das getrocknete Fleisch?
Ja, Beef Jerky.
Ach, das kommt von da?
Die machen auch etwas, aber das ist halt deutlich besser als das, was die Amis machen.
Ach.
Das solltest du mindestens probieren. Das heißt, glaube ich, auch Jerky oder so.
Achso, ist es The Real Jerky oder was?
Da lege ich mich jetzt mal nicht fest. Es ist auf jeden Fall das bessere Jerky.
Aha, das bessere Jerky. Jetzt muss ich erstmal Intelligenz fragen, wie man das nennt.
Also, wenn du da tatsächlich in Kapstadt bist, ist es auf jeden Fall eine super interessante Ecke.
Da gibt es...
Du warst da schon mal.
Da war schon mal vor ein paar Jahren eine Wikimedia-Konferenz.
Und das war eine der wenigen Konferenzen, unterhalb des Äquators.
Dieses Jahr auch wieder in Kenia. Kann ich auch noch mal zwei Worte dazu verlassen.
Aber ja, Kapstadt ist auf jeden Fall super interessant. Da ist eine große indische
Community auch und das Essen ist entsprechend gut und lecker.
Bobo Tea ist auch noch eine Sache, die man probieren muss.
Bobo Tea?
Ja, das ist so ein klassischer Auflauf in Südafrika.
Wie schreibt sich das?
Wie man spricht.
B-O-B-O-T-I Tatsächlich.
Wahrscheinlich Bobotje.
Ein Auflauf. Interessant.
Ja, Bill Tong war der gesuchte Name.
Ja, ich glaube Bill Tong ist sogar, ist das nicht sogar so ein bisschen das
Synonym für, kann das sein, für Barbecue?
Nee, das ist Brei.
Ah, ja richtig, Brei. Brei, genau. Wie schreibt sich das? Hast du das im Kopf?
B-R-A-A-I, glaube ich.
B-R-A-A-I. E.
Vielleicht noch, keine Ahnung.
Doch doch, genau, alles klar,
Haben ja schon wieder alle Begriffe beisammen. Okay.
Also kulinarisch würde mich das glaube ich sehr reizen.
Ja, ich bin jetzt auch schon ein bisschen erregt.
Okay, für Kulinarik ist gesorgt.
Für Kulinarik scheint definitiv gesorgt sein. Ein Brei wurde ich wohl auch schon eingeladen.
Beziehungsweise wurde mir das in Aussicht gestellt, dass man da nicht dran vorbeikommt.
Das sieht ganz so danach aus.
Aber was mich natürlich wirklich interessieren würde, ist, sollte es Hörerinnen
oder Hörer in Südafrika geben?
Oder da in der Region? Weiß nicht. Also, okay, Region, also das ist natürlich
alles sehr groß. Was gibt es da noch für ein Einzugsgebiet in der Ecke? Namibia vielleicht?
Genau.
Namibia, auch ein Land.
Wo… Ja, das habe ich so im Hinterkopf für, kann man nochmal einen Ausflug auch noch hinmachen.
Deutsch ist dort eine der offiziellen Sprachen.
Deswegen interessiert mich das auch so ein bisschen. Also nicht wegen der Sprache,
sondern der Geschichte, die das sozusagen hatte.
Ja. Deutsch, Süd, Est, Afrika ist keine schöne Geschichte.
Nee, ist keine schöne Geschichte, aber naja, ist auf jeden Fall mal interessant
zu sehen, was so für Fußstapfen die Geschichte dort hinterlassen hat.
Das war ja nicht ganz ohne Auswirkung.
Das will ich jetzt auch gar nicht alles aufrollen.
In der Wüste Namibia, in der Namibwürste, gibt es eine Kunstinstallation.
Da ist so ein Lautsprecherset, was solarbetrieben ist und dann 24 Stunden lang von Toto ab.
Das ist brutal.
Warte mal, davon habe ich sogar schon mal gehört. Das finden wir doch schnell
raus, wo das ist. Ah ja, genau, hier.
To play for all eternity in the Namib Desert. Alles klar.
Das ist a thing. Hm.
Oh Mann.
For all eternity. Das ist die Frage, wie lange das hält.
Oh Mann. Ja, also wie gesagt, wenn ihr das hört und ihr seid da oder ihr habt
da irgendwie Südafrika-Erfahrung, das würde mich natürlich auch interessieren.
Ich werde voraussichtlich, es ist alles noch nicht in Stein gemeißelt,
aber ich werde voraussichtlich ab Mitte Januar dort aufschlagen und dann da
auch ein bisschen länger bleiben wollen.
Und dann gucke ich mal, was alles so passiert. Und ich sammle jetzt gerade so
die Dinge, die ich mal abklopfen sollte.
Aber wir werden natürlich auch weiterhin senden, keine Angst.
Weil ein Grund für Südafrika ist natürlich die kompatible Zeitzone.
Das fand ich dann doch sehr interessant.
Stimmt, nur eine Stunde.
Weil als ich jetzt in Asien unterwegs war, Das war ja mit uns hier irgendwie
sehr schwierig, da gemeinsame Termine zu finden.
Das soll uns so nicht wieder passieren. Deswegen dachte ich mir,
bleibe ich mal in der gleichen Zeitzone.
Und ja, auch gut, dass du da zu unseren Wintermonaten auf der Nordhalbkugel hin wirst.
Weil da ist es dann halt richtig Sommer.
So als ich da war, das war so Juli, August. Da war es knackig kalt.
Genau, das war natürlich auch so ein bisschen die Intention hier,
der Kälte zu entfliehen. und dann dachte ich mir, passt das irgendwie ganz gut.
Ja, und ich bin gespannt. Also ich bin natürlich auch gespannt,
falls irgendjemand da im Tech-Bereich irgendwas macht.
So all diese ganzen Dinge. Ihr wisst ja, was mich so interessiert.
Das, da beiß ich dann schnell an.
Genau, und wenn es genug Hörerinnen und Hörer gibt, die sich melden,
dann mache ich auch ein Hörerinnen-Treffen in Kapstadt oder so. Weil, warum nicht?
Ja, aber vorher müssen wir ja noch Weihnachten abfeiern und wir schalten jetzt
zu unserem Weihnachtsgeschenksexperten, dem Ralf, der sozusagen von Konsum sowieso
nie genug bekommen kann.
Alles, was bei drei noch nicht gekauft wird, wird von ihm abgeräumt.
So sieht es auch aus, oder?
Verdammte Axt. Vor irgendwie drei Sendungen, als Huckel hier war und für die
große Messer-Folge hatten.
Da wurde uns nicht ganz zu Unrecht vorgeworfen, das sei ja doch alles eher so
ein Shopping-Kanal mittlerweile, die Freak-Show.
Ohne Affiliate-Links.
Wir hatten 10 oder 12 Produkte, die wir da gefeatured haben.
Seitdem versuche ich das in der Tat auch etwas zu reduzieren.
Wieso? Ich meine, das muss doch nicht kritisiert werden, das ist doch ein Feature.
Ja, aber dass man es nicht so übertreiben sollte, finde ich,
das kann ich schon nachvollziehen.
Die Sendung war schon massiv, aber ich glaube, da war auch wirklich viel Schönes
drin in dieser Sendung. Von daher stehe ich dazu, aber habe mich seitdem zurückgehalten.
Aber jetzt Weihnachten kommt plötzlich und unerwartet.
Und das ist jetzt so die Sendung, wo man noch Zeit hätte zu reagieren,
wenn man der Meinung ist, dass irgendwie dieses Gadget-Tool, was auch immer,
Unter dem Weihnachtsbaum gehört. Entweder für die Liebsten oder die Familie oder auch sich selber.
Ich finde es auch völlig legitim, sich selber zu Weihnachten zu beschenken.
Also das ganze Spektrum ist da.
Wir brauchen jetzt so einen Jingle. Ralfs Shopping-Ecke.
Du beschenkst dich doch das ganze Jahr.
Das ist alles selbstlos, um hier für die Hörerinnen und Hörer unkritische Produkttests.
Mir wurde echt Zeit meines Lebens noch nie irgendwas zugeschickt zur Testung.
Ja, ich habe noch nie irgendwas gekriegt.
Also ihr Firmen da draußen, kommt mal mit dem Hintern hoch oder weiß auch immer was.
Ich habe auch noch nicht.
Also Hörerinnen und Hörer schicken mir regelmäßig, aber schon mal ab und zu
irgendwie, wie die Shelly oder sowas, wo ich auch immer sehr dankbar drum bin,
weil ich das meistens dann immer genau gut brauche.
Aber so Bestechungsversuche hat es noch nie gegeben.
Vielleicht wissen die, dass ich Beamter bin und mich dann sofort strafbar mache.
Bei der Gelegenheit sollte ich mich noch über ein Buch bedanken und einen Kochtopf,
den ich geschickt bekommen habe von lieben Hörern.
Aber ich weiß jetzt natürlich nicht mehr, wie er heißt. Das tut mir fürchterlich
leid. Aber vielen Dank trotzdem.
Also ich hatte mal vor vielen, vielen Jahren einen Blog mit anderen Leuten zusammen
und da ging es um koffeinhaltige Erfrischungsgetränke für Hackerinnen und Hacker und Hackerbrause.
Das Blog gibt es mittlerweile nicht mehr Es ist ein Buch bei O'Reilly rausgekommen,
das auch vergriffen ist jetzt, aber da war auch die Motivation,
wir möchten gerne abgefahrene Brausen zugeschickt bekommen und das hat auch geklappt.
Das Blog ist weg Das Buch ist weg, aber den Podcast gibt es noch dazu Gibt es noch ein E-Book?
Ja, wahrscheinlich gibt es das auch noch als E-Book irgendwo Das reicht doch.
Da sollte man nochmal für sorgen. CAE Hackerbrausen.
CAE 175 von vor fast 15 Jahren.
Gott im Himmel.
Meine Herren, mich schockt das auch mal so ein bisschen.
Genau, mit dem Jetzt zusammen.
Mit dem Jetzt zusammen, genau. Das war eine schöne Sendung.
Wobei ich sagen muss, die bemerkenswerteste Sendung, die ich finde,
die wir je zusammen gemacht haben, war wirklich die über Internet-Meme.
Weil die war so, die kam so zeitig, dass, also wir haben diese Sendung gemacht,
da waren Internet-Meme einfach noch kein Mem.
Also da war das so in der Gesellschaft noch überhaupt nicht abgespeichert,
dass es sowas gibt und da haben wir dann schon irgendwie die Geschichte davon besprochen.
Und das fand ich super. Und das ist noch viel länger her, nämlich,
2009.
Manchmal bin ich so ein Proto-Hipster.
16 Jahre. Du bist auf jeden Fall immer dem Zahn der Zeit auf der Spur.
So, genug geworben hier für die eigenen Produkte.
Okay, dann lege ich mal los.
Darfst du jetzt mal loslegen, was kriege ich denn?
Sag mal Tim, wie putzt du eigentlich deine Brille?
Mit einem Ultraschallreiniger, wie denn sonst.
Okay, den hast du ja aber nicht immer dabei, was machst du dann?
Mit einem Brillentuch, Mikrofaser.
Mit einem, okay. Also ich bin
hier übrigens jetzt im Studio mit drei Brillenträgern. Das nochmal dazu.
Brillentäter.
Was habt ihr für Tools, um eure Brillen zu?
T-Shirt.
Nichts, was so rumfliegt.
Jetzt nimmt es einfach hin und verschließt die Augen vor der Realität.
Nee, T-Shirt oder Hoodie oder was man halt so anhat.
Also ich bin jetzt leider in einem Alter, wo jetzt auch hier meine Altersweitsicht
eintritt und ich jetzt also auch eine Lesebrille brauche für viele Szenarien.
Batteriebetriebene, mobiles Ultraschallreinigungsgerät.
Nein, das nicht. Es ist etwas simpler. Das habe ich bei einem Kollegen gesehen,
das Tool, was ich jetzt hier mal überreiche.
Und zwar den Pocket Cleaner.
Ein Pocket Cleaner.
Der reinigt auch noch die die Fosentasche.
Von Polyclean. Also wir beschreiben mal für die Hörerinnen und Hörer,
was wir jetzt hier gerade nicht sehen.
Also du hast hier ein softes, rechteckiges Ding in der Größe eines.
Tja, halbe Visitenkarte würde ich sagen.
Halbe Visitenkarte trifft es ganz gut in einem Plastikgehäuse,
wo man es rausschieben kann und dann klappt es sich auf und dann ist es eine
etwas längliche Visitenkarte und es ist so ein softes Material, so ein bisschen wie Wie.
So ein Schwamm?
Wie so ein,
Weiß ich nicht. Das ist bestimmt Mikrofaser.
Ja, ich glaube früher hat man da Kunstleder zu gesagt, jetzt heißt es ja veganes Leder.
Genau, es hat zwei Seiten. Die äußere bedruckte farbige hat ein bisschen mehr
Grip, damit man die Finger gut Halt finden und die innere Seite,
mit der man putzt, ist also so schwarz.
Und der Clou ist also, dass man damit halt beide Seiten eines Brillenglases
gleichzeitig putzen kann, ohne irgendwo was festhalten zu müssen.
Okay, gucken wir mal, wie das hier performt.
Das ist also so ein Spezialstoff.
Also von der Haptik her muss ich sagen, ist schon mal ganz okay.
Also das funktioniert auf jeden Fall.
Also meine Brille ist jetzt nicht schmutzig genug, als dass ich das wage.
Aber danach...
Das Gefühl, dass sie da eher schmutziger wird von...
Also meine, es ist immer schmutzig und es funktioniert schon.
Das ist besser als vorher.
Also es putzt halt. Also am Ende ist es dann mal doch irgendwie so Physik und
Oberfläche und Glas und Dinge passieren. Muss man wissen. Ja, genau.
Muss man wissen.
Wusstet ihr übrigens, dass ich der Letzte bin, der Stoll fotografiert hat?
Habe ich das schon mal erzählt in der Sendung?
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das in der Sendung erzählt hast oder hast es mir irgendwann schon mal erzählt.
Aber ich habe es auch schon wieder vergessen. Du darfst es gerne kurz einwerfen. Axel Stoll.
Genau, wie hieß der Vogel noch mit Vornamen? Dr. Axel Stoll.
Axel Stoll hieß der.
Ja. War das ein Doktor?
Der war Doktor, ja, das war ja das Absurde.
Und das war kein Fake?
Das war kein Fake, nee. Er hat eine echte Promotion gemacht in auch irgendwas
Physikalisches damals.
Sein Verschwörungstheoretiker vor dem Herrn.
Genau. und das ist der, der dann also irgendwie mit den Nazi-Flugscheiben und
Neuschwanland und diesen ganzen Kram und der hatte dann hier in Berlin auch
irgendwie so eine Gefolgschaft und hat dann also immer Reden vor denen geschwungen und,
hat dann so ein paar Kernsätze immer so wie muss man wissen und so drin gehabt.
Der war also schon irgendwie auch so ein, hatte sowas Kultfigurartiges und Hoaxilla,
den Podcast gibt es ja auch immer noch, die haben,
dann eine Sendung über ihn gemacht und dann hatten sie beschlossen,
okay, der ist irgendwie so interessant und spannend, dass wir sogar ein ganzes
Buch machen. Hier, Bartosz war noch mit dabei.
Sebastian Bartoszek.
Genau, Sebastian Bartoszek. Grüße. Und die beiden haben ihn dann also interviewt
und haben mich angeheuert, das Ganze gleichzeitig zu filmen und zu fotografieren.
Weil sie wussten, dass ich so ein bisschen Fotokrams halt irgendwie mache und
sonst ist ihnen irgendwie keiner eingefallen, dem sie zutrauten.
Du hast es auch noch gefilmt.
Es gibt auch Filmaufnahmen.
Ich müsste sagen, der Kameramann von einem Interview mit Dr. Axel Stoll, der Film.
Exakt.
Wow.
Ja, ich stehe da sogar auch namentlich erwähnt. Und in dem Kontext habe ich gesagt.
Die Leni Riefenstahl des YouTube-Seite-Alters.
Ja, irgendwie schon. So wie du es jetzt sagst, hört sich gar nicht mehr so cool an.
So, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, habe ich die Bilder sogar auf Flickr hochgeladen.
Aber ich glaube, in den geschützten Bereich, weil ich nicht wollte,
dass dann da Nazi-Horden sich irgendwo, weil das war halt auch alles rechtslastig.
Also alles schon eine sehr, sehr schwierige Figur.
Aber irgendwie, ich glaube, ein Jahr später oder knapp ein Jahr später war er tot.
Ich filmst du nicht. Jetzt muss ich gucken.
Ob ich an die Bilder noch reingucken.
Das ist das Beginn einer Straftat.
Aber ich habe dann halt Bilder von ihm gemacht, wo er dann diese typische Lederkluft
hat und diesen Lederhut und so.
Also schon sein ikonisches Auftreten, was er da kultiviert hat. Wie auch immer.
Wie sind wir denn da jetzt überhaupt drauf gekommen? Ach ja, wegen muss man wissen.
Genau.
Das war so sein Spruch immer. Deswegen, das war die Brücke.
Ja. Ist Physik, muss man wissen.
Weihnachten.
Genau, also diese Brillentücher, die sind wohl vor allen Dingen im Umlauf von
dieser Firma als Werbegeschenke.
Das heißt also, der eigentliche Use Case für die ist, dass du die also außen
bedruckst mit deinem Firmenlogo und dann als irgendwie nützlicheres Giveaway
hast als Kugelschreiber und ähnliches.
Und die habe ich halt beim Kollegen gesehen und dachte mir, oh die putzen aber
wirklich schön und kosten halt irgendwie vier Euro oder sowas.
Und da dachte ich, das bringen wir doch mal mit.
So, für die nächste Sache machen wir mal was.
Hat Apple nicht auch so ein Brillenputztuch im Angebot für irgendwie 35 Euro oder so?
Nicht Brille, aber was haben die, Putztücher hatten die mal?
Für iPads oder sowas? Nein, für ihre besonders delikaten Beschichtungen von Displays.
Oleophobik.
Nee, ich glaube, das war es nicht sondern diese spezielle Entspiegelung die
sie da haben dafür haben sie das glaube ich rausgebracht.
Gab es früher mal dazu aber inzwischen kriegt man ja nicht mal ein Netzteil.
Ist glaube ich auch nur irgendwie ein Mikrofasertuch was irgendwie,
weiß ich nicht besonders hübsches steht.
Aber es gab ja auch mal iPod-Socken.
Ja und jetzt gibt es auch iPhone-Mankinis gibt es jetzt auch.
Mankinis.
Das hast du nicht mitbekommen, ist nicht dein Ernst.
Dieses Schulterband.
Ja, genau. Aber das sieht halt aus wie ein Mankini. Du weißt, was ein Mankini ist.
Ja, so ein... Was da dieser Typ, dieser Cohen, wie hieß er?
Genau, der Cohen.
Getragen hat.
Ja, also der Vergleich.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass ich das sehr schnell finde. Und genau.
Wir gleiten schon wieder ab.
Oh, da war was.
Borat, genau.
Borat. Sie haben halt irgendwie so eine merkwürdige,
komische Socke für 250 Dollar rausgebracht in begrenzter Form.
Also es ist einfach so eine gestrickte Bag, wo man so sein iPhone unten reintun
kann und dann kann man sich das so umhängen.
Gott.
Damit man das, weiß ich nicht, irgendwie fashionmäßig tragen kann.
ich verstehe diese ganze Fashion-Industrie auch nicht und es sieht halt sehr
ähnlich aus wie der Man-Kini, den halt Borat so gebracht hat.
Naja, so eine Sachen halt.
Entschuldigung, dass ich wieder mal vom Thema abgekommen bin.
Sowas soll uns ja hier nie passieren eigentlich.
Vom Thema abkommen.
Ja.
Ja, dann übernehme ich doch mal wieder. So.
Wie rollt ihr denn eigentlich eure Kabel auf?
Sagen wir mal so ein USB-C-Kabel, um das irgendwo zu verstauen,
zum Beispiel in einem Rucksack.
Normalerweise rolle ich das auf und tue es dann in eine kleine Plastiktüte.
Ja, also ein Meshback.
Nicht unbedingt ein Meshback, kann auch ein normales kleines Plastiktütchen
sein, weil nur Kabel, die voneinander tatsächlich getrennt sind,
sich nicht verwickeln ineinander.
Deswegen kommt jedes Kabel in sein eigenes Tütchen und dann kommen die alle
zusammen in ein Meshback.
Das passt.
Wie wäre es, wenn ich euch sage, dass eine der magischsten Kräfte dieses Planeten
uns helfen könnten, Kabel vernünftig zu verstauen?
Gravitation?
Magnete?
Magnetismus. Jetzt schaut, was ich hochhalte.
Ein magnetisches Kabel?
Das ist ein magnetisches Flachband-USB-C-Kabel, was sich quasi selber aufrollt
durch die Macht des Magneten.
Hattest du nicht neulich irgendwie diese Pressekonferenz, wo Trump irgendwie
über Magnetismus und das ist auch so eine geheimnisvolle Kraft.
Niemand versteht sie, gerambled hat?
Also auf die Idee bin ich wirklich selber gekommen, als ich irgendwann mal nachts
wieder nichts zu tun hatte und dachte so, warum ist das mit diesen Kabeln immer so scheiße?
Warum kann man nicht mal was erfinden und wie wäre es denn eigentlich,
wenn die sich irgendwie magnetisch zusammenfalten würden? Das ist total toll.
Einmal auf Amazon geguckt und sofort gefunden.
Gibt es also offensichtlich auch schon seit längerem, aber habe ich noch nie irgendwo gesehen.
Also beschreiben wir nochmal genauer, was es ist. Es ist also jetzt ein erstmal
stinknormales USB-C-Kabel, ich glaube anderthalb Meter in dem Fall hier.
Etwas flacher mit so einer Art.
Genau, es ist ein Flachbandkabel. Es ist also kein rundes, kein runden Querschnitt,
wie man das ansonsten eigentlich immer hat.
Ein Flachbandkabel würde ich es jetzt nicht nennen, aber es ist zumindest ein bisschen flacher.
Also ich glaube, innen drin ist es sehr flach. Es hat halt eine zusätzliche
Ummantelung und die ist halt magnetisch, wo die eine Seite halt quasi positiv
und die andere negativ geladen ist, sodass es sich auch nur in eine Richtung sinnvoll aufwickelt.
Und jetzt kann man das dann also, wie so eine Schnecke, rollt es sich dann also zusammen.
Nicht wirklich selber, aber man muss also nicht viel dazu tun,
dass es sich also vernünftig rollt und kann es einfach schnell drehen.
Schon toll.
Und bleibt jetzt einfach mal in
dieser Form, auch wenn ich es irgendwo reinschmeiße und wieder heraushole.
Jetzt hätte ich gerne die Fluxfolie dabei, die ich neulich bestellt habe.
Weißt du, was eine Fluxfolie ist?
Eine Fluxfolie ist eine Folie, da sind magnetische Partikel drin und wenn man
die auf irgendwas drauf tut, was Magnete enthält,
kannst du sehr schön sehen, wo sind die Magnete und in welche Richtung sind
die ausgerichtet und die könnte man jetzt schön über das Kabel tun und gucken,
was da tatsächlich drin ist.
Wahrscheinlich sind da nämlich nur in regelmäßigen Abständen oder so kleine Magnete verbaut.
Genau, also ich habe auch so ein paar Fragen, was dieses Kabel angeht.
Also das Erste ist, es ist erstmal schwer.
Das heißt, man erkauft sich einfach diese zusätzliche Funktionalität damit,
dass es locker doppelt so schwer ist wie ein normales USB-C-Kabel.
Genau, irgendwo muss es halt herkommen.
Sagt man doch schwer oder sagt man schon wertig?
Ja, schwertig.
So, und damit einher geht natürlich so ein bisschen so ein Grundmisstrauen bei mir.
Okay, wie schlau ist es jetzt also bei einem elektrischen Kabel wirklich mit
Magneten in direkter Umgebung irgendwie zu operieren?
So, Rodin nimmt es jetzt, guckt, ob sich das auch als Armband eignet und rollt es sich jetzt.
Als modisches Accessoire.
Modisches Accessoire, genau.
Jetzt sieht es so aus wie dieses Teil, was diese merkwürdige Frau in dem einen Spiel umhat. irgendwas.
Und, also ich nehme es auch wirklich dezidiert nur als Stromkabel,
nicht um da jetzt irgendwie Daten rüber zu schicken, aber ich vermute,
die Fehlerkorrektur würde das auch alles irgendwie ausbügeln,
ansonsten könnte man es wahrscheinlich nicht verkaufen.
Aber fand ich also als Proof of Concept erstmal spannend und das ist jetzt so
mein USB-C-Kabel, was ich einfach immer bei mir in der Tasche habe.
Also auch dieses Kabel kann man so verheddern.
Dass man… Ah, jetzt fängt Timmel gleich an zu messen hier.
Ja, ich habe leider nicht den USB-C-Tester gefunden, den ich jetzt eigentlich
gerade haben wollte. Und ich habe jetzt nur einen gefunden, von dem ich gar
nicht weiß, ob er funktioniert.
Der hier in der Sendung von einem Hörer empfohlen wurde. Den habe ich nämlich
auch gekauft und der ist echt super.
Nee, das ist noch ein anderer, den ich irgendwie beim Aufräumen gefunden habe.
Und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, ob der jetzt das macht,
was ich denke, was er tut.
Nee.
Also ich fand jetzt bei beiden Produkten, der Chat hat das auch schon gesagt,
die haben so einen Vibe von TikTok-Werbung.
Wo man dann irgendwie diese Produkte sieht, die ganz liebevoll in China von,
Menschen zusammengestellt werden und man denkt dann erst mal,
was für eine geile Idee und dann aber ein paar Minuten später Was.
Für ein Scheiß.
Ja, denkt man sich ja. Vielleicht brauche ich das doch nicht so dringend,
wie ich gerade gedacht habe.
Ja, das mag durchaus passieren.
Was Frevel?
Im Teleshopping-Kanal ist das egal, da geht es ja auch ums Gefühl.
Genau. So, apropos Gefühl.
Seitdem Seid ihr bereit für die nächste Eskalationsstufe?
Aber selbstverständlich.
Da muss ich nämlich jetzt erstmal meine Hose aufknüpfen.
Oh Gott.
Für das nächste Toy.
Also das in Sachen Eskalationsstufe.
Ich bin geblendet.
So.
Habt ihr sowas hier schon mal gesehen? Wisst ihr, was das hier ist?
Ein Gürtel.
Aber es ist nicht irgendein Gürtel.
Es ist dein Gürtel.
Es ist mein Gürtel, das zeichnet ihn schon mal aus.
Ja, das stimmt.
So, aber was siehst du noch, wenn du dir diesen Gürtel anschaust?
Ich sehe eine Rasterapplikation an der Innenseite der Spitze, die man einführt.
Und ich würde mal vermuten, das ist so ein sehr fein einstellbarer Gürtel,
der nicht so diese typische Lochabstandauflösung hat, sondern hier von diesen
kleinen Rasten, die schon so ein bisschen abgewetzt aussehen, ehrlich gesagt.
Also es ist so ein typischer erwachsener Ledergürtel.
Der reagiert auf jeden Bar.
Aber er hat überhaupt keine Löcher.
Er hat keine Löcher.
Und man kann dann so, warte mal, ich mach das mal hier schön am Mikrofon.
Das ist ein beruhigenden Schnapp, Schnapp, Schnapp.
Das muss ich nur noch gucken, wo der Release-Button ist. Ah, hier an der Seite.
Genau, da so oben. Den musst du nach oben.
Den Pin-Nüppeln.
Und wo ist jetzt der USB-C-Port an dem Ding?
Der ist ja gar nicht magnetisch hier.
Aber es hat was...
Schon so ein bisschen befriedigend, dieser Sound. Geht gut.
Irgendwann hört es auf zu schnappen.
Genau, irgendwann ist die Rasterung halt durch.
Dann hast du zu sehr gefasst.
Darfst du wieder anfangen zu essen.
Also womit wir es hier zu tun haben, ist ein sogenannter Ratschengürtel.
Bis vor anderthalb Jahren wusste ich nicht, dass so etwas existiert.
Aber dafür haben wir ja jetzt hier diese Sendung.
Und jetzt macht den nicht kaputt da. Das ist die andere Seite.
Und dieses Prinzip ist also auch nicht jetzt wirklich irgendwie revolutionär
neu und es gibt irgendwie 30.000 Firmen, die den in unterschiedlichen Qualitätsstufen produzieren.
Und der hat halt so ein, zwei Vorzüge, die ich schon irgendwie jetzt nach,
ich habe den jetzt also über ein Jahr, zwei Stück davon und ich feiere das nach wie vor sehr,
weil du musst halt nicht immer, um die Hose an und aus zu ziehen,
den kompletten Gürtel halt aufmachen und beim Klogang und sowas,
sondern du machst ihn einfach nur etwas weiter,
indem du eben diesen Release-Button drückst, ihn etwas weitest,
aber er bleibt ansonsten in sich geschlossen.
Fällt nicht runter, plöddert nicht irgendwo gegen und dann, wenn was auch immer Hose gewechselt ist,
machst du mit einer einzigen Bewegung wieder Ratsch und dann ist er wieder exakt
auf deiner derzeit sich befindlichen Bauchbreite ohne irgendwelche fehlenden Zwischenschritte.
Das ist der Gürtel, den du hier jetzt auch in Chat gestellt hast von der Firma Beltimore.
Das ist jetzt ein Beispiel, den ich da habe. Ich glaube, den hier,
den gibt es so schon gar nicht mehr, weil das jetzt auch so ein Prinzip ist,
wo so wieder diese China-Buden im Wochentakt denen irgendwie anbieten und dann wieder wer anders.
Aber da kann man sich dann sicherlich, wenn einem das Prinzip interessiert,
mal reinnerden und gucken, welche Firma da vielleicht etwas seriöser und Bestand hat.
Also Beltimore finde ich als Gürtelfirmenname schon stark.
Das ist mindestens eine 5 auf der nach oben offenen Friseurnamen.
Ein Kabelbinder als Gürtel, ja, genau so ähnlich.
Aber den man auch wieder aufkriegt.
Und man muss halt sagen, von der Haltbarkeit her ist das halt erstmal eine gute
Idee, weil das kennt man da ja vielleicht schon von einem normalen Ledergürtel,
dass so um die meist benutztesten Löcher, und meistens sind es dann ja eben
irgendwie ein bis zwei, zwischen denen man so hin und her oszilliert.
Die leiern dann eben doch relativ zügig irgendwie aus.
Und nach einem halben, dreiviertel Jahr, Jahr oder sowas ist der Gürtel dann
halt, normaler Gürtel, schon doch relativ runtergerockt.
Nicht so dieses Modell, weil also da quasi das Ganze sich irgendwo dran festklammern
auf der Innenseite passiert.
Und das halt irgendwie mit dieser Plastikverstärkung ist, hat er von draußen
quasi keine sich abnutzenden, sichtbaren Teile.
Hast du gerade gesagt, nach einem halben Jahr ist ein Gürtel abgerockt?
Wie benutzt du deine Gürtel?
Ich finde das jetzt auch ein bisschen pessimistisch, die Ausblicke.
Ich trage meine Gürtel deutlich länger.
Wenn du welche mit normalen Löchern hast, dann sind sie halt entweder immer
ein bisschen zu eng oder ein bisschen zu weit per Definition.
Es ist halt nicht, wie war das mit diskret versus digital?
Vor allem, wenn man mal eben so ein bisschen Platz für den Burger schaffen will,
musst du ja sozusagen nur einmal kurz drücken und nicht einmal öffnen und wieder
schließen. Das sehe ich durchaus als Vorteil.
Es geht super schnell.
Probiert das mal aus.
Das ist in der Tat eine interessante Produktkategorie. Da war ich mir auch noch
nicht darüber im Klaren, dass es die gibt.
Aber die gibt es tatsächlich auch in allen acht buchstabigen Kombinationen von
Markennamen, die sich die Chinesen gerade einfallen lassen.
Der große China-Namenswürfel hat
zugeschlagen. Früher hatte ich so einen Koppelgürtel von der Volksarmee,
hier von der Ostarmee, der war auch stufenlos und der hatte einfach nur einen
Haken, wo man ihn eingehängt hat.
Und dann war er eingehängt und wenn man ihn aushängen wollte, hat man ihn ausgehängt.
Passiert es irgendwie, dass man an diesen Öffnungsmechanismus so rankommt,
wenn man so sitzt oder so? Nee, gar nicht.
Der ist also so ein bisschen fizzelig sogar, würde ich sagen.
Das mag aber sein, dass da andere Modelle noch elaborierter sind.
Also ich habe zwei von unterschiedlichen Herstellern, die aber glaube ich exakt
dasselbe Grundpatent irgendwie bedienen.
Also die sind glaube ich bis auf den Millimeter gleich gebaut von einer Verschlussmechanik her.
Da kommst du nie aus Versehen irgendwie gegen, dass man da zu peinlichen Momenten und so passiert nicht.
Und denkst du, dass die Flower Power Enterprises Klonengürtel schlechter sind als dein...
In Anführungsstrichen Markenprodukt?
Ich habe mit Sicherheit so einen Klon. Ich habe die damals irgendwie auch ohne
viel denken. Also das sind Sachen.
Die kriege ich immer im...
Das war nur einer, wo das Prinzip fand ich jetzt gut erklärt wird,
dass man es vernünftig für die Shownotes nachvollziehen kann.
Ich habe dieses Produkt nicht.
Aber es sieht auch wiederum von einem Verschluss quasi pixelidentisch aus zu dem, was ich habe.
Denke ich, wird das schon alles dasselbe sein.
Die kaufen auch nur in China ein. Alright. Das ist gut.
So, jetzt habe ich noch zwei. Weihnachten ist ja auch das Fest der Kinder und
der Familie und sowas. Und von daher habe ich jetzt noch zwei Spiele.
Zum einen das vielleicht irgendwie älteste und populärste Spiel der Welt, nämlich Schach.
Und da war ich lange auf der Suche nach...
Jetzt neu. Jetzt neu.
Du wirst lachen. Erkennst du hier, was der Magnussen gerade promotet?
Magnus Carlsen meinst du?
Genau, Magnus Carlsen, dieses Schach 801 oder sowas.
Extreme Schach, da gibt es ja irgendwie diverse... Chess Unlimited,
ich weiß gar nicht wie der jetzt...
360.
360, ja, kann schon sein.
Der ehemalige Schachweltmeister und angeblich, oder vermute ich auch wirklich,
der beste jemals lebende Schachspieler.
960, Entschuldigung.
Nein, 960.
960, genau.
Kann ich gleich erzählen, wo dieser Name herkommt. Der hat irgendwann so vor, ich glaube, drei,
vier Jahren ist es auch schon her, das Statement rausgegeben,
so ein klassisches Schach, das langweilt ihn nur noch, weil es nur noch darum
geht, wer mehr Eröffnung irgendwie auswendig lernen kann und mehr Grundpositionen
halt irgendwie beherrscht. Und...
Hat sich dann also auf diese neue Schachvariante kapriziert,
die so funktioniert, dass die Bauern stehen da, wo sie vorher auch stehen,
aber wo die ganzen anderen Figuren stehen, das wird quasi vor jedem Spiel per
Zufallsgenerator ausgewürfelt.
Und beide Kontrahenten haben also dann dieselbe Aufstellung auf der Grundlinie,
natürlich auch mit denselben Figuren, aber du weißt halt vorher nicht,
wie die zusammengemixt sind.
Es gibt genau 960 mögliche Kombinationen.
Es sind jetzt nicht alle rein mathematisch möglichen Kombinationen,
weil ein paar Kombinationen werden ausgeschlossen, schlicht deswegen,
weil noch eine Rochade möglich sein soll.
Das heißt, der König muss zwischen den Türmen stehen und ich weiß gar nicht,
ob es noch irgendwelche Mindestabstände gibt.
Auf jeden Fall ist das so im Wesentlichen der Constraint, der da drin ist.
Und das ist natürlich insofern sehr interessant, als dass Freestyle-Chez quasi
von der ersten Sekunde an die meisten Spieler vor...
Also anders gesagt, man kann sich nicht, wie man das im klassischen Schach eben
macht, auf bestimmte Eröffnungen einschießen.
Üblicherweise studiert man ja seine Gegner, wenn man die Zeit hat und weiß,
wer einem zugelost wird.
Je nach Turnier ist das ja, weiß man das, früher oder später.
Und dann kann man halt sagen, okay, gut, hier, die eröffnet immer mit Damenbauern
und spielt gerne das und all diese Geschichten.
Und das ist natürlich alles komplett über den Haufen geworfen und man muss ganz
neue Strategien machen.
Und das ist sowohl für die Spieler als auch eben für die Zuschauer super interessant,
weil du eben nicht so, ja okay, jetzt die ersten zehn Züge und dann,
das wurde jetzt schon so und so viele Millionen Mal gespielt und 30 Prozent
der Leute haben in dieser Stellung dann irgendwie das und das gemacht.
Ja, ich habe mir das auch schon mehrfach angeschaut und diese Freestyle-Chess-Sachen sind super spannend.
Und es ist halt trotzdem fair, weil beide halt mit derselben Startaufstellung dann unterwegs sind.
Es ist dann nicht so, dass es für jeden ausgelost wäre, dass wir dann schon sehr unfair...
Ich hoffe, du hast ja jetzt nicht ein Freestyle-Chess-Schachset kaufen.
Das stand da drauf, Tim, dass das extra dafür geeignet ist.
Oder hat es einfach nur dein Interesse am Schachspiel wieder neu entflammen lassen?
Also das Interesse ans Schachspiel hat in der Tat gesagt, darauf wäre ich nämlich
zu Recht in den Kommentaren hingewiesen, dass das eine Floskel ist,
die ich viel zu häufig verwende. Ich globe Besserung.
Also Schach spiele ich wieder gerne seit The Queen's Gambit.
Ja, wie der Rest der Welt auch, ja.
Ja, also hier Serie mit der, wie heißt sie?
Serie? Achso, das ist noch als Serie.
Das ist eine Miniserie, also ich glaube fünf Folgen oder sowas.
Das gibt es ja vor allem als Film, richtig, ne?
Äh, nein. Das ist eine Netflix-Miniserie. Das gibt es nicht als Film.
Doch, klar.
Nee.
Natürlich. Habe ich ja gesehen.
Haben sie das zusammengeschnitten? Nein. Also IMDb sagt auch TV-Miniseries.
Also vielleicht hast du die gebinge-watcht, aber es ist kein Film, es ist eine Serie.
Was?
Ja, es ist eine kleine Serie. Spielt hauptsächlich in Fredriksheim.
Richtig. Man kann sich die Locations angucken dazu.
Also für mich soll in den USA spielen und dann später in Moskau und so,
aber man erkennt schon die Wunderwelt der deutschen Filmförderung sehr gut,
wie die Museumsinsel dann plötzlich
Paris sein soll und der Park mit den schachspielenden Russen ist.
Hier die Dingens Allee.
Allee, genau.
Was ist das? Frankfurter?
Frankfurter Allee, genau.
Ich bin sicher aber ein bisschen schockiert. Ich habe das doch als Film gesehen.
Wie gesagt, kann nicht sein, aber macht ja auch nichts.
Wie das kann nicht sein?
Ja, also warum solltest du eine Miniserie von fünf Folgen, die es schon hat,
noch in den Film kompaktieren?
Das macht keinen Sinn. Was willst du denn da streichen?
Dann habe ich das irgendwie in einem Zusammenschnitt gesehen,
wo das einfach hintereinander lief und keiner hat mir Bescheid gesagt.
Jetzt bin ich aber ein bisschen überrascht.
Oder vielleicht hast du stattdessen von Schnitzler die Schach-Novelle gesehen
und verwisselst du das gerade?
Das war schon hier Beth Harmon und so weiter.
Ist ja krass. Ich bin ein bisschen überrascht.
Sieben Folgen? Okay, schreibt sie gerade sogar in den Chat. Also nicht fünf,
sondern sieben. Also schon einiges. Okay, wie dem auch sei.
So, seitdem interessiere ich mich wie andere auch wieder für Schach und versuche
das auch meinen Kindern nahe zu bringen.
Wichtig ist, egal wo du bist, gerade im Urlaub willst du eben ein Schachspiel dabei haben.
Wie ist dir denn das gelungen? Ich habe das ja seit Jahren lang probiert.
Meinen Kindern Schachspielen beizubringen?
Also ich hätte es ihnen ja gerne beigebracht, aber es gab einfach keinerlei Resonanz.
Ich sage ja nicht, dass es mir geglückt ist.
Du hast es probiert.
Ich habe auch probiert. Nur gesagt, ich habe mich aufgestafft mit Hardware.
Das hat mich extrem geärgert.
Weil es ist halt einfach, ich meine, wann hast du Schach gelernt?
Da war ich vielleicht so acht, würde ich sagen, dass mein Papa mir das beigebracht
hat und irgendwann wollte er nicht mehr gegen mich spielen, weil er Angst hatte,
gegen mich zu verlieren und es war eben so ein wichtiges Ego-Ding,
dass er in seinem Leben keine Partie gegen seinen Sohn verliert. Arschloch.
Ja, das geht ja nun gar nicht. Du wolltest nicht spielen Schach?
Nicht wirklich.
Hast du es mal gespielt?
Ja, naja, man lernt halt irgendwann als Kind Schach spielen.
Aber das hat dich nicht fasziniert oder so?
Nicht so richtig, nee.
Also ich fand es super.
Ich habe auch mal Schach gelernt. Hat mich nicht so super gefesselt,
wo ich wirklich extrem viel Zeit drauf geschmissen habe und was lange Zeit halt
wirklich auch, dass ich da Formen gesehen habe, mein ganzes Denken ging darum und so.
Das ist Go. Das ist nämlich tatsächlich das älteste noch heute gespielte Brettspiel
mit unveränderten Regeln.
Das ist bei Schach alles ein bisschen anders. Da gibt es ja auch Schach-Varianten.
Ich fand immer ganz witzig eigentlich diese chinesische Variante von Schach, Changi.
Und da gibt es so tolle Figuren wie die Kanone und den Elefanten und sowas.
Wer mal ein ganz anderes Schacherlebnis haben will, der kann mal Changi spielen.
Und ja, Go, Baduk, Weiji, wie immer man es dann nennen möchte,
fand ich einfach witzig.
Das ist total toll. Ich habe auch damals irgendwie mir einen Wecker gestellt,
als dieses Spiel, wie heißt er?
Deep Blue gegen...
Deep Mind. Deep Blue heißt er, gegen Isidol, den damals besten...
Go-Spieler der Welt.
Den damals besten Go-Spieler der Welt, der dann nach dem Turnier auch aufgehört
hat. Er hat gesagt, die Freude ist ihm geraubt.
Alles, was er bisher mit dem Spiel gemacht hat, das sieht er jetzt nicht mehr.
Und das hat auch zu extremen Veränderungen in der professionellen Go-Spieler-Welt,
zumindest in Korea, geführt.
Die Leute versuchen jetzt mittlerweile, als Menschen mehr wie KI zu spielen.
Und ob das alles irgendwie so toll ist, weiß ich nicht.
Das ist interessant. Wenn wir uns irgendwann mal nochmal über den Weg laufen,
müssen wir mal Go spielen. Weil ich habe ein sehr schönes Go-Brett zu Hause
von meiner lieben Frau geschenkt bekommen und ich kapiere die Regeln nicht.
Und ich glaube, dass es nicht daran liegt, dass ich da grundsätzlich zu blöd
für bin, sondern ich behaupte, die Regeln sind nicht vernünftig hier geschrieben.
Ich habe ständig Situationen, in denen ich mich frage, ist das jetzt hier gerade erlaubt oder nicht?
Und dann recherchiere ich eine halbe Stunde im Internet und ich finde nicht
die Antwort auf diese Situationsfragen, die ich da habe. Und ich denke, wie kann das sein?
Also irgendwo ist da ein Knoten in meinem Kopf.
Der… Also die Regeln sind sehr überschaubar und auch schnell erklärt.
Und wir können uns da gerne mal zusammensetzen.
Also mein ältester spielt sehr gerne Go und der hat tatsächlich vor der Pandemie
auch schon in seiner Altersklasse irgendwie als Berlins Bester abgeschnitten
in irgendeinem Turnier.
Also, aber für mich, keine Ahnung, ich habe es noch nie gespielt.
AlphaGo hieß es, nee, nicht die Blue, das war glaube ich, war das nicht der,
der gegen den Schachgurzmeister gewundert hat?
Ja, stimmt. Und AlphaGo war auch schon ein erstes, was mit Machine Learning
gegen sich selber trainiert hat, wenn ich das richtig entsinne.
Also das war noch kein neuronales Netz, so wie wir es jetzt kennen,
aber da war schon Machine Learning am Start. War das ein Neuronales schon?
Ja, es war aber auch irgendwie eine riesige Datenabfrage. Also die hatten so in Hardware gegossen,
eine Zuganalyse und solche und haben dann quasi aus einer Datenbank dann die
Zuganalyse immer wieder rausgezogen und haben da extrem hinoptimiert.
Ja, es gab noch irgendeinen Step zu dem aktuellen, was wir so als Machine Learning
in dem Bereich verstehen, aber es klingt jetzt auch nicht mehr ganz zusammen.
Nee, es war nicht das, was man heutzutage als normales Netz bezeichnet.
Bevor du aufschwingst zu deinem Schachspiel, muss ich natürlich auch noch meine
Schachgeschichte erzählen.
War Machine Learning? Gibt es auch eine total tolle Netflix-Doku?
Dass das Machine Learning ist, ist schon klar. Aber ich meine,
es war jetzt nicht so ein All-you-need-is-Attention-Layer-Ansatz, wie wir es jetzt...
Das war vor diesem Paper.
Ja, es war jetzt nicht LLM. Das ist ein klassisches Machine Learning.
Ja, Schach hat mich ja tief geprägt in meinem Leben mehr so als Sozialflucht
tatsächlich, weil ich habe in meiner Jugend die bemerkenswerte Karrierensprung
gemacht, dass ich von einem Fußballverein zu einem Schachverein gewechselt habe.
Nicht unbedingt das, was man typischerweise so in einer Fußballerkarriere so
anstrebt, aber das war für mich irgendwie interessanter.
Damals, ich habe ja später gemerkt, warum, ich wollte halt unbedingt mal unter Nerds sein.
Also ich fand das so wie ganz angenehm mit so Leuten zu interagieren,
die so alles so mit dem Kopf machen und tatsächlich war ein Schachcomputer mein erster Computer.
Okay, in meiner glaube ich auch.
Der Chess-Champion MK2.
Der hat immer so lustig, der hatte immer quasi für jeden Zug eine Tonehöhe.
Das war lustig. Er hat immer so lustig Musik gefiedelt.
Aber Schach hat mir sozusagen diese Computer-Interaktion und ich und die Maschine,
das war sozusagen mit diesem Schach-Computer das erste Mal, dass ich das so
gespürt habe, noch weit bevor es Home-Computer gab.
Aber hattest du nicht schon irgendwie so eine Computer-Uhr auch vor so ein,
zwei Spielen drauf liefen oder sowas?
Ich glaube, das war bei mir noch eher so eine Casio mit irgendwie Weltraumspiel oder so.
Casio mit einem Weltraumspiel zu der Zeit?
Weltraumschach?
Ich suche mal hier kurz meinen Computer raus, da ist er hier,
Chess Champion Supersystem, warte mal, ja doch, das muss der sein,
ich schmeiß das mal hier kurz,
also wir reden von Ende der 70er Jahre, ne?
Ne, so sah meiner nicht aus.
Sowas hatte ich nicht. Ich hatte nur dieses Basismodell, ich sehe gerade,
man konnte das noch ausbauen hier sozusagen, sogar noch mit einem Schach-Display,
ist ja interessant, das war mir noch gar nicht klar, dass es das gab.
Ja, aber ich habe da so meine Züge eingetippsert und mir wurde das durch so
ein einfaches LCD zurückkommuniziert.
War jetzt nicht besonders spielstark, das System, aber es hat mich einfach total
fasziniert. Und das waren eigentlich so meine ersten Terminal-Sessions.
Von daher mochte ich Schach schon immer. Ich war jetzt kein ambitionierter Schachspieler,
aber ja, ich finde irgendwie, meine Kinder könnten sich trotzdem nochmal für Schacher werden.
Ja. Also ich fand Schach immer sehr cool, hab das eigentlich immer gerne gespielt
und bin aber irgendwann in dieses Loch reingefallen, was in Queen's Gambit auch gut beschrieben wird.
Irgendwann merkst du, du kommst jetzt mit Denken nicht mehr weiter,
sondern jetzt hilft nur noch trainieren und vor allen Dingen viel auswendig lernen.
und das war irgendwie so diese Ebene,
ich weiß gar nicht wie viele Elo-Punkte herum sich das dann irgendwie so kippt,
kippt das dann plötzlich so was das Spiel dann auszeichnet und was du noch investieren
musst um noch signifikant irgendwo auch nur einen Schritt weiter zu kommen das
passte dann irgendwie nicht mehr so in mein Leben Oder du bist Magnus Carlsen Ja.
Das hilft vielleicht auch Also was bei dem Typ irgendwie anders verdrahtet ist,
aber ich schaue immer wieder mit Begeisterung so Analysen von seinen Spielen,
weil er einfach so irre Sachen macht, die so jenseits der Lehre sind.
Der ist ja mittlerweile auch so gelangweilt von seiner Rolle, der Beste zu sein.
Also ich meine, der hat ja nach zehnmal die Weltmeisterschaft gewonnen und dann
hat er einfach aufgehört, sich irgendwie für die Weltmeisterschaft überhaupt
noch zu bewerben, weil ihn das irgendwie nicht mehr gekickt hat.
Und deswegen, was du schon erwähnt hast, Freestyle-Chess und vor allem spielt
er einfach immer wieder so Spiele, wo er dann so völlig,
hanebüchende Eröffnungen macht, so alles, was im Buch steht,
was man auf gar keinen Fall tun sollte, so mit den Bauern an der Seite und was
weiß ich, opfert nochmal seine Dame und gewinnt am Ende die Spiele dann trotzdem
und das ist total irre, weil man merkt so richtig,
wie der so einem in so einem Modus mit irgendwie mir kann nichts mehr passieren,
ich fahre jetzt irgendwie nackt Motorrad und Scheiß drauf.
Ich finde das irgendwie bemerkenswert und er ist einfach, weiß nicht,
auf eine Art und Weise kreativ, die niemand in den Griff kriegt.
Also er verliert zwar ab und zu mal ein Spiel, aber er ist ja immer noch die
Nummer 1 der Weltrangliste. Das ist irre.
Also ich war mal auf so einem Festival-ähnlichen Ding, da war so ein Typ,
der hatte halt sich so in so einer Wagenburg von vier Tischen verschanzt und
dann stand auf jedem Tisch standen zwei Schachspiele,
und dann konnte man halt einfach hingehen und das Spiel eröffnen und er hat
dann weitergemacht und dann hat er halt gleichzeitig mit vier,
fünf, sechs Leuten je nachdem wie viel Interesse der Schach immer gegen die gespielt.
Ist dann mal im Kreis gegangen und hat immer geguckt, ob er jetzt dran ist und einen Zug machen muss.
Da gab es ja auch mal so einen Künstler, der auch groß damit geworben hat,
dass er irgendwie so 50 Prozent der Spiele gewinnt, egal wie viele gegen ihn spielen.
Hat er auch geschafft. Immer.
Hä?
Naja, er hat einfach sich immer zwei rausgesucht, hat sich die Züge gemerkt
und immer nur die Züge der anderen gemacht.
Also er hat eigentlich gar nicht selber gespielt, sondern nur die anderen gegeneinander
spielen lassen, ohne dass sie es merken.
Sehr schöne Idee.
Er war Vermittler.
Ein Matchmaker. Ja, echt cool. So, aber was ist denn nun mit Schach, Ralf?
Wie dem auch sei. Wenn wir euch jetzt neugierig gemacht haben,
dass das doch ein Spiel ist, was man mal irgendwie auch unterwegs ausprobieren sollte.
Ich war also lange auf der Suche nach einem wirklich vernünftigen Reiseschach-Set.
Das habe ich jetzt leider nicht mitgebracht hier heute Abend.
Hatte ich keine Zeit, mir das noch reinzupacken, aber wir können es beschreiben
und ich kann hier Bilder in den Chat reinwerfen, beziehungsweise einen Link, wo das herkommt.
Weil bei so einem Reiseschach willst du halt zwei Dimensionen ausgleichen.
Es soll nicht zu fizzlig sein, dass die Figuren sofort umkippen und weggeweht
werden und das auch alles irgendwie keinen Spaß macht und man nicht ordentlich
Überblick hat auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite willst du es halt
kompakt haben auf der anderen Seite.
Und der klassische Ansatz ist, dass du in der Mitte ein zusammenklappbares Holzbrett
hast, was im Inneren die Steine irgendwie aufnimmt.
Das ist so der gängige Formfaktor.
Obendrauf zwei Eisenplatten,
Und dann ist jede Schachfigur unten mit einem Magneten ausgestattet.
Magnetisch, genau. Und das tut auch und das ist auch ganz schön.
Aber du hast dann halt die Außenseite, wo die Figuren drauf ziehen,
das ist dann halt noch außen exposed.
Das heißt also, wenn du das einfach mal irgendwo reinschmeißt,
dann kriegt es, gerade wenn es Holz ist, kriegt es irgendwie Macken und Risse und alles Mögliche.
Und ich war halt irgendwie auf der Suche nach noch was anderem.
Und wo ich jetzt drüber gestolpert bin, ist die Firma A&HS. Mittlerweile gibt
es etliche Copycats, aber ich glaube, die haben es wirklich erfunden.
Nämlich, dass die sagen, unser Schachbrett ist nicht aus Holz,
sondern es ist aus Silikon.
Das heißt, das ist eine Silikonmatte, die man zusammenfaltet,
nicht rollt, sondern faltet.
Irgendwie drei- oder viermal faltet man die und dadurch, dass es eben so ein bisschen...
Also Memory Foam ist es jetzt nicht wirklich, aber ihr könnt euch das vielleicht so vorstellen.
Die ist so mitteldick, die ist also schwer genug, dass sie sofort irgendwie
liegen bleibt und sich nicht wieder entlang der Knicklinien aufwölbt.
Es ist nicht hundertprozentig perfekt, aber mehr als good enough und die kannst
du halt auf jede Oberfläche draufschmeißen, die du halt hast.
Und dann die zweite Komponente sind dann die Figuren selber.
Die sind nicht aus Holz, sondern aus Plastik, aber ein ungewöhnlich wertiges Plastik.
Also da wäre es wirklich schön, wenn ich die jetzt hier dabei hätte.
Ich kann in der nächsten Sendung nochmal mitbringen.
Dadurch sind sie grundsätzlich etwas leichter als Holz und relativ groß,
sehr groß und kriegen aber auch noch ein schweres Gewicht unten rein.
Aber es ist halt nicht magnetisch, weil in der Silikonmatte hast du halt kein Magnet drin.
Das brauchst du aber auch nicht wirklich, weil die Figuren selber halt dadurch,
dass sie oben durch das Plastik leicht sind und den ganzen Schwerpunkt wirklich
weit unten haben. Stehen sie wirklich sehr robust.
Also ich habe das in diversen Mobil-Szenarien getestet. Du kannst da problemlos
auf jedem Tisch, auch auf dem Boot und sowas mitspielen.
Und dieses Set ist irre groß.
Es ist nicht ganz Turniergröße, aber dadurch, dass du halt das nicht nur einmal
in der Mitte durchfaltest, sondern eben drei- oder viermal faltest,
kriegst du das in eine sehr kompakte Reisebox drin, wo gerade eben quasi alle
Figuren reinpassen zusammen.
Das heißt also, da geht der ganze Platzbedarf hin, weil die Silikonmatte selber
ist mehr oder weniger, kostet nichts in Bezug auf Platzbedarf.
Und wenn du das auspackst, sehen sofort alle, oh du meinst es ernst.
Also es gibt, die haben das noch in zwei Größen, in original Turniergröße,
das ist dann 20 mal 20 Zoll, dann hast du quasi, könntest du da eine Weltmeisterschaft drauf spielen,
das finde ich dann unnütz und das, was ich also jetzt hier empfehlen kann,
ist die 15 Zoll Variante und die könnte noch ein Tucken kleiner sein,
sogar für meinen Geschmack, um es noch eine Ecke kompakter zu machen,
also ich würde sagen so 13 Zoll wäre nochmal super,
aber das Gefühl ist fantastisch, weil du packst dieses Teil aus und sofort denken
alle, Oh, jetzt kommen hier die Vereinsspieler um die Ecke.
Das gibt sofort so eine gewisse Ernsthaftigkeit rein, wenn man das auspackt.
Und das ist für Kinder vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich habe es immer sehr genossen, als ich das als Kind noch mit meinem Papa gespielt
habe. Der hat halt auch ein sehr teures, sehr wertiges Holzschachtset und das
ist dann auch schon so ein Ritual und ist auch so eine Geste.
Wir holen jetzt nicht so ein Mensch ärgere dich nicht raus, sondern das ist
hier ein Spiel, wo ein bisschen mehr Würde irgendwie am Start ist.
Und das transportiert diese etwas skurrile Kombination aus Silikon und großen,
schweren, wertigen Plastikfiguren sehr gut.
Und es kostet nicht viel, irgendwie 35 Euro und da würde ich mal sagen,
das ist eine Empfehlung.
Ja, ist ganz nett. Also ich schaue mir hier gerade die Holzvarianten an.
Die gefallen mir ehrlich gesagt auch sehr gut.
Weil ich bin eigentlich mehr so ein Holz-Typ.
Ich normalerweise auch. Aber wie gesagt, ich ärgere mich jetzt,
dass ich es halt nicht eingepackt habe.
Diese Plastikdinger, die fassen sich verdammt gut an.
Kannst du mal kurz sagen, wie groß kommt diese Tasche dann rüber?
Das ist, ich mache jetzt mal ungefähr so wie eine Switch 1 Tasche.
Hätte ich gesagt.
Ein bisschen kleiner vielleicht. So und dadurch, dass du das Ganze in so einem Case hast.
Kannst du auch eine Switch mitnehmen mit Schach drauf.
Ja Tim, das kannst du auch. Viel Glück bei deinen Kindern, die dann von den
anderen Spielen fernzuhalten.
Genau, das hatte ich jetzt noch nicht gesagt. Das Ganze kommt in einer Form,
schön Hardcase-Tasche noch daher, wo das dann alles unterkommt und die ist halt super robust.
Die schmeißt du irgendwo rein und der ist es völlig egal.
Da zerkratzt er nichts. Das heißt also, alles was da drin ist,
ist dann bestens geschützt.
Verstehe. Alright.
So und noch ganz kurz eine letzte Geschichte und dann bin ich durch mit meiner Verkaufsshow hier.
Im Sommer letzten Jahres habe ich mich zu der Aussage hinreißen lassen,
dass Dorfromantik das Brettspiel, das beste Familienspiel seit die Siedler von
Katan sei. Wir erinnern uns.
Da stehe ich immer noch zu. Da würde ich sagen, das ist so.
Aber wenn man es einmal komplett durchgespielt hat, was immerhin bei uns,
ich glaube, knapp 30 Runden gebraucht hat.
Welches andere Spiel, bitteschön, habe ich 30 Mal mit meinen Kindern gespielt.
30 eins.
Also ich exakt gar keins. Ein Brettspiel, du? Welches?
Hase und Igel. The best.
Hase und Igel. Das ist so aus den 80ern, ne? 70er?
Das ist glaube ich das erste Spiel, was ein deutscher Spielpreis bekommen hat.
Das müsste aus den 70er, 80ern sein, ja.
Nee, das ist nicht aus den 70ern. Haar und Igel ist aus den...
Oh, doch. Wurde erfunden. In den 70ern.
78. Echt? So alt ist das? Okay. Du hast recht. 79.
Als erstes Spiel mit dem Preisspiel des Jahres ausgezeichnet.
Ja, ich finde Hase und Egel super.
Okay, bis zu welchem Alter, würdest du sagen, konnte man das spielen?
Echt, hier steht ab zehn Jahren, das ist ja irre. Ich hätte das jetzt also als
Kleinkindspiel irgendwie verortet.
Kleinkindspiel ist es nicht, aber es ist gut so das erste richtige Brettspiel, ja.
Zehn Jahre weiß ich nicht.
Weil du lernst halt auf eine ganz einfache Art und Weise Strategien,
weil du hast quasi so einen exponentiellen Preis für das Voranschreiten.
Du musst also umso mehr Schritte du nach vorne gehen kannst in diesem Rennen
zwischen Hase und Igel, um zum Ziel zu kommen, musst du halt irgendwie Karotten einsetzen.
Und jeden Schritt, den du weiter laufen willst, musst du eben bezahlen,
aber der Preis steigt exponentiell an. Und jetzt gibt es eben verschiedene Strategien, die man fahren kann.
Man kann halt sich zurückfallen lassen, man kann darauf wetten,
dass man in einer bestimmten Position landet und kriegt dann dafür eine Belohnung,
wenn man wieder dran ist oder man setzt einfach aus und akkumuliert dadurch neue Karotten.
und manche sagen halt, ja, ich gehe in kleinen Schritten voran und dann bin
ich immer vorne und dann holt mich keiner ein.
Manche gammeln bis zum Schluss irgendwie am Anfang rum, hüpfen hin und her.
Du musst in der Zwischenzeit auch noch was getan haben, du musst deine Salate fressen und so weiter.
Es gibt so ein paar Duties, die du erfüllt haben musst und du musst dann vor
allem am Ende auch genau deinen Karottenvorrat aufgebraucht haben bis zu einer
bestimmten Allowance, die wiederum von deinem Platz abhängt.
Das heißt, wenn du als erster reinrillst, darfst du glaube ich nur so zehn Karotten
überhaben und umso weiter hinten du bist, umso mehr Spiel hast du da.
Und das heißt, du musst die ganze Zeit kalkulieren und du musst so eine Strategie
entwickeln und du musst deine Strategie auch immer mit den Strategien der anderen
anpassen und das ist einfach ein geiles,
einfaches, super simples Spiel mit einem klaren Ziel, aber mit vielen Lösungsvarianten.
Und es wird von daher irgendwie nicht alt.
Ich mochte das immer. Ich bin jetzt nicht so der totale Brettspiel-Fanatiker,
aber Hase und Igel war schon immer.
Mein Ding und ich finde, auch wenn das 79 erfunden wurde, das kann man heute
immer noch, also das wäre wirklich mal mein Tipp, hatten wir glaube ich noch
nie drüber gesprochen, Hase und Igel.
Also die Rezensionen geben dir recht. Ich habe hier gerade mal die HAL 9000.de-Seite.
Also HAL mit zwei L, nicht wie der Computer.
Das ist so das Brettspiel Reddit oder was?
Ja, genau. Also für Deutschland und eher so eine kleine Community.
Also jetzt nicht hier wie die internationale Boardgame-Geeks,
aber das ist immer so mein erstes Go-To, wenn ich irgendwie von alten weißen
Männern die Einschätzung haben will.
Und die sagen exakt das, was du gerade sagst. So der Klassiker schlechthin,
erstes Spiel des Jahres 79, das leider in eher kindlicher Aufmachung wohl oft
das falsche Zielpublikum anspricht.
Ja, da ist was dran.
Es steckt auf jeden Fall mehr drin, als man denkt. Zeitloser Klassiker,
Must-Have in jeder Spiele-Sammlung.
Ah, das schaue ich mir doch mal an.
Absolut, also wenn du das noch nicht gehabt hast, dann darfst du das gerne mal
deiner Sammlung hinzufügen und da würde mich mal wirklich deine Bewertung interessieren.
Das werde ich tun. Ich hatte das ganz ernsthaft hier, wie heißen denn so diese
ersten Kleinkind-Spiele?
Also das eine ist hier das mit dem Apfelbaum.
Und dem Raben.
Obstgarten. Und wenn man eins drüber ist, da gibt es auch so ein Pseudo-Rennspiel.
Da dachte ich immer, das sei sowas in der Größe. Aber guck, was gelernt.
Hat sich die Sendung doch schon wieder hier lohnt. Sehr schön.
Nee, es ist wirklich für dieses Genre German Board Games, wie es die Amis immer
nennen, ist es halt wirklich ziemlich stilprägend und ich würde auch sagen,
es gibt halt so Vielen Dank.
Die Hase-und-Igel-Generation und die Siedler-von-Kartan-Generation.
Dazwischen gab es noch die Mr. X oder wie es damals hieß, Scotland,
die Art-Generation. Das war ich.
Richtig, ja.
Das war mein erstes richtiges Spiel, wo ich dachte, so, das ist aber pfiffig hier.
Okay, so, wir kamen aber eigentlich von Dorfromantik. Was ich nach wie vor denke,
fantastisch, 30 Runden gespielt.
Aber dann hat so eine gewisse Hemmschwelle so, eigentlich denkt man sich,
ich würde eigentlich mal gerne wieder Dorfromantik spielen, aber jetzt nochmal
so eine ganze Kampagne, wenn es schon einmal durch ist, das ist ja quasi ein
Legacy-Spiel, wir erinnern uns,
was du wieder resetten kannst und wo du alles wieder in den Ausgangszustand
für eine neue Kampagne quasi schalten kannst.
Und das war dann doch immer relativ hoch, diese Hürde.
Und dankenswerterweise gibt es jetzt aber quasi einen Teil 2 davon.
Es gab so Extensions, aber die fand ich nicht so spannend.
Aber schon vor irgendwie sechs Monaten oder sowas Das ist jetzt Dorfromantik
Sakura rausgekommen, was das ganze Dorfromantik Grundsystem auf Japan überträgt.
Wir sehen hier schon den Mount Fuji im Hintergrund auf dem Bild und irgendwo
ist auch ein kleiner Totoro.
Also da sind auch so kleine lustige Japan-Referenzen überall verbaut.
Und das hatte ich dann für unseren großen Sommerurlaub mitgenommen und das zündet
dann genauso wie das Original.
Ich würde jetzt gar nicht so viel spoilern, weil der Charme dieser Spiele liegt
auch daran, dass man nicht weiß, was so alles passiert und was so alles an Mechaniken dazukommt.
Aber wenn ihr euch in der Zielgruppe, die ich gerade eben ein bisschen beschrieben
habe, wiederfindet, eigentlich würde man mal gerne wieder Dorfromantik spielen,
aber nochmal genau dasselbe vielleicht nicht so.
Das erfüllt genau diesen Sweetspot, dass man da wieder locker 20, 25 Partien Spaß hat.
Und ändert nicht so rasend viel an dem Grundkonzept, bringt halt mehr Komplexität
rein, aber auch übersichtlich.
Ich finde es insgesamt vielleicht fast eine Spur zu leicht.
Also gefühlt haben wir die Kampagne schon so nach 22 Runden durchgehabt,
weil man sehr schnell, sehr gut vorwärts kommt und sich sehr viele Extras freischaltet.
Das mag aber auch daran liegen, wenn man halt einmal das Grundspiel schon komplett
durchgeohnt hat, dass man dann
einfach schon Profi ist und nicht mehr so viele Fehler macht am Start.
Und dann kommt da halt auch so eine Dynamik rein, dass man relativ schnell,
relativ viel frei spielt.
Das wäre fast mein einziger Kritikpunkt, dass es gefühlt ein bisschen zu einfach ist.
Aber ansonsten zu Weihnachten mit den Kindern, die damals Spaß hatten,
das funktioniert wieder genauso gut.
und damit ist unser kleiner Shopping-Kanal beendet.
Da kann ich auch noch ein Spiel empfehlen. Und zwar, meine Jungs mögen eigentlich
kooperative Spiele sehr gerne.
Und da gibt es eins, das heißt Emission und ist so ein Klimawandelspiel,
wo man versuchen muss, zusammen zu agieren, sodass die Welt nicht untergeht.
Und das ist gar nicht so einfach. Also ich kann das empfehlen.
Emission.
Emission heißt es, ja.
Davon habe ich schon gehört. Das soll in der Tat gut sein. Meine sind da noch zu klein für.
Es gibt auch von Siedler von Katan ein bisschen ähnlich gelagertes Spiel,
wo du so die Katan-Grundmechanik auf Klimawandel und Umbaugesellschaft und lieber
Windräder bauen und sowas.
Ja, bei dem Spiel ist es so, dass es, es gibt relativ viele Mechaniken in dem
Spiel, du kannst dann Bäume pflanzen, dann kannst irgendwie so Meereswellen,
die nehmen dann CO2 auf und wenn du aber zu viel erzeugt hast,
dann steigt wieder die Temperatur und wenn die Temperatur steigt,
dann hast du mehr Katastrophen, die du ausführen musst und dann hast du sowas
wie gesellschaftliche Unruhen, die
dann auftreten, wenn du nicht genug Gesellschaftspunkte gesammelt hast,
die das dann abfedern, dass du gesellschaftliche Unruhen hast und so weiter.
Und wenn man das nicht geschickt spielt oder zumindest ein bisschen Glück hat,
dann schaukelt sich halt alles ständig auf.
Und dann geht die Welt unter?
Naja, dann verlierst du es halt, weil du irgendwie bei drei Grad landest oder
was das ist. Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht genau.
Also du spielst es immer sieben Runden, glaube ich. Und wie gesagt,
ist es nicht ganz einfach, das Spiel tatsächlich zu gewinnen.
Und teuer ist es, 80 Euro.
Früher hat man Risiko gespielt und seine Armeen über die Welt geschickt und
jetzt muss man sich rennen.
Aber das Witzige an dem Spiel ist halt, also einer spielt USA,
einer spielt Europa, einer spielt Afrika und so weiter.
Und du musst aber zusammenspielen natürlich, weil das sind ja globale Auswirkungen.
Also es ist kein Gegeneinander.
Ja cool.
Ich meine vielleicht noch, ich sehe ab zehn Jahren, wobei das ja immer so ein
bisschen, aber mein kleiner ist jetzt sechs Jahre. Also Dorfromantik kommt ja
gut mit, aber da ist wahrscheinlich noch der Sprung ein bisschen zu groß.
Also das ist auch Kennerspiel des Jahres 2024, also letzten Jahres geworden.
Also dieses Spiel des Jahres haben wir irgendwann ausdifferenziert.
Zuerst hatten sie Kinderspiel des Jahres und normales Spiel des Jahres.
Das ist aber bestimmt schon 15 Jahre her, 20 Jahre her, dass sie den Split gemacht haben.
und seit, ich glaube, drei oder vier Jahren gibt es auch noch das Kennerspiel
des Jahres, wo dann so die etwas komplexeren Sachen drin sind und da hat es
den Pokal letztes Jahr gewonnen.
Ja, ich glaube, die Spiele des Jahres 25 sehen auch spannend aus.
Zwei davon habe ich schon bei mir auf der Pile of Shame.
Da werde ich dann vielleicht in einer der nächsten Sitzungen mal berichten.
So, weil der Spiel des Jahres 25 ist nämlich auch ein kooperatives Spiel,
wo man gemeinsam eine Bombe entschärfen muss.
Ah, das liest sich auch alles sehr spannend.
Alright.
Gut.
Übrigens, Hacker-Brausen-Blog gibt es doch noch. Jetzt hört wohl gerade zu und
hat das sofort kommentiert.
Ach.
Aber nicht im Chat, sondern auf Mastodon. Ja.
Hier wird noch Paleo empfohlen, kann ich auch empfehlen.
Da, Hacker-Brause.org.
Ist aber schon sehr, sehr lange nichts mehr gepostet worden, glaube ich, ne?
Weiß nicht. Letzte Post 13. April 2015. Ja, aber gibt's noch.
Lustig. Berliner Mädchen. Mit E.T.
Eine Mate.
Eine Mate. Sehr schön. Anyway, womit machen wir weiter?
Ah ja, genau. Ich habe ein Produkt erworben. Das wollte ich kurz berichten,
da gibt es nicht so richtig viel zu erzählen.
Jetzt gibt es überhaupt mein Magnetkabel wieder her. Ja, ja.
Willst du deinen Gürtel auch wieder haben?
Ja, ich bin ja nach wie vor eigener und Nutzer der Apple Vision Pro.
Man ist da sehr alleine irgendwie. Die Community ist sehr überschaubar.
Ich habe nur einen Freund, der auch einen hat.
Und naja, Apple hat ja jetzt dieses Produkt etwas verbessert,
wie ihr vielleicht mitbekommen habt.
Jetzt gibt es dasselbe sozusagen etwas schneller mit so einem M5 Prozessor.
Das ist ehrlich gesagt nicht weiter erwähnenswert, auch wenn es sicherlich ganz
okay ist, wenn sie da Produktpflege betreiben, aber es ist natürlich jetzt keine
Revolution, weil sich ansonsten an dem Gerät nichts geändert hat, außer das Band.
und das habe ich mir gekauft, weil das ist wirklich für Apples Verhältnisse,
absurd billig, also es ist wirklich ich fasse es überhaupt nicht diese Plastikkrampe
die du da so ranklemmst, die so magnetisch an diese Brille randockt nur um dann
sozusagen nochmal Platz zu bieten für so eine kleine,
Pufferkranz, den du dir dann ins Gesicht drückst, für das Teil wollen sie über
200 Euro haben aber für diesen für dieses Dual-Knitband, was also diese.
Gewebtes Kopfband ist, was man da so reinklemmt und was jetzt eben in dieser
neuen Variante auch oben einen Streifen hat.
Und hinten, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, sind nochmal so,
Gewichte eingebracht.
Damit es noch schwerer ist.
Um das auszubalancieren.
Genau, damit es schwerer wird tatsächlich. um die Brille vorne auszubalancieren,
weil es ist nicht so sehr das Gewicht an sich, was stört. Es ist die Imbalanz.
Und außerdem ist der hintere Streifen, sitzt auch tiefer.
Der vordere klemmte sich ja wirklich, sagen wir mal, eher so direkt an den Hinterkopf.
Und das neue Ding sitzt halt eher drunter.
Und das habe ich jetzt erworben und getestet. Ich habe bis dahin...
Wie viel kostet denn das neue Band?
99 Euro.
Was also wirklich für...
Schnäppchen.
Für eine Brille, die 4000 kostet, ist es ein Schnäppchen, ja.
Ja, nee, aber es ist aber auch als Produkt an sich, weil es hat an der Seite
nach wie vor dieses Einstellrädchen, das war ja vorher schon sehr gut gelöst mechanisch.
Und jetzt ist es so, du kannst es halt rausziehen und dann stellst du das obere
Band ein und wenn du es wieder reindrückst, stellst du das hintere Band ein.
Meistens will man eh nur das hintere Band einstellen, aber ab und zu um die
Höhe sozusagen insgesamt nochmal und die Festigkeit zu steuern,
machst halt auch manchmal nochmal das andere, je nach Situation.
Und ich habe das dann erworben. Das war, ist ja ein bisschen später zu bekommen
gewesen, als jetzt in den USA.
Das kam jetzt irgendwie an, rangemacht. Und ich muss sagen, Volltreffer.
Also Apple hat dieses Produkt signifikant verbessert mit diesem Band.
Ich habe ja vorher so ein Third-Party Plaste-Klemmteil, was man so auf diese
seitlichen Bügel dranklemmt, was schon das Gewicht immer hier vorne auf die Stirn verlegt hat.
Wir sprachen in der Sendung darüber.
Genau, das war an sich schon mal der Fix, mit dem das überhaupt benutzbar war.
Aber jetzt mit dem Dual Band ist es einfach mal noch besser geworden und ganz großer Move.
Wie gesagt, an dem Produkt an sich ändert sich nichts. Es ändert sich auch nichts
daran, dass das Angebot an Software nach wie vor äußerst dürftig ist.
Und nach wie vor, und da muss ich sagen, bin ich glaube ich mit meinen Vorhersagen
noch so halbwegs richtig.
Also was ich ein bisschen unterschätzt habe, ist die Sinnhaftigkeit dieses Macintosh Monitor Modus.
Habe ich ja dann auf meiner Reise festgestellt, das ist einfach geil.
Also wenn du wirklich unterwegs bist, Brille mitnehmen und du hast immer einen großen Bildschirm.
Und wenn man sich halt nicht schämt, irgendwie auch im Flugzeug und in der Bahn, einfach geil.
Also du hast einfach einen Riesenscreen und kannst irgendwie korrekt arbeiten.
Keiner kann dir einen Bildschirm gucken und so.
Alle halten dich natürlich für so ein bisschen wonky so, aber mich haben die
Leute schon mein ganzes Leben lang immer ein bisschen wonky gefunden.
Von daher macht mir das jetzt auch nicht so viel aus.
Und da kann man dann mit der passenden Nerd Pride sowieso drüber stehen.
Perfekt wäre es dann auf dem E-Roller.
Ja, das habe ich so. Mit dieser 360-Grad-Kamera habe ich ja diesen Effekt.
Ich kann jetzt sozusagen auf dem E-Motorrad meine Fahrten aufnehmen und die
dann in der Vision Pro mir dann wieder in 360 Grad anschauen.
Das ist schon irgendwie ganz fancy.
Och, nur mit Übelkübel.
Nö. Also mir ist noch nie übel geworden bei dieser Brille. Also wenn sie irgendwas
hinbekommen haben, dann wirklich dieses Tracking ist einfach sagenhaft gut.
Also sie haben alle Latenzen so weit runtergeschraubt bekommen,
dass ich, also ich habe zumindest, es mag bei anderen Leuten anders sein,
aber ich habe, das ist wirklich nicht das Problem dieser Plattform.
Das Problem liegt eher da drin, dass ich finde, dass sie jetzt ein bisschen
anders ihre Softwareentwicklung, ihre Weiterentwicklung anders priorisieren
müssten und ich finde, Apple liefert selber zu wenig gute Beispiele.
Es sind immer noch die Hälfte der Systemprogramme, sind eigentlich nur die iPad-Versionen
und sie haben keine nativen Vision Pro Apps draus gemacht, wo man sagen kann, naja, okay,
Home und so weiter und Kalender, das funktioniert ja auch irgendwo.
Aber dann muss ich sagen, okay, wo ist jetzt der Punkt, dass du in so einem
offenen Environment auf einmal auch Vorteile hast, die du sonst nicht hast.
Und das konnten sie so bisher noch nicht zeigen. Mir ist ein bisschen unklar, warum sie das nicht tun.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass sie da schon irgendwie dran arbeiten.
Meine optimistische Vermutung ist, dass sie feststellen,
dass um das so zu machen, wie sie sich das vorstellen, sie tiefergreifende Änderungen
in ihrem OS vornehmen müssen und erst wenn die fertig sind, dann können sie das auch tun.
Das kann so sein, kann nicht so sein.
Hatten sie jetzt aber auch schon eineinhalb Jahre Zeit für.
Naja gut, aber ich meine, wir waren uns ja auch einig, das Ding ist an sich eine Beta-Version.
Ich glaube, dass sie jetzt einfach diese Zeit nutzen, um einfach Feedback einzusammeln
und wenn sie in der Software so antworten wie mit diesem Headband,
dann bin ich, dann mache ich mir keine Sorgen.
Ich glaube, was sie machen müssten, wäre eine CAD-Bude kaufen und so,
So dass das Logic oder das Final Cut oder wie auch immer, was sie halt auf dem
Mac haben, auch für die Vision dann rausbringen.
So dieses eine Programm, was so geil ist, dass du dir die Hardware kaufst.
Ja, aber du kaufst es dir schon deshalb, weil du eben genau mit diesen existierenden
Programmen mit dem Laptop einfach perfekt auf dem Ding arbeiten kannst.
Nee, ich nicht. Du.
Ich kaufe mir die nicht.
Nein, aber wenn du diesen Bedarf hättest, ich mache Videoschnitt on the go und
ich habe halt nur einen Laptop, aber ich hätte gerne einen riesigen Space.
Dann ist das Ding keine Geldausgabe.
Ja, wenn du den Macintosh Monitor Modus meinst, aber von dem rede ich ja nicht.
Ich rede ja von einer echten 3D-Anwendung, die das Ding halt auf ein neues Level
heben würde. Weißt du, die Macintosh-Monitor-Anwendung könnte ich auch auf einem
anderen Headset haben, wenn das möglich wäre.
Ja, das wird sich zeigen. Also ich meine, bei macOS 26 haben sie ja jetzt so
ein Feature eingebaut, was es quasi Programm auf dem Mac erlaubt,
sozusagen 3D-Content in die
Vision Pro so durchzustechen. Ich habe davon noch kein Beispiel gesehen.
Man kann jetzt für alles irgendwie Lösungen finden. Man kann rein natives,
man kann so einen hybriden Ansatz wählen.
Ich glaube, dass die Vision Pro sehr viel mehr ein Companion ist für den Mac
als für irgendwas anderes.
Also so wie die Uhr zum iPhone gehört, ist die Vision Pro so eine Extension vom Mac.
Derzeit. Die ist noch nicht genug, um was Eigenes zu sein, aber als Erweiterung
des Macintosh ist sie für manche Leute sehr praktisch.
Ja, ich finde trotzdem, es fehlt dir eine Anwendung, für die du unbedingt diese Brille haben willst.
Ja, der Macintosh-Monitor-Modus, das ist die Killerheit.
Ja, ich glaube, damit kriegt es aber kaum jemand.
Doch, ich kenne da eine Menge Leute, die genau das auch so sagen und die andere
Anwendung ist halt einfach Filme gucken. Das mache ich irgendwie jeden Abend.
Haben die jetzt nicht, also meine These war ja immer, sie müssen über Sport
gehen, Sport live, ich sitze oder stehe halt im Stadion und bin aber einfach
über die Vision Pro halt dabei mit einer vernünftigen Kameratechnik vor Ort.
Und da haben sie aber doch irgendwas jetzt auch.
Sie übernehmen Formel 1 für die nächsten fünf Jahre in den USA, komplett.
Ja, ob das nun gerade der Sport ist, der sich dafür anbietet,
müssen wir mal gucken, aber könnte sein.
Also ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie sie es machen, aber überleg mal,
was Formel 1 wahrnehmen primär ist.
Sie werden 3D-Kameras auf diese Formel 1-Wagen drauf machen,
live das Video übertragen und dann hast du noch Augmented Reality mit den ganzen Daten.
Nicht tun. Also dann gewinnst du ja kein Rennen mehr, wenn du so eine Kamera oben drauf hast.
Die haben sowieso alle schon Kameras drauf. Das wird jetzt nicht so eine Studio-Filmkamera
sein, aber da so eine kleine Mini-360-Grad-Kamera.
Ich meine, überleg mal, wie groß eine 360-Grad-Kamera ist.
Und wenn die alle das irgendwo verbaut haben, dann...
Ist das sozusagen ein Reglement und dann ist das so und dann haben das alle.
Also das glaube ich nicht, dass das die Bremse ist.
Ob sie es trotzdem tun werden, kann ich dir nicht sagen, aber im Prinzip ist
dieses Zuschauen bei Formel 1 einfach furchtbar langweilig. Aber die Leute schalten
sich halt auf die Streams der einzelnen Fahrer drauf in diesen Pro-Versionen.
Und wenn du das halt irgendwie auch noch in der Brille machen kannst und dann
hast du so augmented noch deine ganzen Fahrzeugdaten und du fährst jetzt selber
dreidimensional in Realtime mit den Profifahrern mit.
Also das kann schon funktionieren. Ob sie das so machen werden,
kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Aber wenn ich so überlege, welche Sportart eignet sich jetzt erstmal am besten
für solche Sachen, dann ist Formel 1 wahrscheinlich gar nicht so eine doofe Idee.
Und sie haben ja jetzt auch schon diesen Formel 1 Film haben sie ja sozusagen
schon selber rausgebracht, dann haben sie auch schon so mal so eine Demorunde,
das fand ich allerdings,
ich bin auch nicht so der Formel 1 Typ, muss ich dazu sagen,
also mich tangiert das nicht und Verbrennermotoren und so weiter.
Aber grundsätzlich wissen wir ja, Leute, fasziniert das.
Und sie hatten ja diese Demo-Runde von, wie heißt der Schauspieler,
ist das Brad Pitt? Brad Pitt.
Der hat irgendwie so eine Demo-Runde gefahren, das war jetzt kein richtiges Rennen.
Und dann konntest du das halt irgendwie so auf der Brille angucken.
Hat mich jetzt auch nicht so abgeholt, aber ich glaube, das gibt schon Leute, die das geil finden.
Also jetzt, wo du es so erzählt hast, ja, I'm sold. Ich glaube,
das könnte funktionieren.
So eine Kamera in ein Auto einzubauen ist auch leichter als in einem Fußballspieler.
Glaube ich. Ja, bei Fußball ist es, ich meine auch da gibt es immer noch diese
Möglichkeiten, sie haben ja diesen Deal mit dieser langweiligen MLS,
muss man mal gucken, also ich glaube den Fußballmarkt sich zu erarbeiten ist auch schwierig.
da hast du es wirklich mit sehr vielen Leuten zu tun, aber Formel 1 ist halt
sehr, sehr technisch und sehr datengetrieben das ist ja irgendwie ein irrer
Zirkus nach wie vor naja aber.
Ich weiß nicht ein Gerät, was nicht nur Pro heißt sondern auch so bepreist wird,
dann als Entertainment Gadget zu benutzen, ist jetzt auch irgendwie ich finde
das passt nicht so richtig.
Na gut der Preis kann sich ja noch ändern. Du musst aber erstmal den Content haben.
Und derzeit gibt es halt den Content nicht. Aber dass es den Content auch nicht
gibt, hat mit mehreren Sachen zu tun.
Also es gab jetzt bis vor kurzem auch noch gar nicht die Kameras dafür.
Also die haben sich da jetzt teure Rigs bisher so zusammengebaut,
aber jetzt kommt zum Beispiel von Blackmagic diese Kamera,
die explizit jetzt für Vision Pro-artigen Content gebaut ist und es muss überhaupt
erstmal diese ganze Industrie, muss erstmal gebootstript werden in technischer Hinsicht.
dann fehlte halt auch die Erfahrung, so ein bisschen wie bei der Apple Watch am Anfang.
Was haben sie uns da nicht alles erzählt, was man damit machen kann?
Ja, emotional contact und übertrage den Herzschlag deines Liebsten und sowas.
Hat am Ende überhaupt keinen interessiert. Aber so Training-Daten und Motivation
und Notifications hat voll reingehauen, zack, bumm, die Dinger verkaufen sich halbwegs.
Und genauso ist es jetzt auch bei dieser Brille. Du musst erst mal ein Gefühl
dafür kriegen, wie muss ein Film sein, dass der dich anspricht?
Wie muss so eine Videoaufnahme sein, dass die dich begeistert und nicht verliert?
Dass du nicht verloren bist, dass du nicht weißt, was ist, was ist spannend, was ist nicht spannend?
Sie haben halt diese eigene Company da gegründet, die halt am laufenden Meter
so Sachen raushaut, die mal so, mal so, mal so sind und darüber messen sie jetzt quasi ein,
was funktioniert, wie muss man es machen, weil es ändert sich so viel.
Du kannst nicht mit dem Wissen eines normalen 2D-Films 3D machen.
Weil wie nah darf eine Person sein? Es gibt zum Beispiel diese ganzen Künstler-Performances
und dann bist du da so 20 Zentimeter gefühlt vor so einem schwitzenden Körper
und dann denkst du halt auch nur so bitte nicht.
Willst du dich selber bewegen? brauchst du kurze Schnitte, brauchst du lange
Schnitte, all diese ganzen Fragen kommen da schnell auf und keine Ahnung,
ob sie am Ende die Lösung dafür finden werden ich weiß es nicht,
vielleicht scheitert das Ganze auch, aber ich würde sagen, der Drops selbst
ist da noch lange nicht gelutscht und es ist alles noch komplett offen und bis dahin,
Kann ich nur hoffen, dass sie es auch noch schaffen, eine Verbesserung zu erzielen,
was so Auflösung, Reaktionszeiten und so weiter betrifft.
Das soll ja jetzt mit der neuen Variante mit M5 so ein bisschen besser geworden
sein, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so dramatisch viel besser.
Du kannst mir die gerne mal wieder ausleihen. Ich würde mir da den aktuellen
Stand der Software gerne mal wieder zu Gemüte führen.
Hat sich nicht viel getan, es gibt nur mehr Content, aber Software ist mau.
Alright. So. Jetzt können wir mal reinholen.
Du hast ja hier auch noch so ein Gadget. Das müssen wir uns auf jeden Fall nochmal geben.
Weil Jens sitzt hier mit einem Laptop, der ein bisschen aussieht wie so ein
Pausenbrot-Kistchen, würde ich sagen.
Oder so eine Bento-Box, ne?
Ja, so eine Bento-Box, so in dieser Größenordnung. Und es ist trotzdem ein Laptop.
Vielleicht hat er den Namen Laptop sehr viel mehr verdient als andere Laptops,
weil der passt halt auch irgendwie noch ganz gut auf den Lab.
Ist ziemlich dick. Also ich würde
mal sagen, drei- oder viermal so dick vielleicht wie mein MacBook Air.
Mindestens, mindestens, ja.
Mindestens, genau. Aber hat eine Clickety-Clack-Tastatur. Und wir erinnern uns,
wir haben hier vor kurzem über den Raspberry Pi 500 Plus gesprochen,
der LEDs unter der Tastatur hat.
Und unter jeder Taste eine eigene LED, die man natürlich auch noch fancy-fancy
farblich ansprechen kann und das hast du auch?
Das habe ich auch, genau.
Was hast du noch da drin, bevor wir sagen, was genau ist?
Oh, da ist auf jeden Fall in der Ausbaustufe auch noch ja, ziemlich schickes,
Armprozessorchen unter der Haube. Genau, da ist eine SSD drin,
ja, verschiedene Sachen. Vor allen Dingen diese physikalische Tastatur,
das ist so ein richtiges Schreibmaschinengefühl, was man da hat.
Es wird wieder geklickt und geklockt.
Ich klicke mal.
So, wir reden von dem,
MNT Pocket Reform, the iconic Open Hardware Mini Laptop from MNT.
Ideal for using Linux on the go. M&T Pocket Reform ist ein fully-featured 7-inch
Mini-Laptop das ist Modular, Upgradable, Customisable und Repairable.
so jetzt dein Pitch.
Mein Pitch ist, hat einen langen Weg hinter sich, der ist direkt aus Berlin-Charlottenburg gekommen.
Charlottenburg gehört nicht zu Berlin.
Es ist ein lokales Produkt und es hat auch so ganz diesen Vibe mit lokales Kunsthandwerk.
Also das wird in kleinen Badges hergestellt und dauert dann auch mal ein bisschen,
bis man das von der Bestellung dann bekommt.
Es ist ziemlich exakt so schwer, wie es aussieht.
Das ist ziemlich schwer.
Schon so ein Backstein.
Es hat halt wirklich an allen Ecken Schrauben. Und du kannst es jederzeit aufschrauben,
kannst alles rauspacken.
Dann ist es leicht.
Dann ist es wieder leicht, ja. Nee, aber die Idee dahinter ist,
dass wenn halt ein besseres Mainboard rauskommt, ein besserer Prozessor,
dann kaufst du dir nicht einen neuen Computer, sondern dann schraubst du es auf und baust es halt um.
Du kannst das irgendwie reparieren, was auch immer wieder schwieriger gemacht
wird bei den neuen MacBooks oder sowas.
Ich meine, es gibt Leute, die reparieren die auch, aber das ist was anderes,
als wir das früher gemacht haben mit diesen Tower-Gehäusen oder so.
Das macht man nicht mal mal eben, ja.
Ja, genau. Und dieses Gefühl hatten wir halt wieder. Und das ist halt Farm-to-Table Open Source.
Also es gibt wirklich fast keinen Aspekt an diesem Gerät, wo es nicht offen
ist. Also es ist unter einer offenen Hardware-Lizenz vom CERN,
die haben so eine Open-Hardware-License geschaffen, ist das alles drin.
Wenn irgendwie das Gehäuse kaputt geht, dann sind die STL-Files für den 3D-Drucker
da, sodass ich mir dann irgendwelche Sachen nachdrucken kann.
Natürlich ist da irgendwie Linux drauf, so eine Debian-Variante,
die sie ein bisschen angepasst haben und ja,
also wirklich, es gibt keinen Punkt, der da nicht dokumentiert ist und der nicht
auch nachbestellt, nachgehackt und sonst was melden kann.
Es ist sicherlich nicht irgendwie für alle Leute der richtige Computer.
Aber für Leute, die dieses Spiel, wie offen kann mein Gerät eigentlich sein,
ins Extrem spielen wollen, ja, da wäre es eine Variante.
Das hängt irgendwie auch zusammen. Ich habe da kurz vor der Sendung,
habe ich nochmal kurz einen Blogbeitrag gemacht dazu.
Hängt mit dieser Idee vom Permacomputing zusammen. Permacomputing ist so eine,
Solarpunk-Idee.
Dein Blog ist wo?
Blog.jol.io und dann slash permacomputing findest du gleich den Artikel.
Permacomputing ist so eine Solarpunk-Idee. Und ähnlich wie Solarpunk kann man
das auch verschiedentlich verstehen.
Also mal so als ästhetische Bewegung,
müssen wir wirklich immer das Neueste kaufen und das,
weniger neue dann wegschmeißen oder können wir nicht irgendwie versuchen dann
irgendwie permanent auszutauschen ich hoffe jetzt, dass ich diesen Rechner noch
ziemlich lange behalte aber mal schauen ob es wirklich,
für immer dann sein wird und wirklich permanent wird.
Die Idee vom Permacomputern kommt aus der finnischen Demoszene und das hat natürlich
auch irgendwie was mit Aktivismus zu tun und wie kann man eigentlich in einer
schlechten Welt überhaupt noch irgendwie ethisch konsumieren?
oder ist das alles irgendwie Quatschikato? Genau.
Ich bin ziemlich begeistert, also ich finde für unterwegs was schreiben und
unterwegs ein bisschen was codieren, ist das super.
Ich weiß noch nicht so ganz, ob es irgendwie wirklich jetzt mein Main-Treiber
wird. Und es ist natürlich viel, viel teurer.
Das ist halt auch wieder dieser Bio-Laden-Effekt.
Ist halt Nicht Aldi. Und ich denke, dadurch, dass es irgendwie in Europa hergestellt wird,
in sehr kleiner Marge hergestellt wird, muss man da viel mehr für ausgeben als
für vergleichbare Konsumerprodukte.
Das Versprechen ist ja auch, dass man sich dann viele Ausgaben in der Zukunft auch sparen kann.
Das ist die Idee.
Und was war das jetzt, 1000 Euro oder wie?
Also zwischen, hier hat jemand 1100 geschrieben, zwischen 1100 bis 1500.
Also ich habe dann halt noch ein besseres Mainboard dazu gekauft.
So ist ungefähr der Preis. Und das ist nicht angemessen, oder das ist nicht
vergleichbar mit dem, was man sonst für so einen kleinen tragbaren Computer bezahlen würde.
Da würde es ja wahrscheinlich eher so 500 bis 800 Euro bezahlen.
Also das Display hat 7 Zoll und stimmt das hier 1920x1200 Pixel?
Das ist ja eine Menge, das heißt, da kommt man irgendwie so auf 320 ppi. Das ist ja Retina.
Ja, ja, und du kannst damit auch irgendwie 3D-Cut und sowas machen.
Also das ist schon ein richtiges Arbeitsgerät, das ist kein Spielzeug.
Was sagen deine brillenlosen Augen, Ralf?
Ja, dadurch, dass es auf deiner Seite halt dann eben nur 7 Zoll ist,
wenn du jetzt irgendwie so neben so ein iPad Air oder sowas hättest,
so, das ist dann halt schon.
Musst du noch eine Apple Vision Pro dazu kaufen Ja.
Also zu Hause habe ich es natürlich an einen großen Monitor angeschlossen und
dann ist es halt wirklich ein Genuss Ich.
Suche nämlich gerade irgendwie so ein erstes Laptop für meinen großen Racker,
so, was da eigentlich jetzt ein schlauer Weg ist, ob man ihm einfach mal einen
Linux hinstellt oder Das.
Ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr, sehr großzügiges Weihnachtsgeschenk.
Das sieht aber hinreichend robust aus. Das würde dafür sprechen,
dass es nicht sofort nach einer Woche kaputt ist.
Da gibt es auch Geschichten von Leuten, denen das im TGW, im französischen Schnellzug,
aus der Ablage runtergefallen ist auf dem Boden und nichts passiert.
Ich dachte, aus dem Zug gefallen.
Ja, aber ist dieser Hinge, dieser Klappmechanismus, ist der irgendwie jetzt
besonders robust ausgeführt?
Ich finde schon, ja. Den kriegt man auch eigentlich nicht.
Da brauchst du immer zwei Hände, um das zu eröffnen.
Mach mal zu und reich mal kurz rüber, wie das so als Klotz dann eigentlich sich
anfühlt. Kann das Kabel ab oder geht der dann sofort? Doch, der hat doch einen Akku.
Das ist schon wirklich dick.
Wie lange hält der Akku so im Betrieb?
Ach so, also die Akkus, die da jetzt drin sind, die habe ich jetzt auch nicht ausgekauft.
Dass dir das Screen nicht ausgeht, das ist Absicht.
Ja, da wird aber nochmal gerade dran gearbeitet.
Ah, jetzt verriegelt der sich auch irgendwie ganz schlau. Wie kriege ich den
jetzt überhaupt wieder auf?
Nee, nee, das muss nur... Achso, das ist die falsche Sorte.
Ja, der ist richtig rum.
Okay.
Und anstatt Trackpad hast du da so einen Trackbutton oder was ist das?
Trackball, ja.
Trackball ist das.
Wall. Mechanisch.
Mechanisch.
Aha, und ist das, also ich meine...
Ich finde es cool. Also es ist was zum Anfassen und Liebhaben.
Also der Trackball wäre für mich...
So eine klitorische Gestalt. Echt, ein Trackball ist ja wie beim ersten MacBook.
Der wäre für mich ein Ausschlusskriterium.
Also dieses Gerät ist gedacht, mit Tastatur bedient zu werden.
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Okay, und die Tastatur fällt mir jetzt gerade erst auf, ist so eine klare...
Matrix, also hier sind die Tasten direkt übereinander. Was ist denn das für eine Tastatur?
Es ist eine orthogonale Tastatur, da hast du das ganz richtig erkannt.
Orthogonale Tastatur, wow.
Genau, hat natürlich auch diese ganzen, also du fängst da an mit der Hyper-Taste,
dann kommt die Super-Taste, dann kommt die Meta-Taste.
Kein Caps-Lock.
Kein Caps Lock, weil steht auch im Handbuch, dass es irgendwie sehr hervorragend ist.
Die Benutzergruppe, die sie ansprechen wollen, würde sich das Caps Lock eh immer,
umdefinieren. Deswegen haben sie gesagt, brauchen wir nicht auf das Tastatur.
Gibt es da zumindest das Feature mit Doppelshift irgendwie so Shift-Shift Caps
Lock einzuschalten? Das fand ich eigentlich mal ganz sexy als Lösung.
Aber was ist eine AGR-Taste?
Alt-GR. Alternative Graphics.
Altgriechisch.
Altgriechisch, genau.
Na okay, also zumindest Inverted T irgendwie und so und das ist ein amerikanisches Also sie versuchen.
Nicht irgendwie einen größeren Markt.
Anzusprechen.
Aber es ist von Hackern für Hacker
und wird auch sicherlich nicht das Ding sein, was jeder im Großen hat.
Okay, und die Space-Taste sind sozusagen einfach zwei einzelne Tasten in der
Mitte nebeneinander sozusagen, also man hat zwei sozusagen und dann gibt es
links und rechts von dem Trackboard gibt es auch nochmal jeweils zwei Tasten, wofür sind die?
Das sind die Maustasten.
Warum vier?
Weil du unter, je nachdem wie du der X11-Kone gefiguriert hast,
sind vier Tasten halt schon ganz praktisch.
Achso, verstehe, man kann bis zu vier Maus, verstehe, okay.
Und man kann sich das dann so umkonfigurieren wahrscheinlich wieder,
wie man es haben will. Okay, fancy.
Was ich da jetzt drauf habe, ist, genau, also das ist auch eine Standardauswahl,
insofern gar nicht so tolle Leistung von mir oder so, sondern ich habe einfach
nur Ja, Ja, Ja geklickt, das ist Wayland,
das ist also dieser Nachfolger von X11 und auf Wayland läuft dann Sway als Window-Manager,
Und Zwei ist so ein bisschen, also wer jetzt,
ja, die Apple-Freaks haben wir jetzt wahrscheinlich eh verloren,
aber ja, wem i3 was sagt unter X11 als Window-Manager, ein Stacking-Window-Manager.
Also wenn du jetzt mal zum Beispiel, du siehst da jetzt gerade diesen Firefox
vor dir und wenn du da jetzt die Taste mit dem Logo und Return drückst, also zusammen,
zusammen, also Taste mit dem
Logo und Return zusammen, dann öffnet sich daneben ein Terminal. Genau.
Ich sehe schon. Also ich würde sagen, in der Nerd-Skala von 1 bis 10 ist es
schon eine klare 10. Also.
Ja, oder eine 11.
Ah, muss ich gleich hier übermütig werden. Ähm.
Was mich wirklich fertig macht, ist dieses Glossy Pink, was du hier irgendwie so als Dings hast.
Lila.
Die Farbe ist doch wohl völlig cool.
Ja, die ist cool. Also das macht irgendwie, dann hat das Ding einfach sofort
so einen Schminktaschen-Effekt.
Absolut. Pinky Pie.
Wenn das Ding so auf dem Tisch liegt, er hat erstmal keiner was,
dann denkst du wirklich, du machst wirklich deinen Schminkkasten auf. Ja.
Und dann kommt da irgendwie so ein Computer mal raus. Das ist irgendwie schon crazy.
Extra auch deswegen in der Konfiguration genommen. Also ich glaube,
das gibt es auch in Schwarz oder sowas, aber wer will das denn schon?
Nee, also da muss man ja mit auffallen.
Genau.
Das ist wirklich absurd.
Ja, also in einer Besprechung habe ich gelesen, da wurde dann gesagt,
das hätte so einen brutalistischen Charme.
Brutalistisch, ja das kommt hin.
Das kommt absolut hin und beim Brutalismus gibt es Leute, die hassen das mit
Inbrunst. und es gibt Leute, die lieben Brutalismus in der Architektur. Genau.
Ist mehr so ein bisschen Geschmackssache, ob man das gut oder schlecht.
Was hat der Brutalismus jemals für uns getan?
Es gibt so ein Levelpack für Quake, so ein Brutalismus Levelpack,
da haben ganz, ganz viele Leute Brutalismus Levels zusammengebaut.
Da passt das unheimlich gut hin, weil das so diese Verzweiflung über das viele
Beton ist, einfach zusammen mit viel Feuerkraft, das passt einfach.
Also, dass jetzt der USB-C-Stecker zum Laden jetzt oben am Display ist,
also nicht oben im Sinn von Oberkante, sondern so rechts oben,
Das ist schon ein bisschen weird, muss ich sagen. Also das ist die ganzen Ports da.
Ja, es ist eine weitere Weirdness in diesem an Weirdness nicht armen Gerät.
Jetzt würde mich eins nochmal interessieren. Bei dem Raspberry Pi 500 Plus haben
wir so gesehen, da gibt es so Settings für wie diese Displaybeleuchtung so konfiguriert werden kann.
Ich habe das noch nicht in der Hand gehabt, ich habe das nur aus dem Video.
Und das meiste fand ich ziemlich albern, aber eins fand ich eigentlich,
sah cool aus, auch wenn es Privacy Implications hat, nämlich du hast alle Lampen
aus, aber wenn du tippst, hast du dann immer so ein Nachleuchten bei der getippten Taste.
Sodass, wenn du jetzt schnell tippst, sozusagen so ein Feuer immer deinen Tippbewegungen nachläuft.
Hast du sowas da auch? Und hast du das schon ausprobiert?
Kann ich machen. Also die einzelnen Lämpchen unter jeder Taste lassen sich auch ansprechen.
Das ist halt dann ein Pfeil. Also wie unter Unix halt üblich,
ist einfach ein Device, wo ich Werte, RGB-Werte auch,
rein.
Man muss ja die Keyboard-Events dann sozusagen auch bekommen.
Genau, müsste man vielleicht irgendwie noch ein Kernel-Modul oder sowas packen.
Was vielleicht auch nicht schlecht wäre, wenn man diesen Blinkenlights...
So ein Keylogger mal ganz anders. Das ist ja eigentlich auch so ein bisschen so ein Security-Thema.
Dieses Blinkenlights-Movie-Format, wenn man das irgendwie dann auf der Tastatur
abspielen könnte, das wäre eigentlich auch keine schlechte Idee.
Aber was ich schon gesehen habe.
Warte mal, wie viele Zeilen und Spalten sind das?
Das sind 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 mal 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
Das ist eine sehr geile Idee.
Das solltest du tun. Na gut, BLM, also okay, die Originalblinklats ist 8x18,
da fehlt noch so ein bisschen was, aber im Prinzip spricht nichts dagegen,
dass du zumindest das Format benutzen kannst, ja.
Und was ein bisschen sinnvoller ist, dass Leute so Sachen gemacht haben,
wie wenn sie als Root unterwegs sind, sich als Root einloggen oder per Sudo
zum Root werden, dass dann halt die Tastatur eine.
Andere Farbe hat.
Ja, Rot wird.
So ein Dangerous Red.
Genau.
Das finde ich auch ganz cool. Ganz ehrlich, LED, einzelne Farb-LED unter jeder
Tasse, das ist ein echtes Killer Feature und das will ich eigentlich sofort
haben und ich weiß, ich werde es nie kriegen. Tja.
Cool.
So. Genug.
Wer weiß, wenn Apple die Ideen ausgehen, vielleicht kriegst du dann auch deine RGB-Tastatur.
Wer möchte denn mal seine Themen reinschmeißen? Roddy, du hast ja noch gar nichts
reingeworfen, aber du hast ja hier noch ein Thema, du hast ja ein Auto gekauft.
Ich habe ein Auto gekauft, genau.
Und zwar, da muss ich jetzt mal kurz den Link kopieren und abwerfen.
Es gab vor sieben Jahren, ich habe das vorhin nochmal nachgeguckt,
gab es von dem Fully Charged Kanal auf YouTube, gab es dieses Video,
wo sie von dem ID.Buzz damals,
einen fahrtüchtigen Prototypen gezeigt haben.
Und ehrlich gesagt war ich, als ich das Video gesehen habe, sofort verliebt
in das Ding. Und dachte mir, naja, das wird sowieso nie was.
Aber inzwischen kann man die Teile tatsächlich gebraucht kaufen und dann wird
es dann doch realistisch.
Und das habe ich jetzt getan.
im Süden von Berlin gab es einen VW-Händler der hatte einen vor Ort und ist
ihn dann eine Weile lang nicht los geworden und als er das zweite Mal mit dem
Preis runtergegangen ist, dachte ich mir rufst du mal an,
ja und jetzt habe ich einen ID.Buzz.
Und du hast damit was abgestoßen, deinen ID.3.
Den habe ich noch nicht abgestoßen aber.
Der wird jetzt abgestoßen.
Na, ich sag mal so, es nervt mich jetzt schon, zwei Autos zu haben und der muss tatsächlich weg,
allerdings ist es jetzt so, dass der es halt kurz vor TÜV neu machen und jetzt
ist auch ein schlechter Zeitpunkt, ein Auto verkaufen zu wollen einfach.
Warum?
Weil der Automarkt im Frühjahr relativ gut läuft und aber am Ende des Jahres nichts mehr passiert.
Ah.
Warum?
Warum genau kann ich dir nicht sagen. Ich kann dir nur sagen,
dass es da Leute gibt, die ich kenne, die Statistiken haben.
Die ganz klar sagen, dass der Frühling, Frühsommer eigentlich so der Punkt ist,
wo die Leute anfangen, plötzlich über ein neues Auto nachzudenken.
Mit dem sie dann in den Urlaub fahren können oder so, keine Ahnung.
Diesen Sommer machen wir. Ja, genau. Das kann ich mal nachvollziehen.
Wobei, ja, okay, das könnte dann, das heißt, du musst jetzt nochmal ein halbes
Jahr parken, muss ich sagen.
Ja, ich mache mir jetzt gerade keinen Stress, deswegen, sagen wir mal so.
Aber du hast jetzt ein Auto zu verkaufen, falls jemand einen ID.3 braucht.
Genau, First Edition mit Batteriezertifikat, wo drinsteht, dass das sogar überdurchschnittlich
gut ist, noch die Batterie.
Ja, der Bus, der ist quasi Vollausstattung bis auf einen Detail.
Und zwar, wenn man ein bisschen googelt, findet man diverse Foren,
in denen man lesen kann, dass als VW dieses Ding auf den Markt geworfen hat,
hatte der Zulieferer für die Rückfahrkamera Lieferprobleme.
Das heißt, die haben den ganzen Leuten quasi die Rückfahrkamera ausgeredet und
aus dem Konfigurator wieder rausgeschmissen und das ist den,
den ich habe, der ist jetzt einer von denen, der hat keine Rückfahrkamera.
Und du kannst die auch nicht nachrüsten doch.
Man kann die nachrüsten.
Aber ist teuer.
Pff, teuer ist relativ.
Also man kann es nachrüsten.
Man kann es nachrüsten, auch das Originalersatzteil kann man nachrüsten.
Allerdings muss man tatsächlich wahrscheinlich einiges auseinanderbauen,
weil man muss ja das Kabel von hinten, von der Klappe bis vorne zum Entertainment-System durchziehen.
Ich hätte ja gleich den Händler dazu verpflichtet, das einzubauen.
Ja, wenn du die Rückfahrkamera einbaust, dann nehme ich ihn mit.
Ja, nee, also genau, und da gibt es ja diverse Anbieter, die also quasi das
Originalersatzteil verkaufen, zusammen mit so einem Dongle, den man da so in...
Okay, aber warum jetzt ein Buzz und kein Adi 3, was ist jetzt,
was war jetzt dein Upgrade-Wunsch? Also was...
Naja, er ist größer und vor allen Dingen ist als Campingmobil realistisch benutzbar.
Okay.
Also wenn man die Rückbank um... Also es ist jetzt der mit der kurzen,
mit dem kurzen Radstand, der mit dem langen Radstand ist nochmal einen halben
Meter, glaube ich, länger.
Ungefähr, ja.
Der aber der mit einem kurzen Radstand, wenn man die Rückbank umklappt,
dann hat man halt 2,20 Meter ebene Fläche in der Länge und das reicht zum Drinnenpennen locker.
Ist aber nicht komplett eben.
Doch. Es gibt da so ein Zusatzaufbaubrett.
Ich hab's gesehen.
Wenn man alles umklappt, dann ist es Brett eben.
Also wir haben es eben ausprobiert, hat er mir gezeigt, ist eben.
Ist eine durchgängige, gerade Ladefläche für Ikea-Regale.
Ich war bei so einem Händler, hab mir den Alibas angeschaut,
der hat es umgeklappt, das war nicht eben. Hab ich gesagt, das ist ja nicht
eben, was ist denn das für ein Scheiß?
Und dann meinte er so, da wäre ich ja der Erste, der das fragen würde.
Und ich dachte mir nur so, wo bin ich?
Naja, man muss den Vordersitz ein Stück nach vorne machen, weil es sein kann,
dass er nicht ganz runterklappt. aber man merkt wenn er runtergeklappt ist dann.
Also das war der Moment, wo der Adibas bei mir komplett raus war,
als mir der Händler gesagt hat, das kriegt man nicht eben.
Doch.
Und jetzt erzählst du mir, es geht. Was erlaube Händler?
Händler sind auch nur Händler.
Ja, auch nur Händler. Ich meine,
wenn die keine Ahnung haben von diesen Fahrzeugen, wer denn dann sonst?
Das ist eine gute Frage, die ich hier so jetzt nicht beantworten kann.
Ich bin frustriert. Ich hasse das. Mich machen immer so Autohändler immer völlig
fertig. Sie erzählen immer so viel Unsinn.
Ja, man darf sich nicht auf Aussagen von Autohändlern verlassen.
Ja, und die haben auch keine Ahnung von ihren Fahrzeugen. Die fragen mich,
was ist eigentlich der Zweck eurer Existenz?
Wozu gibt es euch überhaupt? Ihr könnt keine Frage beantworten.
Und wenn man dann irgendwelche Wünsche hat, dann erzählen Sie immer einen,
das würde ja keinen interessieren.
Ich stehe vor Ihnen und interessiere mich dafür. Dann erzählen Sie mir, na.
Ja, ich musste dem Händler auch so ein paar Sachen erklären.
Aber ist egal. Also, genau.
So wie früher beim Computerkauf eigentlich, ne?
Ja.
Da ist was dran, ja.
Ja, also er fährt super. Man merkt, das ist halt ein typisches Elektroauto im Skateboard-Design.
Sprich, die Batterie ist im Boden und dementsprechend hat er halt einen Schwerpunkt,
der ist irgendwie noch unter der Schuhsohle.
Und das merkt man einfach. Man merkt aber auch, dass das Ding leer zweieinhalb Tonnen hat.
Also das ist jetzt irgendwie kein Leichtfuß in dem Sinne.
Hat aber ordentlich Anzug für so einen Bus. Also das passt schon.
Aber du befährst dich jetzt noch nicht so lange, dass du schon irgendwas über
Reichweiten-Geschichten erzählen könntest.
Also ich war jetzt in Kiel und habe es hin mit einmal Zwischenladen geschafft.
Bin zurück aber nur mit 40 Prozent losgefahren, das heißt ich musste zurück zweimal laden.
Aber der lädt relativ schnell. Der lädt relativ schnell. Er hat ziemlich viel
Ladegeschwindigkeit, ich weiß nicht, was war das, 150 Kilowatt oder sogar mehr?
Also laut Hersteller 175, ich habe jetzt gesehen, das Größte,
was ich gesehen habe, waren 142.
Also ja, Laden ist immer so ein Ding, aber normalerweise kannst du eigentlich
immer rechnen, wenn du bis 80 Prozent lädst, dann ist das eine halbe Stunde,
ist fast egal, welches Auto es ist.
Und je größer der Akku ist, desto mehr kriegst du halt rein in der Zeit.
Nö, also er fährt super. Auch diese ganzen Assistenzsysteme,
da muss man sich auch erstmal dran gewöhnen.
Ich habe auch unbedingt den haben wollen mit den elektrischen Schiebetüren, ist super.
Und die elektrische Heckklappe ist auch super.
Hat der Schiebetüren links und rechts? Ja. Ah ja, fancy. Okay,
naja, dann demnächst auch ein Käfflingplatz.
Das merkt man auch jetzt im, ja, ist noch nicht ganz Winter, aber so gut wie.
Er wird relativ langsam warm, weil da so viel Innenraum zu heizen ist.
Und wenn du beide Schiebetüren aufmachst, dann macht der Wind einmal hui und
dann ist das Auto wieder kalt.
Aber nö, ansonsten bin ich sehr zufrieden damit.
Gut, dann werden wir demnächst davon mehr hören.
Ja, hoffentlich nicht.
So, Ralf. Was ist ein Tahoe-Elektron-Detektor?
Und wieso müssen wir darüber reden?
Also, das habe ich aus der, ich glaube, vorletzten ATP-Folge,
Accidental Tech Podcast.
Ach, jetzt weiß ich erst, wovon du redest. Alles klar, ja, okay, berichte.
Der ein oder die andere von uns hat vielleicht doch schon auch auf macOS Tahoe
aktualisiert und dann passieren Dinge,
dass plötzlich einzelne Apps irgendwie den kompletten Speicher wegknuspern und
man gigabyteweise plötzlich RAM verbraucht hat und ähnliches.
Und nach ein paar Wochen war auch klar, wo das eigentlich herrührt,
nämlich dem Elektron-Framework.
Was, ich versuche es mal irgendwie werteneutral, es ja ermöglicht quasi HTML-Apps
zu bauen, was ich persönlich gut und cool finde.
Ich habe auch ein, zwei selber gebastelt.
Es gibt Leute, die da sehr starke Meinungen zu haben, warum das der Untergang
des Abendlandes und vom Teufel ist. Aber gerade wenn man so Cross-Plattform-mäßig
denkt, ist das einfach doch ein sehr eleganter Weg.
Wie auch immer, Elektron hatte
also in ihrer Form eben, ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie die Schuldfrage.
Da war ich meine sogar, Apple hätte auf seiner Seite was an den APIs so gedreht,
dass es nicht mehr richtig hinpasst. Auf jeden Fall gab es dann relativ schnell
ein Update von Elektron.
So Achtung hier, wir haben das Problem identifiziert und da ist der fix und
aktualisiert mal eure Apps.
Und das muss man dann aber tun und je nach Hersteller und je nach Coder dauert
das dann mal mehr oder mal weniger lange.
Und diese App hier, nämlich der Tahoe-Elektron-Detektor, geht also einmal durch
dein ganzes macOS durch und sucht dir alle Apps raus, die halt Elektronen einsetzen.
Inklusive meine irgendwo im Datei rumlungernden Selbstgebauten,
die nirgendwo irgendwo im Programmeverzeichnis sind oder sowas.
Also der flügt wirklich mal durch und wirft einem dann eine Liste raus mit einer
Auflistung, welche davon schon umgestellt und gefixt sind. Da gibt es einen
grünen Haken und welche noch nicht.
Das habe ich vorhin mal hier im Vorlauf für die Sendung mal durchlaufen lassen.
Und hui, da sind A mal ganz schön viele und B ist da ganz schön viel rot. Ich schmeiß das mal...
in den Chat rein. Wie viele sind das hier?
40, 50 Elektron-Apps und davon sind gerade mal irgendwie sieben aktualisiert.
Und um die restlichen sollte man sich jetzt mal kümmern. Weil ansonsten passieren Dinge.
Ihr könnt das ja bei euch mal starten lassen.
Es ist wirklich traurig zu sehen, was alles irgendwie mit Elektronen läuft.
Also alleine dafür fand ich es schon mal cool, dieses Tool, dass man das mal
so schwarz auf weiß mal ins Auge kriegt, wie auch immer man sich dazu verhält,
es zu wissen ist schon mal gut.
Ja, bei einigen Sachen sieht man, ah, Elektron, ach, deshalb.
Ja, Signal ist, glaube ich, so ein Ding.
Ja, aber Signal ist schon gefixt.
Signal ist gefixt, Slack ist gefixt, Cursor ist gefixt, Metamouse ist gefixt,
Mulvart, VPN ist gefixt.
Das sind die, die bei mir jetzt schon im Reinen sind. Und ich habe gerade... Und Rocket Chat.
Ja, ist bei mir noch rot, aber es kann gut sein.
Dass... Meine Variante ist schon gefixt.
Ja, okay, das...
Hätte ich jetzt auch erwartet.
Ja, also was mich ja wirklich beunruhigt ist, dass hier irgendwie meine Jabra
Extension, die hier irgendwie für diese Kamera ist, dass die irgendwie auch da drunter fällt.
Und außerdem auch noch Dropbox mit so einer Ancient-Version von dem Ganzen unterwegs ist.
Wobei manche wie Discord haben so ihre eigenen Fixes am Start davon.
Aber was mich eigentlich mehr beunruhigt, ist die Tatsache, dass das passiert, dass es möglich ist.
dass ein Programm dem Betriebssystem so die Karten legen kann.
Sie tun das wohl dadurch, dass sie einen undokumentierten Private API benutzen.
Ja, aber ich meine Private API ist aus Gründen Private.
Wenn man die dann benutzt und dann geht es irgendwann nicht mehr,
dann darf man nicht weinen.
Ja, sollte Apple ein OS-Update rausbringen, das Ding umbenennen und irgendwie
alles brechen, was irgendwie das benutzt.
Ich fand es spannend, was halt wie gesagt alles das Arduino,
die Arduino Idee zum Beispiel eine Electron App ist, wusste ich nicht.
Die war immer schon shady, aber ich wusste nicht, dass es Electron ist.
Ich glaube, sie haben sie irgendwann neu geschrieben in Electron,
war vorher irgendwie Java oder so.
Naja, könnt ihr auch mal gucken.
Elektron ist eh das neue Java, ne?
Das hast du gesagt.
Ja,
JavaScript ist das neue Java. Das ist furchtbar.
Na gut, könnt ihr alle mal testen. Ich habe auch was getestet und zwar weiterhin
arbeite ich an meinem Smart Home.
Ich taste mich langsam vor. Ich habe ja letztes Mal berichtet,
dass ich meine Heizung jetzt schon irgendwie angeschlossen habe.
Jetzt starte ich gerade das zweite Kapitel Licht und kann sagen, es ist knifflig.
Also ich habe weiterhin, forsche ich sozusagen auf Ebay nach günstigen Preisen
für dieses ganze Gerät, weil es ja sonst ganz schön teuer sein kann teilweise,
auch wenn die guten Sachen wirklich gut sind.
und nachdem ich also mit Eve bisher sehr gute Erfahrungen gemacht habe,
bin ich dann dem Eve Light Switch hinterher geforscht und bin da auch fündig
geworden und habe also jetzt ein paar davon installiert.
Ein paar gleich?
Ja.
Ich hatte erstmal einen gekauft und wollte dann mal gucken, wie das ist mit
dem Eve Light Switch und jetzt, wo ich einen habe, werde ich auch keinen zweiten kaufen.
Warum?
Weil der einfach zu teuer ist dafür, dass er null Haptik hat.
Irgendwie, wie ich finde.
Und dann...
100 Euro für ein Ding, was nur ein- und ausschaltet?
Listenpreis ist 80, glaube ich.
Ja, ist ja billiger geworden.
Da sind deutlich drunter.
Ja gut, kann sein, dass sie mit dem Preis runtergegangen sind,
weil das schon wirklich viel war.
Ich bin aber großer Fan von diesen Rollladenswitches. Die sind wirklich genial.
Von Yves, die Rollladenswitches. Die sind aber nochmal extra teuer.
Nö, die kosten auch.
Achso, nur der Switch selber, ja?
Nur der Switch selber, ja.
Und der kommuniziert dann mit dem Rollladen wie?
Er schaltet den Motor ein und aus.
Achso, der ist nur ein Motor an, Motor aus, Leitung.
Ja, mehr oder weniger. Das Schöne an den Rollladenswitches ist,
was ich relativ genial finde,
ist, du kannst halt mit dem Magnetkompass von dem Phone quasi dem Switch sagen,
in welche Richtung schaut dieses Fenster.
Du hältst das Phone von innen gegen das Fenster. Der Magnetkompass misst die
Himmelsrichtung und dann weiß er, wann fängt die Sonne an, ins Fenster zu scheinen
und wann hört sie auf, ins Fenster zu scheinen.
Und du kannst dann im Sommer den Beschattungsmodus einschalten,
wo der tatsächlich, wenn die Sonne anfängt, ins Fenster zu scheinen,
den Rollladen runter macht und wenn die Sonne wieder raus ist aus dem Fenster,
den Rollladen wieder hoch macht.
Das ist wirklich in heißen Sommern wirklich sehr geil.
Naja, also ich habe auf jeden Fall den E-Flight Switch genommen und ich muss
sagen, das scheint mir derzeit auch für die Anwendung das beste Produkt zu sein.
Ich habe jetzt mit der Haptik nicht so sehr Probleme, zumal ich ja die Dinger
vor allem deshalb gekauft habe, um sie nicht mehr selber tasten zu müssen,
sondern das sozusagen smart lösen zu können.
Klar, man drückt ja immer noch drauf, deswegen will man es ja auch haben,
aber ich empfinde das als okay, weil du weißt halt, einschalten ist immer oben
und einschalten ist immer unten und das ist halt ein softerer Touch,
aber man gewöhnt sich an alles.
Also solange es nicht kaputt geht, ist das für mich völlig in Ordnung.
Nee, der ist auch super, der Switch. Was ich an den Eve-Sachen auch sehr schön finde, ist,
dass sie dieses Einbaurahmensystem von Eve, da gibt es eine Firma,
da kannst du diese gesamten Einbaurahmen, du kannst auch Steckdosen und du kannst auch normale,
stinknormale Schalter von denen kaufen und das alles kombinieren mit diesen Eve-Sachen.
was ich auch teilweise schon gemacht habe, weil ich in einigen Zimmern habe
ich halt Lichtschalter und Rollladenschalter direkt untereinander als Zweierkombination.
Da kann man den Zweierrahmen kaufen und fertig.
Und alles sieht super aus, als hätte es noch nie anders gehört.
Genau, also das habe ich auch gemacht. Und die eigentliche Herausforderung ist aber die Verkabelung.
Weil du musst halt diesen Switch erstmal mit permanenten Strom versorgen und mit Neutralleiter.
Da muss man schon mal gucken, dass die eigenen Lichtschalter,
die man hat, darüber auch verfügen.
Ja, also dass das nicht so die Sparvariante ist und außerdem hatte ich dann
noch so absurde Kaskaden von Stromverlängerungen und so weiter und merkwürdigen
Doppelnutzungen und also ich musste sozusagen erstmal alles debuggen und mir
erstmal darüber im Klaren sein,
wie ist denn hier überhaupt alles miteinander verschaltet und dann eine größere
Armada von Vago-Klemmen in die ganze Installation rein spenden,
damit das irgendwie lief.
aber als ich das dann endlich alles auf die Kette bekommen habe und die packt
habe, seitdem funktioniert es irgendwie auch wunderbar.
Jetzt bin ich gerade dabei, noch den Rest nachzumachen, weil dann hat man irgendwie alles fettisch.
Was aber dieser Eve Live Switch nicht macht, ist dimmen.
Und das ist so ein bisschen blöd. Es gibt einen Dimmer von Acara,
wo ich mich noch nicht so richtig rantraue, weil ich irgendwie so ein anderes
Produkt von Acara hatte und das kam mir mit so einer völlig hässlichen App und
mache erstmal einen Account in unserer Cloud.
Da habe ich das sofort wieder zurückgeschickt und gesagt, mit euch will ich nichts zu tun haben.
Jetzt habe ich Angst, dass auch dieser Dimmer ähnlich drauf ist und ich will solche Produkte nicht.
Ich möchte nur cloudlose, local-only, Meta- und Thread-basierte Systeme haben, alles andere.
Weißt du, dann geht die Firma pleiter und deine Wohnung funktioniert nicht mehr.
Das ist einfach das Just-to-know.
Aber wenn der Meta hat, dann müsste er eigentlich auch...
Müsste er ja theoretisch, aber warum will dann erstmal die App von mir einen Account haben?
Also das vielleicht habe ich mich auch in dem Moment getäuscht,
aber ich war da einfach zickig und habe gesagt, geh weg.
Ja, sehe ich aber ein.
Was jetzt allerdings ganz spannend, ja, erstmal diese Dimmer-Geschichte, ähm,
Ich habe jetzt so eine Lampensituation, wo so mehrere Leuchtmittel,
also sechs, an einer Stromversorgung hängen.
Das ist ja der Vorteil dieser eingebauten Switches. Also wenn du den Taster
ersetzt, dann schaltest du ja ganz normal wieder alles auf einmal an.
Du musst nicht in jede einzelne Lampe so ein smartes Leuchtmittel reinsetzen,
was ja auch manche Leute machen.
Kannst du machen, ja.
Ja, aber dann brauchst du halt auch immer Strom. Du kannst ja mit dem Schalter
der ganzen Installation den Strom nehmen und dann kannst du es halt nicht einschalten.
Dann kannst du sagen, okay, dann verzichtest du auch auf den Schalter.
Aber dann hast du halt auch irgendwie nicht so, dann fehlt dir so ein bisschen
der Schalt mal alles ein und es gibt derzeit noch sehr wenige reine Smart-Schalter,
die man ja dann vielleicht haben wollen würde.
Dass man sagt, okay, ich lege da oben einfach dauerhaft Strom hin und so weiter.
Gut, ich könnte den Strom auch wegnehmen, dann wäre der Strom immer dran und
dann, das mache ich vielleicht auch, aber so ist es irgendwie alles noch so
ein bisschen weird, weil dann müsste ich ja alle Leuchtmittel durch smarte Leuchtmittel ersetzen.
Dann wäre immer Strom dran.
Hab ich gemacht.
Dann wäre immer Strom dran. Das hast du gemacht?
Also mit allen Lampen, die wir irgendwo in der Wohnung hatten. Die sind alle smart.
Und die Schalter sind aber dumm geblieben. Das heißt also dieses Szenario,
okay, jetzt ist Schalter auf, off.
Dann ist natürlich die smarte Birne tot. Das ist so.
Dann ist sie nicht mehr smart.
Aber daran sind halt alle gewohnt und da halt alle irgendwie mit Siri an der
Hand durch die Gegend laufen.
Hast du dir einfach angewöhnt, so Schlafzimmer aus. und dann geht es halt Schlafzimmer aus.
Aber auch erst wenn du halt im Bett liegst, musst nicht schon vorher und so,
also es hat nur Vorteile.
Die sind alle dimmbar und ich liebe es.
Ich habe das halt so, also im Schlafzimmer da ist der eine Schalter,
den ich habe, der eine E-Flight-Switch und da hängt an der großen Lampe,
wo ein dummes Leuchtmittel drin ist und kann man halt trotzdem per,
Sprachsteuerung oder sonst was, kann ich den halt trotzdem ausmachen,
weil es ist ja ein smarter Switch und alles andere sind aber smarte Leuchtmittel,
sodass ich mir halt auf so eine Multi-
Button-Ding halt verschiedene Szenen programmiert habt, wo es mal heller und mal weniger hell ist.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall alles, man muss wirklich gucken. Also vielleicht
mache ich mal diese Variante mit, ich setze die Lampe dauerhaft auf Strom und
habe dann sozusagen nur noch smarte Dinger drin, damit ich dann da Farbe und
Dimmen und so weiter habe, wenngleich das dann auch nicht über den Schalter geht.
Aber eigentlich hätte ich gerne lieber so einen Dimmer-Schalter,
der sowohl einschalten als auch dimmen kann, damit man mit so einer Handbewegung
das macht und nicht jedes Mal Telefon zücken muss oder mit dieser bekloppten
Siri sich unterhalten muss, die wirklich so ein dummes Vieh ist.
Aber Licht kann sie.
Licht kann sie?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich bin der Erste, der da macht. Doch, doch.
Ich widerspreche hart.
Doch, alle Lampen ausgeht bei mir immer.
Ja, ein Scheiß geht bei mir immer.
Ein Raum, kann ich sagen, Wohnzimmer auf 50. Das läuft.
Du musst halt kurz und präzise und exakt mit dir reden. Dann geht das.
Ja, mach alle Lampen aus. Ja, ja, hab ich in deinem Zimmer nicht gefunden.
Ja, das ist aber nicht ein Problem von Siri, sondern wie die Lampen untereinander
dann ihre Informationen weitergeben.
Ja, die Frage ist eher, wie nennt man die, damit man immer das richtige Target hat.
Aber dann hatte ich zum Beispiel mal zum Test eine smarte Lampe in diese ich
schalte alles ein und aus Lampe, also eine von sechs ersetzt,
einfach warum wir uns so sehen, wie das so ist.
Und dann so, ja, schalt mal, wunsch mal Licht an. Und dann Siri so, ja, okay, schaltet an.
Und dann war aber zu dem Zeitpunkt natürlich, die eine hatte noch keinen,
also die smarte Lampe davon, hatte noch keinen Strom.
Ja, bis die hochbootet und sich im Netz einwählt, musst du natürlich warten.
Klar, aber Siri versucht natürlich sofort, an alle irgendwie zu machen.
Und dann kommt sie mir so, ja, aber die eine Lampe konnte ich nicht finden.
Und das ist mir einfach zu geschwätzig. Also das geht einfach gar nicht.
Ich muss das irgendwie mal gucken. Also ich hoffe, dass da demnächst gute Dimmer,
an Start sind, weil es muss ja ein lösbares Problem sein, wenn man so einen
normalen Schalter macht, muss man ja irgendwie auch dimmen können.
Es gibt noch die Hardware, die ganz harte Hardware Lösung von Ikea,
diese Lampe, die so auseinander klappt, wenn man am Band zieht,
diese die manche Supernova-Lampe nennen.
Und diese hässlichen Plastikteile von Ikea.
Ich finde die nicht so hässlich, aber die Die dimmen tatsächlich,
also wenn man die zuklappt, dann ist es dunkler.
Okay, naja, apropos Ikea. Ikea hat jetzt angekündigt, zumindest haben sie das
für die USA angekündigt, aber ich denke mal, das wird dann auch ein weltweiter
Trend sein, dass sie jetzt ihre ganzen Smart-Geschichten auch auf Matter und Thread umstellen.
Das finde ich natürlich super, weil ich ja gesagt habe, ich mache Thread-only.
Also auf jeden Fall Thread-only. Ich will auf gar keinen Fall ein zweites Funksystem
noch haben und dann mit Bridges und dann wird alles ganz kompliziert.
Nee, Thread funktioniert auch umso besser, je mehr du davon hast.
Also das ist wirklich so. Die Erfahrung habe ich gemacht.
Also da bin ich auch total von überzeugt und offensichtlich treibt das jetzt auch alle vor sich her.
Auch Philips Hue hat jetzt angekündigt, dass sie Thread-Varianten von ihren Lampen rausbringen.
Also gehen da auch vielleicht nicht unbedingt weg von Zigbee,
aber halt so Dual-Protokoll.
jetzt wäre es noch schön, wenn Shelly auch endlich mal reagiert und sagt,
hier unsere ganzen Einbauteile machen wir jetzt auch mit Thread,
weil das sind die einzigen, die das noch nicht machen.
Aber wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, dann ist Thread ja so ein Standard,
der so ein bisschen auf Zigbee aufbaut.
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, wie
verwandt die jetzt sind, aber es sollte auch irgendwie ähnliche Hardware.
Sie fahren nur ein anderes Protokoll oder irgendwie sowas. also wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe das kann jetzt Unsinn sein Ja.
Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, müsste ich nochmal gucken, kann sein,
auf jeden Fall Thread ist irgendwie,
IPv6 basiertes Mesh Networking und funktioniert irgendwie super Ja.
Du darfst auf dem Mac dann kein Discovery aufmachen das ist dieses Zero Conf,
Bonjour hieß mal Bonjour Browser das ist dieses diese App.
Also funkmäßig sind sie sich wohl ziemlich ähnlich hier Zigbee und Thread aber
Thread ist halt IP basiert.
Ja, und ist vor allen Dingen halt auch ein Mesh-Netzwerk. Das ist der Punkt.
Zigbee ist halt Hub to Point.
Nee, Zigbee ist auch Mesh?
Nee, Zigbee brauchst du immer. Jedes Leuchtmittel muss in Hörweite der Basisstation sein.
Was du bei Thread eben nicht hast.
Also eigentlich ist jedes Thread-Gerät, was dauerhaft am Strom hängt, auch ein Router.
also die ganzen Schalter und das Zeug, was du da verbaut hast.
Oder aber Lampen, die ständig Strom haben.
Insofern, wie ich gesagt habe, also je mehr Thread-Geräte du hast,
desto robuster wird das Netzwerk, weil die dann einfach besser Daten austauschen können.
Warum haben sie es denn Thread genannt? Der Name Gilgamesh lag da so nah.
Gilgamesh.
Ja, mal gucken Ich finde es redet jetzt auch nicht so einen tollen Namen Aber
es heißt nochmal so wie es heißt Können wir jetzt wenig dran drehen Es.
Könnte schlechter sein.
Ich werde auf jeden Fall weiter berichten Ich hoffe, dass ich mein Stromproblem
Da irgendwie elegant gelöst bekomme Und mal schauen, Jalousien und so Finde
ich auch ganz interessant,
Mal gucken, also du sagst, dieser Controller Der braucht im Prinzip nur Zu einem normalen,
Also ist es für Jalousien oder für Rollos?
Ich habe Rollos, Dinger, die außen sind, außen am Fenster.
Ja, mit Rollo meine ich fährt hoch, fährt runter und ist immer gleich und eine
Jalousie kann ja… Achso.
Nee, nee, Rollo ist dieses Plastikzeug außen am Fenster.
Ja.
Genau, du lernst ihn einmal an, dass er weiß, wann ist oben,
wann ist unten, wie lange fährt er da und dann kannst du eben halt sagen,
jetzt fahr 50 Prozent und so.
wobei das auch ganz merkwürdig ist, ich kann mir immer nicht merken,
30% ist glaube ich 30% offen oder 30% zu, es ist irgendwie unlogisch.
Aber,
Gut, soviel zum Smart Home,
So, wollen wir schon unser großes Thema angehen oder wollen wir noch ein paar Sachen vorher greifen?
Mal langsam das große Thema, oder?
Oder noch? Du jetzt im Wesentlichen hier mit Themen noch in der Liste bist,
kannst du das selber empfehlen.
Was?
Ich würde dir sonst noch deine Themen vorziehen und das kannst du dann selber entscheiden.
Achso, dann lass doch vielleicht irgendwie Cursor 2 noch kurz machen.
Oder ich rede noch kurz über die Konferenz, geht wirklich schnell.
Kann man auch erstmal einschieben.
Also ich war in Italien, in Bologna auf der Pragma-Conference.
Das müsst ihr euch alles nicht mehr merken, weil die Veranstalter im Closing
gesagt haben, dass sie die Konferenz jetzt nicht mehr machen werden.
Es war insgesamt eine Konferenz, die zwar eigentlich sehr schön war und die
Speaker waren auch alle super, aber irgendwie hat man schwer das Gefühl,
dass in der Apple Developer Community die Luft raus ist. Das haben einfach alle keinen Bock mehr.
das ist irgendwie das okay.
Warum warst du dann da?
Also was gab es da?
Na, es gab so diverse Talks über die Technologien von Apple und so weiter.
Also ich würde jetzt ein bisschen zu weit führen, das alles auszuführen,
das kann man sich ja mal im Internet durchlesen, was es da jetzt genau gab.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, es gab auch so ein paar, ich nenne sie mal Ami-Talks,
wo dann, kennt ihr diese Talks, wo so ein Amerikaner irgendwie großes Storytelling macht,
weißt du, so ein Dreiviertelstunden-Slot, eine halbe Stunde,
wird mithilfe einer aufgebauschten Geschichte auf das Thema hingearbeitet und
man denkt nur so, komm doch mal auf den Punkt, komm doch mal auf den Punkt.
und dann kommt er auf den Punkt, dann hat er keinen Punkt.
Warum hält man solche Talks? Ich verstehe es nicht.
Um kostenlos auf die Veranstaltung zu kommen.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Echt so Butter bei die Fische, Alter.
Ja, okay. Also du warst auf einer Apple-Konferenz und es war nicht so gut,
dass jemand das nochmal machen wollen würde.
Nein, die Konferenz war schon gut. Also das will ich nicht gesagt haben.
Die Konferenz war gut, Aber das Team, das die Konferenz macht,
ist irgendwie ausgebrannt. Wir haben keinen Bock mehr scheinbar.
Die war jetzt auch nicht ausverkauft.
Also mir wurde berichtet, dass vor zwei Jahren oder so der Saal noch irgendwie
so voll war, dass man kaum Sitzplätze gekriegt hat. Das war diesmal nicht so.
Und sagt das mehr über die Konferenz oder mehr über die Plattform aus?
Also für mein Dafürhalten waren die Sprecher schon größtenteils wirklich gut
und haben auch gute Sachen gemacht.
Ich glaube, es sagt mehr was über die Plattform aus. Also es ist so ein bisschen die Luft raus gewesen.
Also, ja, keine Ahnung. Das war so ein bisschen schade, das war so ein bisschen deprimierend.
Allerdings, Italien wieder, Bologna, Essen war gut.
Ja, am ersten Abend haben wir eine super Pizza gegessen, am letzten Abend dachte ich, isste noch,
Bolognese, wie es so schön heißt, also Ragua la Bolognese.
Ich habe mich dann dafür entschieden, eine Lasagne zu essen,
da ist die ja auch drin, die war wirklich gut. Letztes Thema, aber auch durch.
So, Körser.
Körser, genau, unsere liebste Vibe Coding Plattform hat ein großes Update gekriegt,
die 2er Version, so vor einem Monat oder sowas ungefähr.
Und da sind ein paar Neuerungen drin, die schon ganz spannend sind und die ich
jetzt in den letzten Nächten auch mal so ein bisschen in den C reingehalten
habe, so wie sich das so auf meine 13 Projekte auswirken.
Benutzt du Cursor oder hast du das mal benutzt, Jens?
Nicht wirklich, nee.
Überhaupt Vibe-Coding?
Er lächelt nur Ich lächle nur.
Ja Mit deiner gewissen Abscheu im Gesicht.
Kannst du dich da gerne zu äußern?
Ich glaube schon, dass das irgendwie Irgendwann dann auch alternativlos ist,
Dass man das einsetzt Weil sonst fällt man einfach hinterher Ich schreibe einfach
nicht mehr so richtig viel Code Und wenn ich es dann mache Dann,
Schreibe ich es auch gerne per Hand Ja So sieht es aus,
Aber ich verstehe auch, dass es für viele Leute dann eine Möglichkeit bietet,
überhaupt mal in die Umsetzung der eigenen Ideen einzusteigen und sehe das auch
bei Leuten, die ich als sehr, sehr klug ansehe, dass die da sehr viel mitgenommen haben.
Ich habe so ein bisschen Sorgen.
Es gibt ja so verschiedene Rollen, die man einnehmen kann.
Also dieser ganze Bereich Junior Developer wird dann wohl wegfallen. Und dann frage ich mich.
Wo kommt der Nachwuchs her? Das hatten wir ja schon ein paar Mal auch, ja.
Und ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass es wirklich Probleme geben kann bei einigen
Leuten, die halt wirklich vollkommen bei Alpcoding sozialisiert sind.
Ein bisschen so wie an der, ich glaube das ist an der FU, wo bei dem Einführungskurs
in Informatik mittlerweile erklärt werden muss, was ein Verzeichnis ist und wie ein Pfad aussieht.
Weil die kennen keine Dateien mehr.
Genau, die kennen keine Dateien mehr.
Oh Gott.
So kann ich mir vorstellen, dass bei Leuten, die halt wirklich durchs Vibe-Coding
ins Coding gekommen sind, dann auch vielleicht nicht unbedingt das Wissen für
Architektur, für Planung von größeren Projekten da ist, weil…,
Das fällt ja alles aus dem Computer raus.
Jaja, also das sind alles valide Punkte und das ist definitiv da.
Ich denke, es ist halt wie mit allen Werkzeugen, man muss mal gucken,
wofür man es am besten zum Einsatz bringt.
Ich denke, der allergrößte Nutzen liegt eher so im Prototyping auf der einen
Seite, also wenn man sich jetzt wirklich Code erzeugen lässt,
aber ich rede viel mit Leuten, die das benutzen Und viele sagen so,
nee, so aus meinem Code lasse ich das raus, aber Doku, Tests, dafür ist einfach mega.
Also eine Code-Analyse, Code lesen lassen, analysieren lassen,
nach bestimmten Funktionen gucken oder auch, sagen wir mal so,
automatisiert bestimmte Umbenennungen vorzunehmen, wo du sonst wahnsinnig wirst,
dafür ist es einfach ein irres Tool.
Und wenn man halt weiß, was man tun müsste sozusagen und es dann wirklich nur
noch Handarbeit ist, ist darüber dann gut zu automatisieren,
da finde ich überhaupt nichts falsch dran.
Aber wenn es ums Codenlernen geht und so weiter, dann sollte man schon aufpassen,
dass man da dem Kind nicht zu früh das Smartphone in die Hand gibt.
Ja, also das haben wir in der Tat die Position schon in der Sendung schon ein
paar Mal rauf und runter dektiniert.
Das ist für die Leute, die gut programmieren können, ist das plötzlich irgendwie
schon am Rande einer Offenbarung.
Für alle anderen ist es auch einfach mal eine große Gefahr, die da auf uns zurollt.
Also was ich auf jeden Fall unterschreiben würde, ist es unter den generativen KI-Anwendungen,
Die ist, wo ich am meisten Positives sehe, wo ich auch denke,
das wird am ehesten noch überleben.
Also da gibt es viel Quatsch, wo Leute sagen, da muss unbedingt generative KI rein.
Das wird in ein paar Jahren, werden wir dann noch drüber lachen,
dass wir mal das irgendwie geglaubt haben.
Aber bei Code, vor allem dieser Boilerplate-Code, den du ja immer in irgendwelchen
Softwareprojekten drin hast. Ja klar, warum solltest du dann nicht die schlauste
Autovervollständigung der Welt mit beauftragen?
So ein Feature, also eins der neuen Feature, die jetzt Cursor 2 bekommen hat,
ist ein integrierter Browser, auf das dann halt Cursor vollen Zugriff hat in seinem Agent-Modus.
Und der ganze Kram oder ich sag mal 80% dessen, was ich irgendwie so baue an
Tools ist halt alles so klassisch Web-App,
JavaScript und irgendwas Datenbank und Visualisierungsframeworks und gib ihm
so und da ist natürlich jetzt die Verheißung groß zu sagen, okay,
ich muss jetzt nicht mehr irgendwo noch im separaten Browser ständig irgendwie
die Dev-Tools offen haben und dann wieder die Fehlermeldung aus der Konsole
rauskopieren und eben wieder in Cursor reinkopieren.
Und stattdessen sagst du jetzt im Cursor, starte unsere App in deinem internen
Browser und hab einen Blick auf die Fehler in der JavaScript-Konsole und komm
erst wieder, wenn da alles läuft.
Das kannst du so schreiben. Das heißt also auch so nicht, okay,
beheb Fehler A und dann Fehler B, sondern wirklich exakt so,
wie ich es gerade gesagt habe, kannst du das machen.
Und dann fräst er sich da durch und das alleine hat jetzt so meine letzten Experimente
sicherlich so um den Faktor 5 beschleunigt, weil du einfach...
Und ganz viel Kram, dann gar nicht mehr in Kontakt trittst dabei.
Das geht auch so weit, dass er deine Web-App fernsteuert.
Das heißt also, wenn du sagst, probiere die Drilldown-Suche aus,
ob da die richtigen Treffer rauskommen. Der klickt auf Buttons,
der füllt Formulare aus, der analysiert den Output, auch dessen, was er sieht.
Er kann Screenshots machen, um sich nicht nur jetzt irgendwie so am theoretischen
DOM zu orientieren, sondern auch zu sehen, wie wird es wirklich real gerendert.
Das ist schon crazy.
Es ist in der letzten Implementierung, ich bin jetzt auf der aktuellsten Version,
ist es nicht wirklich perfekt. Das heißt also, er vergisst häufig mal,
dass er überhaupt einen internen Browser hat.
So ist klar, es ist halt ein LLM dahinter, dem du ständig wieder beibringen
musst, was es darf und was es nicht darf, weil es das selber einfach nicht weiß.
Das ist ja letztendlich so das, was Cursor da auch dann zugibt an Icing halt.
Und auch wie, also selbst so ganz simple Sachen so wie, okay,
mach jetzt einen harten Reload, damit deine Codeänderungen überhaupt sichtbar werden im Browser.
Aus irgendeinem obskuren Grund bekommt er das auch nicht hin.
Er behauptet, er macht einen harten Reload und sagt ja auch,
er wird jetzt sogar die richtigen Tasten drücken, aber sichtlich siehst du in
dem Browserfenster, was du natürlich auch sehen kannst, dass er keinen harten
Reload macht und wenn du selber den anschiebst, dann läuft es plötzlich so.
Also gut, aber das werden die innerhalb von Wochen irgendwie gefixt haben,
da werde ich jetzt nicht der Einzige sein, der darüber stolpert.
Da bin ich ganz zuversichtlich.
Also das ist ein Feature, was ich sage, das ist cool, dass sie das haben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das so dieser integrierte Browser in der Coding-Umgebung,
ob das die anderen Großen schon vorher auch hatten.
Wisst ihr das? Das von GitHub-Copilot?
Ist mir, wäre mir neu, aber weiß ich auch nicht sicher.
Also ich merke jetzt so bei meinen Geschichten, dass mich so diese kleinen Nicklichkeiten
so ärgern, dass ich dann 50% der Zeit dann doch in einem echten Browser nebenbei
noch irgendwie unterwegs bin, um da irgendwie nochmal einen Benchmark zu haben.
Aber da würde ich mal sagen, das ist ein total gut verstandenes,
lösbares Problem, das werden die irgendwie mit ein paar Releases in den Griff kriegen.
So und das zweite, worauf ich gespannt war, ist, dass sie selber jetzt ein Coding-Modul
damit rausgegeben haben.
Also ein Model.
Ein Model, genau. Ein Model. Was eben hochspezialisiert eben nur auf Code-Generierung
sein soll und Software-Architektur.
Also bisher haben wir ja schon ein paar Mal diskutiert.
Wir haben gerne mit Claude Sonnet gearbeitet. Irgendwie die erste 3.5er,
dann die 3.7er, dann die 4.0er, jetzt die 4.5er. Da kommen ja auch so alle paar
Monate neue Releases raus.
ChatGPT 5 oder 5.1, jetzt ganz frisch, habe ich irgendwie an der letzten Sendung
schon gesagt, dass ich das ganz, ganz manierlich fand, dass da auch ChatGPT aufgeholt hat.
Und jetzt habe ich wirklich etliche Nächte mal mit Composer 1 verbracht.
Das ist schon gut. Also das schwimmt da jetzt bei den Anwendungsfällen, die ich habe.
Und ich kann gleich nochmal erzählen, dass ich da auch die Komplexität nochmal
ein bisschen hochgedreht habe.
Schwimmt das aber locker mit auf der Ebene. Das finde ich dafür,
dass es so ihr erster Aufschlag ist in der Runde, erstaunlich.
Und es ist irre schnell.
Es ist also, würde ich sagen, um den Faktor 5 schneller als JetGPT 5.1 und auch
deutlich schneller, mindestens dreimal schneller als das letzte Sonnet-Modell.
Und das ist dann auch so ein Faktor.
Weil jetzt auf etwas kompliziertere Ausgaben wartest du bei ChatGPT 5.1 teilweise
schon mal zwölf Minuten, bis der sich so mal richtig zusammengefunden hat.
Zwölf Minuten?
Da werden ganz schön Bäume gerodet.
Was meinst du mit JET GPT-1?
JET GPT 5.1.
Ach so, 5.1.
Das ist nochmal eine Verbesserung vom Fim war, dass es irgendwie vor ein paar
Tagen rausgekommen ist.
Also das dauert schon. Dafür sind die Ergebnisse dann aber auch meistens schon
wirklich für jetzt nicht auf den Code geguckt, aber für das,
was halt das Outcome ist, schon perfekt. Das ist also so diese One-Shot.
Und es funktioniert einfach. Quote ist bei den neuen Modellen wirklich hoch.
und da schlägt sich Composer 1 aber wirklich wacker. Also ich habe das jetzt
im Moment als mein Standardmodell drin.
Composer ist jetzt von wem?
Das ist von Cursor selber.
Das überrascht mich halt enorm, weil der Laden ja im Prinzip so eine Art sich
eigentlich darauf konzentriert hat,
LLMs überhaupt, also Coding Agents in den Editor zu integrieren und alles drum
herum zu bauen, aber dass die jetzt hinter den Kulissen sogar an ihrem eigenen Modell bauen.
Das hat mich ehrlich gesagt ganz schön umgehauen. Deswegen bin ich da auch erst
mal ein bisschen skeptisch, was dabei rauskommt.
Aber wenn du meinst, das hat schon mal ganz gute Ergebnisse,
dann klingt das ja schon mal ganz interessant.
Sicherlich ist das immer noch so ein Markt, wo auch,
der Wettbewerb richtig stramm ist.
Also so zwischen JGPT und Anthropic,
da geht es ja hin und her und auch die Chinesen sind ja mit einigen Coding-Modellen
am Start, da habe ich aber jetzt relativ wenig Erfahrung mit und man merkt ja
auch jedes halbe Jahr, wie viel besser das wird.
Die Geschwindigkeit der Entwicklung ist stunning, einfach irre.
wo ich vor einem Jahr noch habe Sachen erklären müssen.
Was bei mir wirklich viel geändert hat mit Cursor, das kam ja vorher schon,
ist so dieses Planen als Konzept.
Das hat sich ja auch irgendwie so ein bisschen so entwickelt.
Auf einmal geht dieser Agent einfach anders vor. Und jetzt hast du ja sogar
einen expliziten Planungsmodus.
Das heißt, du kannst wirklich sagen, ich will jetzt nur planen.
Damit verhinderst du, dass der irgendwie losrennt.
und dann erstmal, ja, hier habe ich dir schon fertig gebaut und du so,
ah, ich habe dir noch gar nicht alles zu Ende erzählt,
dass du sozusagen erstmal so Gedanken fasst und vielleicht auch einfach in diesem
Planungsmodus drin bleibst, einfach nur so, ja,
ich will das und das bauen, was brauche ich und ich habe immer sehr gute Erfahrungen
damit mit, ich motiviere einfach immer den Agenten, mich Sachen zu fragen,
ich will das und das machen und wie, wo siehst du noch Probleme,
stell mir Fragen.
Wo ich unter Umständen noch ein bisschen doppeldeutig bin und diese Rückfragen sind einfach Gold wert.
Ja hast du das bedacht und hier das ist so ein bisschen ambiguous und hier weiß
ich nicht so genau was du meinst und dann merke ich selber dadurch erst,
dass mein Gedankenmodell noch Fehler hat oder ich zumindest nicht so klar definiert
habe, was eigentlich wirklich gewünscht ist.
Ist ja mal so leicht so, ja ich hab gesagt du sollst mir das bauen und da kam nur Scheiße bei raus.
Ja, weil Shit in, Shit out. Das alte Spiel zählt halt hier in gewisser Hinsicht auch.
Ja, also ich kann immer kurz so den Stack runterbeten, den ich jetzt so in den
letzten Tagen bearbeitet habe.
Ausgangspunkt war eine Excel-Datei mit knapp 4000 Zeilen und das war so eine
Datenbank zu Musikalben und Benotung und Band,
jetzt also nichts überkomplexes, aber halt schon ein bisschen Daten.
und da habe ich mal mit RAC-Modellen gespielt.
Das heißt, das mal in quasi einen Vektordatenbank-Format transferieren lassen,
das gut in der LLM embedded eingebunden werden kann und wo die dann auch Bezug
drauf nimmt und das versteht.
RAG.
Retrieval Augmented Generation.
Genau, danke. Link gibt es in die Shownotes dazu.
Und da hatte ich bisher immer so einen Hüllenrespekt vor, weil das nämlich genau
die Technik ist, mit der wir hier, hatte ich vor einem Jahr mal erzählt,
bei uns in unserem Bibliothekskatalog reingeladen haben, damit man sich mit
dem Bibliothekskatalog unterhalten kann.
Seit letzten Wochenende ist dieser Respekt verflogen, weil die Funktion hatte
ich in fünf Minuten mir von Cursor mit dem Composer 1 Modell schreiben lassen.
Das heißt also, der hat einfach die Excel-Tabber Tabelle genommen,
hat einen OpenAI-Standarddienst genommen zum Anlegen von Racks,
hat die Daten da reingeschrieben, das Ganze an den LLM gekoppelt,
als Orchestrierungsknoten in der Mitte, habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt,
nämlich immer Open Router,
wo ich quasi API-Zugriff auf sämtliche relevanten LLM-Modelle habe und dort
ist nämlich genau auch so eine Rack-Generierung mit erreichbar.
Die scheiß App, dass ich mich also mit dieser Excel-Tabelle unterhalten konnte,
war wirklich in zehn Minuten fertig.
Und von da aus nur noch ein bisschen Feintuning.
Und das hätte ich wieder mal nicht für möglich gehalten.
Das war jetzt mit Composer oder mit?
Das war mit Composer 1 Modell.
Ja.
Der hat auf der ganzen Strecke praktisch keinen Fehler gemacht.
Ich habe dann noch, das war aber eher so ein Spaßprojekt, weil ich quasi einen
Wissenschaftler simulieren möchte, der Experte ist, von dem nämlich auch diese Daten kommen.
und dann habe ich von dem dann noch einen Podcast genommen, wo er über quasi
sein Musikverständnis spricht, habe das durch eine Whisper-Instanz gejagt,
dass ich den Volltext habe und habe dann Cursor gesagt, so schau mal hier, Stunde Interview,
schreib mir mal einen LLM-System Prompt, der möglichst exakt den Charakter dieser
Person abbildet in Bezug darauf, was für eine Rhetorik setzt er ein,
was für Bilder setzt er ein, was ist so sein Wertekosmos, in dem immer unterwegs ist,
hat auch fantastisch funktioniert.
Also du hast es durchgelesen und dachte, fuck, das ist genau die Person.
Wie viel du also aus einer Stunde Audio rauskriegst. Das würde hier mit dem
Podcast mit Sicherheit auch gut funktionieren.
So, und das habe ich dann noch verdrahtet damit.
Das heißt also, dass dann gesagt wird, so Rollenspiel, du bist jetzt also diese
Person, da ist dein System-Prompt und beziehe dich aber die ganze Zeit bei allem,
wenn du über Musik redest, immer und ausschließlich auf die Daten aus dem Rack-Modell.
Und da muss man dann schon so ein bisschen gegentreten, aber das glaube ich
war überhaupt nicht das Problem von Cursor oder von dem,
Von dem Modell, was ich da genommen habe, sondern das war dann eigentlich eher
so Handarbeit, wie balancierst du halt verschiedene Parameter dann aus.
Und ich habe dann ja aber einen Stand erreicht, wo ich sagen würde,
Wahnsinn, dass das also ohne Profitools einfach nur mit hier habt ihr 20 Euro
im Monat, dass ich da in so kurzer Zeit jetzt auf so ein Level gekommen bin.
Also du kannst dich jetzt mit dem unterhalten und du denkst,
der sitzt dir gegenüber.
Genauso wird er reden und er redet über genau das, worüber er auch sonst so redet. Also crazy shit.
Also von daher Respekt hier an die Cursor-Leute, was sie da mit dem Composer 1 hingelegt haben.
Ich glaube aber, es war für die fast alternativlos, weil ich weiß nicht,
ob du das kennst, diese Legion von Blogartikeln, die herrechnen,
wann Cursor quasi bankrott ist und wann die Blase platzen muss,
weil sie so irre viele Lizenzen an OpenAI und Sonnet, glaube ich, vor allen Dingen auch,
die sind mit Cloud ja relativ eng verbandelt,
zahlen müssen, um irgendwie ihren ganzen Operationsbetrieb aufrechterhalten zu können.
und mit dem eigenen Modell sind sie natürlich da draußen.
Aber dass sie das jetzt so irgendwo hergeholt haben.
Ein eigenes Modell erzeugt ja auch erstmal Kosten.
Betriebskosten schon.
Ja, aber dass sie überhaupt das Team haben, um sowas zu machen.
Sie haben natürlich interessante Erfahrungen.
Sie haben auch die Daten, wenn sie die abschnorcheln.
Das denke ich auch. Die werden auf einem sehr großen Pool sitzen.
Weil immer wenn jemand eine Frage stellt, es kommt was zurück,
dann wird noch per Hand nachgearbeitet.
Wenn du das alles capturen kannst als Daten, dann kannst du ein verdammt gutes Modell trainieren.
Genau, das kannst du am Anfang bei Cursor irgendwo, beim ersten Start gibst
du das ja an, ob da in der ganzen Daten für Trainings genutzt werden können oder nicht.
Und wie üblich werden da 80% drüber lesen und per Dark Pattern ist das auch irgendwie.
Das war mir jetzt auch nicht, das habe ich mich nicht in Erinnerung.
Ja siehst du, dunkelgraue Schrift auf mittelgrauem Hintergrund und im Keller von Alpha Centauri.
Hättest du es nachlesen können. Können sie gerne mitladen, ich lerne ja auch eine Menge.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall war das jetzt die letzten Wochen für mich wieder dieser
Moment, okay, das ist alles noch so nicht zu Ende erzählt.
Da passiert immer noch so viel Spannendes Neues.
Absolut, also das ist der Turbo, die Geschwindigkeit, mit der die auch Updates raushauen.
Ich meine, fast bei jedem Launch hast du eine neue Version.
Das ist crazy Shit.
Ich habe in einer Stunde einen Connector gebaut, das ich aus Discourse,
die Plattform, die ja auch der wir auch das Sendegate betreiben,
Open Source, Community-System, dass ich in Discourse sagen kann,
leg mir hier mal eine Word-Datei an in diesem Beitrag.
Dann wird im Hintergrund mal eine Nextcloud-Instanz angeschoben über WebDAV,
wird eine leere XLS-Datei angelegt.
Der Link, die URL dazu, wird zurückgeliefert an Discourse, die wird dann automatisch
gepasst in den Artikel reingesetzt und wenn jemand draufklickt,
wird dann sofort eine Collabora-Instanz hochgefahren und du hast sofort einen Online-Editor.
Ich habe jetzt einen Workflow, wo ich aus unserem Intranet heraus jeder sagen
kann, hier brauche ich jetzt mal eine Word-Datei, auf der beliebig viele Leute
gleichzeitig editieren können.
Die müssen nicht in Nextcloud drüber wechseln, die müssen sich nicht um Rechte
kümmern, sondern die gehen einfach nur da, wo sie gerade arbeiten mit ihrem
Team ohnehin und sagen so, hier Word-Datei, zack und mit einem Klick läuft der ganze Laden.
In Discourse.
In Discourse, ja.
Im Webforum eine Word-Datei bearbeiten.
Die auf einer Nextcloud liegt, die du aber nie siehst. Die ist einfach komplett
transparent. Die wird nur als DMS dazwischen gelegt.
Das Stück Software, was du geschrieben hast, plagt sich wo wie ein?
Das ist eine Theme-Component in Discord. Liegt auf GitHub.
Eine Theme-Component?
Genau.
Die läuft dann in JavaScript oder was?
Genau. Also Discord, das ist glaube ich nicht JavaScript, sondern,
Sprache müsste ich jetzt gucken. Sehe ich ja nicht beim Valkon.
Du hast was programmiert, aber du weißt auch nicht, von welcher Programmiersprache.
So weit ist es gekommen.
So weit ist es zugekommen. Ja, das ist sportlich.
Ja, so Discourse hat halt ein Plug-in-System, dass du entweder Plug-ins schreiben
kannst, die du dann aber immer kompilieren musst.
Das ganze Jahr Ruby on Rails. Dann musst du halt erstmal wieder Server runterfahren
und die App neu durchkompilieren. Und das dauert so fünf, sieben Minuten oder sowas.
Und dann hast du das drin und das ist ein bisschen umständlich und der elegantere
oder einfachere Weg ist, dass du nur eine Theme-Component nimmst.
Ich glaube, es ist aber JavaScript, in der du dann halt nur JavaScript zur Verfügung
hast und nicht auf alle tiefgreifenden Datenlayer von Discourse Zugriff hast,
aber auf viele und für den Anwendungsfall hat es völlig gereicht.
Und dann kannst du halt wirklich sagen, okay, schreib das Ganze gleich auf GitHub.
Du kannst das GitHub-Repo in Discourse einbinden als Team Component und drückst
dann da einfach immer nur auf aktualisieren.
Cursor schreibt selbstständig in mein GitHub-Repo rein. So und von daher habe
ich dann also so einen Test-Workflow, ohne überhaupt irgendwo eine lokale Installation
haben zu müssen, dass ich innerhalb von quasi sieben Sekunden ungefähr eine
neue Version durchtesten kann.
In einem öffentlich, also nicht wirklich öffentlich, aber in meinem Test-Diskurs-System.
Und das sind alles solche Sachen, so dieses Speed-Increase, die du hast.
Und dann gehe ich halt hin und kann auf Arbeit sagen, ich behaupte nicht,
dass es geht, dass du mit einem Klick in Discourse eine Wörterteile anlegst
und sie ist editierbar, sondern ich kann euch zeigen, dass es geht.
Ich habe es nämlich gebaut. so und dann kann ich immer noch hingehen und das
einer vernünftigen bude geben so guck mal hier,
da ist der proof of concept und das baut jetzt mal in ordentlich und das gibt
dann auch vernünftig in die discourse community zurück so und das exakt die
geschichten machen wir jetzt auch bei unserer verarbeit so aber ich kann zeigen
es geht show downtown total.
Genau also das halte ich auch für eine der killer apps,
So, jetzt gucken wir mal in die Wiki-Welt rein.
Jens, muss man jetzt deinen aktuellen Titel mal droppen.
Ich bin Jens. Ich mache das schon länger. Ich habe irgendwie 2002 angefangen,
Wikipedia zu editieren.
Da warst du auch, glaube ich, noch ganz gut dabei.
Ja, ich habe da einen ganz guten Track-Rekord, glaube ich, am Anfang.
Genau. Ich habe fast zehn Jahre lang in der Softwareentwicklung von Wikimedia
Deutschland gearbeitet und wir haben ein kleines Softwareprojekt gewuppt, Wikidata.
Das ist jetzt 13 Jahre alt geworden. Mittlerweile habe ich dann auch gedacht,
will ich es wirklich bis zur Rente machen und habe dann nochmal irgendwie woanders
gearbeitet und arbeite im Moment auch woanders.
Aber das ist ein bisschen wie bei der Mafia. Also raus kommst du nur im Sarg.
Das heißt, ich bin jetzt als ehrenamtlicher mit Wikimedia verbunden und bin
da Beisitzer im Präsidium.
Also ich bin im Präsidium von Wikimedia Deutschland, das wird gewählt,
auf der Mitgliederversammlung und genau, da kümmere ich mich so ein bisschen
um den Bereich Technologie. Und.
Gib mir sofort die Gelegenheit, einen weiteren Podcast, den wir schon zusammen
gemacht haben, zu droppen.
Heute ist Dropping Day.
Chaos Radio Express, das hatte ich fast gesagt, CAE 205, Wikidata,
zu dem prophetischen Termin 9.
Dezember 2013, mit anderen Worten, vor zwölf Jahren.
Da war Wikidata so ungefähr ein Jahr alt, da konnte man auch schon mal was sehen,
aber da waren viele Sachen auch, also damals konnte man keine Sparkle-Abfragen machen zum Beispiel,
aber dieser Podcast hat relativ viel gebracht, also viele Leute haben sich den
angehört und haben gesagt, jetzt habe ich nicht verstanden, was ihr da macht,
weil manchmal brauchen wir schon so eine Stunde oder zwei, um das Ganze zu erklären.
Das stimmt.
Genau, der Untertitel heißt, eine ontologische Datenbank revolutioniert die
Erfassung und Verarbeitung der Wikipedia.
Das war meine prophetische Deutung dieses Themas.
Hat es das tatsächlich getan?
Ja, ich würde sagen, irgendwie schon. Aber das ist für die meisten Leute viel
weniger sichtbar als Wikipedia selbst.
Also Wikipedia ist irgendwie das, was wir alle kennen und lieben oder halt auch
nicht lieben, wenn wir irgendwie Milliardär und reichster Mensch der Welt sind.
Weil der Wahrheit kein Interesse hat.
Genau.
Wikidata ist mehr so wirklich im Maschinenraum des Ganzen.
Irgendwann hat Google, glaube ich, das ist dasjenige, wo es die meisten Leute
sehen, das angefangen in ihre Knowledge Graph zu integrieren.
Also wenn du diese Anzeigen bei einer Google-Suche am Rande siehst,
wo dann so Ergebnisfelder drin sind, diese Infoboxen,
das kommt meistens aus Wikidata und wird dann mit Wikipedia angereichert.
Weil das ist halt schon in dieser computerlesbaren Form da und dann kann man
das da gleich rausziehen.
Das Ganze ist abgespeichert in...
Dem Format, wie man sich das mal überlegt habe, wie das semantische Web mal aussehen sollte.
Und das ist viel mit RDF gemacht worden, gleichzeitig ist es aber auch ein Community-Projekt.
Das heißt, es wird keine Beschreibung der Welt festgelegt. Also es gibt keine
Ontologie, sondern das ist ständig im Fluss und kann jederzeit von der Community geändert werden.
Das macht es dann auch ein bisschen kniffliger damit umzugehen als bei so Standardvokabularien,
wo das alles ein bisschen einfacher zu handeln ist. Und das wird viel eingesetzt.
Man kann es zum Beispiel einnehmen, um so Dinge zu vereinheitlichen.
Also wenn ich sage, Hans Müller, meine ich da den Politiker,
meine ich da den Autor oder sowas, dann hat das alles eine eigene ID in Wikidata.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie das, was Ralf mit seinen Bibliotheken macht.
Ich habe Wissensgegenstände und die bekommene Nummer und dann sind sie eindeutig.
Und das für die ganze Welt macht sozusagen Wikidata.
Ja, man kann, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen weiter ausholen und sagen,
also Wikidata ist ja nicht nur so ein Nebenprojekt,
wo auch noch so ein paar Daten sind, sondern es ist ja schon auch zum großen
Teil die Basis und die Informationsunterfütterung der Wikipedia.
Ja, aber es geht auch darüber hinaus und es war von Anfang an auch so gedacht,
dass es darüber hinaus geht.
Ja, es geht darüber hinaus, aber es ist sozusagen nicht separat,
sondern wenn ich auf Wikipedia mir die Informationen über eine Stadt hole,
dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ein Großteil der Daten,
die in irgendwelchen Infoboxen angezeigt wird, letzten Endes ihre Quelle in Wikidata haben.
Ja, so ist es auf jeden Fall gedacht. Also es wird nicht überall so konsequent
umgesetzt, wo es auf jeden Fall von Anfang an dann,
und da ist es auch zu 100 Prozent der Fälle, wird es da benutzt,
wenn ich so einen Artikel habe und den gibt es in verschiedenen Sprachen,
was weiß ich, 30 Stück, also Wikipedia gibt es ja in fast 400 Sprachversionen mittlerweile.
Ja, es ist nicht so viel, aber es ist schon mehr, als die meisten anderen haben.
Also klar, so 5000 Sprachen wäre mir auch lieber, aber ja, 400 ist schon mal ein guter Angriff.
Das kann man jetzt alles mit AI machen.
Das ist jetzt ein Jammern auf hohem Niveau, oder?
Man muss noch Ziele haben.
So, und diese verschiedenen Sprachversionen werden in Wikidata verwaltet.
Also das ist auch immer ein bisschen schwierig, wenn es dann zum Beispiel keine
1 zu 1 Entsprechung gibt.
Wusstet ihr, dass in einer der beiden norwegischen Sprachen gibt es kein Wort
für Großvater? Da kannst du immer so...
Wie in einer der beiden norwegischen Sprachen.
Es gibt zwei norwegische Sprachen. Es gibt Bugmol. Das ist im Prinzip eine Varietät des Dänischen.
Das ist das, was im Königshof gesprochen wurde. Und dann gibt es Nynorsk.
Nynorsk ist eine konstruierte Sprache, die aus den verschiedenen ländlichen
Dialekten best of zusammengeführt wurde.
Die meisten in Norwegen sprechen Bugmol.
Und in der Schule wird dann noch verlangt, dass man auch dieses Nynorsk lernt
aus patriotischen Gründen.
Manche sprechen das auch als Muttersprache, aber irgendwie gibt es da ein großes Durcheinander.
Also diese beiden Sprachen, die als Norwegisch bezeichnet werden,
die haben jeweils kein Wort für Großvater.
Man kann nur sagen, der Vater der Mutter oder der Vater des Vaters.
Das heißt also, wenn ich einen deutschen Artikel...
Das ist im Schweden auch so, im Schwedischen auch so.
Okay.
Also das ist Far, Far, Far ist der Vater des Vaters und Far,
Moor ist der Vater der Mutter.
Das ist halt ein Unterschied, dass es nicht ein Wort gibt, sondern zwei.
Und diese superklasse Großvater, die wir im Deutschen haben,
die wir im Englischen haben, die gibt es einfach nicht in diesen beiden skandinavischen Sprachen.
Und dann hast du auch keine Eins-zu-eins-Entsprechung.
Aber das sind so die Details.
Im Großen und Ganzen funktioniert das relativ gut.
Ja, das stimmt. Vor allem mag ich halt sehr diese, ja, wir hatten vorhin schon
das Permacomputing, was ich ja ein bisschen bei Permakultur abgeguckt habe.
Wikidata ist für mich auch, sagen wir mal, so das Fleisch gewordene Permalink.
Also wenn dann sozusagen einmal da was drin ist, der bleibt auf jeden Fall.
So ein Wikipedia-Link kann sich schon mal ändern, wenn irgendwas anderes populärer
wird und der Default sein soll, aber so kann man sich halt sicher sein,
was einmal Wikidata unter einer ID liegt, das wird da auch noch liegen, wenn du tot bist.
Genau und auch wenn du dann andere,
permanente,
IDs oder sowas hast, dann also so Pids,
dann was weiß ich, Eintrag in der Deutschen Nationalbibliothek,
das ist eine Nummer oder Library of Congress oder es gibt ein Verzeichnis von
berühmten Grabstätten, Find My Grave, das ist eine Datenbank,
wo berühmte Gräber verzeichnet sind und das kannst du dann alles miteinander verbinden.
Also Q42, der Wissensgegenstand in Wikidata für Douglas.
Find a Grave.
Ja, nicht My Grave. Find My Grave kam mir jetzt auch komisch vor.
Find a Grave. Find a Grave. Entschuldigung.
Genau.
Okay. Also mal, ja.
Q42 ist in Wikidata die Nummer für den Schriftsteller Douglas Adams.
Also alle Nummern werden zufällig vergeben. Manche werden halt noch ein bisschen
zufälliger als andere vergeben und Q42, da steht dann auch drin,
wo das Grab von Douglas Adams in dieser Find a Grave Datenbank verzeichnet ist.
Und allein dieses, dass man dann so ein Flughafendrehkreuz hat zwischen verschiedenen
Identifiern, das gab es halt auch bisher selten.
Also Find a Grave hat mich gleich enttäuscht.
Find my Grave.
Okay, bleib aber bei Wikipedia. Wie findest du denn, hat sich jetzt,
das Wikipedia oder Wikimedia Projekt, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das jetzt nennen soll am besten,
also vielleicht zur Nomenklatur, also Wikipedia kennen wir ja alle,
Wikimedia ist dieser Verein, der sich gegründet hat, der ja auch besonders in
Deutschland sehr stark ist.
Also Deutschland ist ja auffällig, würde ich sagen.
Ich habe mich da oft gefragt, warum das so ist.
Hast du eine Antwort gefunden?
Also erstmal fängt es an mit der deutschsprachigen Wikipedia.
Die ist völlig überrepräsentiert, was die Bedeutung der deutschen Sprache angeht.
Also das ist, je nachdem wie man zählt und welche Metrik man anlegt,
ist es so irgendwie die dritt meist editierte Wikipedia der Welt.
Was ist die Zweitmeister?
Das ist so eine von Bots editierte Wikipedia in einer Sprache,
die auf den Philippinen gesprochen wird, Zibuano.
What?
Da ist wo die Action ist.
Aber das Deutsch je nach Zählweise an zweiter oder dritter Stelle steht,
das geht eigentlich nicht.
Also es sprechen viel mehr Menschen Spanisch. Es sprechen viel mehr Menschen
Französisch in der Welt und von Chinesisch wollen wir gar nicht anfangen.
Chinesisch hat ein anderes Problem, warum es nicht so gut ist mit Online-Beteiligung und so.
Aber zumindest Spanisch und Französisch müssten deutlich vor Deutsch liegen.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, das liegt auch an einem kulturellen Ding.
Also der Deutsche an sich, Der macht gerne irgendwie Ehrenamt in seiner Freizeit,
trifft sich mit anderen und gründet einen Verein.
Verbessert auch gerne andere Leute, wenn online was Falsches steht.
Die Oberlehrer.
Someone's wrong on the Internet.
Und wir haben halt auch ein einigermaßen gutes Bildungssystem.
Also auch wenn wir da alle irgendwie genug drüber meckern können oder so,
da wird schon Wert drauf gelegt, dass die Leute hier vor allen Dingen,
wenn man es jetzt mit Gegenden, was weiß ich, Ostafrika, Westafrika vergleicht oder so.
Also hier ist ein einigermaßen hohes Bildungsniveau und hier ist auch eine Kultur
von wegen, ja, ich mache auch mal was für die Gesellschaft.
Ich bin jetzt auch mal Mitglied in einem Verein. Das gibt es in anderen Ländern,
wird das maximal noch von irgendwelchen Kirchen oder sowas abgedeckt.
Aber dass hier Leute sagen, in meiner Freizeit mache ich was,
was der Gesellschaft hilft, ja, digitales Ehrenamt, das gibt es als Kultur nicht
unbedingt in allen Ländern.
Mir wird noch so einiges mehr einfallen wir haben dann auch so eine enzyklopädische,
Vergangenheit, also so Enzyklopädien sind halt in der deutschen Kultur immer
schon ein Ding gewesen so der Brockhaus das Maya Lexikon also das war ja etwas,
was der deutschen Seele schon immer sehr nah war.
Meine Mutter hat noch den letzten oder so Brockhaus gekauft 30 Bände oder was
das sind und dann war das so ein Abo, wo du halt irgendwie...
Jeden Monat oder jeden zweiten Monat hast du den nächsten Band bekommen.
Ich habe mir auch so von meinem ersten Programmierergeld, ich habe mir auch
erstmal eine Enzyklopädie zusammengekauft, zwar so eine günstige,
kleinere, aber ich hatte einfach einen großen Bedarf danach,
alles mögliche nachschlagen zu können.
Und da es ja das Internet in dem Sinne noch gar nicht gab, war das für mich
irgendwie ein erstrebenswertes Gut. Ja, absolut.
Also das war auch irgendwie bei mich, für mich war das so ein magischer Moment,
einfach in so eine Enzyklopädie aufschlagen zu können.
Da stand alles drin, das ganze Gewissen der Menschheit.
Meine damalige Mitstreiterin Henriette, die du ja auch gut kennst,
ich berichtete ihr erstmalig von Wikipedia.
Ich kam zu ihr und meinte so, ich habe was für dich, das wird dir gefallen.
Und sie, da habe ich ihr das kurz dargelegt und es dauerte nicht lang,
bis sie irgendwie spitze Schreie ausstieß und in ihrem Bibliothekswesen,
in dem sie groß geworden ist, auf einmal so völlig meinte, so,
endlich ein Ort, wo ich meine unnützes Wissen reinschreiben kann.
Und das tat sie dann auch. Und das tat sie dann auch und gehörte so mit zu den
Mitgründern dann von Wikimedia und war da auch lange aktiv.
Und ja, ich denke, es ist auch irgendwie die deutsche Natur,
alles muss richtig sein.
Die Dinge müssen irgendwie in 90-Grad-Winkeln angeordnet werden.
Und das passt irgendwie alles zusammen und ich würde sogar noch weiter gehen,
ich würde auch sagen, aus ähnlichen Gründen,
warum auch Linux so stark ist in Deutschland, das ist ja nun auch nicht in Deutschland
erfunden worden, trotzdem denke ich ist Deutschland eine der stärksten Communities
so für Open Source generell.
Und da passt dann Wikipedia natürlich auch super dazu.
Letztlich ist es ja auch ein Open-Source-Projekt. Ich bin zu Wikipedia damals
gekommen auf der Suche nach einem guten Wiki.
Das war quasi mein Pfad zu dem Projekt, was damals noch keiner kannte.
ja und von daher glaube ich kommt da eine ganze Menge zusammen auch wenn ich
dann immer ein bisschen kritisch bin,
in dieser Debatte zum Beispiel des Exklusionismus und Inklusionismus in Deutschland,
ja hier hat man sich dann immer sehr, bis hier mal ein Lämmer.
Aufgemacht wird, dann muss das irgendwie auch alles relevant sein und da wird
dann viel drüber gestritten da fehlt mir dann doch so ein bisschen die offenporige
Herangehensweise der Amerikaner, die sagen so, pff, scheiß drauf hier,
jede Figur in einem beliebigen Comic-Universum kriegt selbstverständlich eine eigene Seite.
Da freut sich dann auch Wikidata.
Das stört mich so ein bisschen, aber summa summarum kann man sagen,
Wikipedia in Deutschland und, sagen wir mal, nicht nur in Deutschland,
sondern im deutschsprachigen Raum ist ein Erfolgsprojekt ohne Abstriche.
Ja, ich würde sagen, also Wikipedia und Linux sind die beiden größten Geschenke,
die die Nerds uns gemacht haben.
Und da ist dann allerdings auch zum Teil dann dieses Online-Verhalten von Nerds und,
Ja, problematisch. Ich war bei 20 Jahre koreanischsprachige Wikipedia in Seoul,
habe da die Torte mit angeschnitten und einen Vortrag gehalten und war dann super überrascht,
dass Wikimedia Korea da ein Projekt gehabt hat, wo sie an die Selbsthilfeorganisation
der Autistinnen und Autisten in Korea herangetreten sind und haben gesagt, hier,
wollt ihr nicht bei uns Deckel schreiben über Züge und so? und,
das fand ich sehr, sehr interessant, weil,
es gibt bei diesen Wikimedia-Konferenzen auch immer mal wieder hier und da einen
Vortrag über Neurodivers und so weiter, aber das einfach mal so auf den Punkt
zu bringen und zu sagen, hier wir haben,
den Wirkungsbereich für euch,
das fand ich schon außergewöhnlich und das Das wird man wahrscheinlich in Deutschland
oder auch in den USA aus Political Correctness oder so nicht machen.
Aber warum nicht?
Warum nicht? Also ehrlich gesagt, klar, es ist super naheliegend.
Das ist für die doch perfekt.
Und entsprechend sind halt auch manchmal die Online-Diskussionen.
Alles sehr männlich, alles sehr regelbasiert und muss man mögen.
Ja, und klage ich jeden Tag drüber, aber jeden Tag freue ich mich auch,
dass es Wikipedia gibt Und das ist einer der wenigen Orte.
Das Erste, was erfunden werden müsste, wenn es das nicht gäbe.
Einer der wenigen Orte im Internet, die noch nach dem alten Prinzip funktionieren.
Also es gibt keine Werbung drauf.
Du wirst halt einmal im Jahr um Spenden gebeten, aber das war es dann halt auch.
Deine Daten werden nicht verkauft. Kein Tricking.
Und das ist...
Die Meta-Ebene.
Ja, das ist... Und dann auch ein Problem. Also um richtig mitarbeiten zu können
bei Wikipedia oder auch bei Wikidata, solltest du irgendwie einen Account machen.
Das ist ziemlich einfach, wenn du auf die Wikidata-Seite gehst,
dann steht da in der obersten Zeile auch schon irgendwie Create-Account.
Und wollen wir mal kurz den Kontext dazu noch reinwerfen, warum ich mir das
nämlich von Jens wünsche, dass er das uns ja in der Sendung einmal durchklickt.
Vor ein paar Wochen hatte ich mal ein Update gegeben, dass ich hier für den
Fediverse Day dieses Fedipol mal aktualisiert habe.
Wir erinnern uns, das war diese Visualisierung, welche politischen Akteure und
Organisationen im Fediverse schon aktiv sind. Und die Daten dafür hole ich mir
in der Tat aus der Wikidata raus.
So, das war der Gedanke. Ich habe das dann ein bisschen aufgebohrt.
Es gibt ja beispielsweise auch so Parteieninstanzen, Netzbegrünung von den Grünen und ähnliches.
Die ziehe ich mittlerweile von der Seite dann auch noch alle rein,
die Accounts, aber so das Basisset war dann halt eine Wikidata-Query und die
ist relativ kompliziert, ist auch dokumentiert, kann man sich angucken,
was da wo, welche Kategorien ausgelesen werden.
Das war auch einer der Momente, das habe ich auch in einer Sendung schon mal
erzählt, wo Vibe Coding dann echt schwer an seine Grenzen gekommen ist.
Das hat ja erstmal ganz plausibel aussehende Geschichten zusammen verdrahtet
und dann gab es aber so komische kleine Unstimmigkeiten und plötzlich war dann
da irgendwie so eine Heuschrecke irgendwie in einem Datenset drin.
Und dann frage ich die LLM, was denn da los ist. Und dann gab es wirklich diesen
Moment, wo die LLM sich dann so richtig reingesteigert hat.
Ja, das ist schon ungewöhnlich, das sollten wohl mal Wikidata sagen,
dass da ihre Kategorien nicht ganz gerade sind.
Und das ist echt so, zwei Prompt später, meine Güte, da stimmt ja fast gar nichts.
Was ist denn mit Wikidata los?
Da muss man doch mal was tun. und so, dann war natürlich die LLM völlig desorientiert,
was da jetzt irgendwo Phase ist.
Hat sich dann alles ein bisschen gefangen und hat mal eingehigt bekommen,
aber kein guter Use Case für Vibe Coding, Wikidata.
Trainingstiefe offensichtlich nicht stark genug, was ja die Kategorien angeht.
Und manchmal steht da auch wirklich Quatsch drin, der dann hoffentlich nach
dem Viel-Augen-Prinzip dann möglichst schnell wieder geändert wird.
Aber es gibt diese nette Anekdote, dass eine Zeit lang, wenn du Alexa gefragt
hast, was ist denn die Nationalhymne von Bulgarien, kam Despacito zurück.
Weil, dass irgendjemand, der auf Wikidata Vandalismus betrieben hat, mal so eingetragen hat.
In dem Moment kam dann Amazon vorbei, hat das gecashed und hat das in seine
Alexa Knowledge Base reingenommen.
Das war relativ schnell bei Wikidata geändert, aber Alexa hat davon nichts mitgekriegt.
Geil. Tim, du kannst vielleicht mal auf den Beamer hier mal die letzte URL werfen,
die ich jetzt hier gerade in den Chat reingeworfen habe.
Das ist die Doku zu diesem Fedipol, wo man ein bisschen sieht,
wie die Sparkle-Query zusammengezimmert ist und welche Kategorien da angeworfen werden.
Also Parlamentsmitglieder und Politikerinnen muss einer politischen Partei angehören.
Das ist P102 als Merkmal. Oder eine Verbindung.
Also Sparkle müssen wir noch mal kurz einwerfen. Das hast du ja vorhin nebenbei
erwähnt. Das ist sozusagen das SQL von Wikidata.
Es ist ein W3C-Standard. also steht für Sparkle Protocol and RDF Query Language,
Also es ist dafür gedacht, so Sachen, die so ähnlich wie RDF modelliert sind, abzufragen.
Aber das ist im Rahmen von Wikidata entwickelt worden?
Nee.
Das gab es schon vorher?
Das war ein Standard schon vorher. Der war so komplex, dass den fast niemand irgendwie benutzt hat.
Also ein paar Hardcore-Semantic-Web-Fans haben das benutzt.
Aber Wikidata ist, glaube ich, der größte und meistbenutzte Sparkle-Endpoint überhaupt.
Also im Bibliotheksbereich haben wir da auch schon sehr früh mit experimentiert,
aber es ist halt langsam, wenn du dir nicht gut Gedanken machst um Skalierung
und wie du das irgendwie noch mit einer Suchmaschine oben drüber schnell bekommst.
Genau, und Semantic Web, das hat dann auch nie so richtig abgehoben, bis Wikidata kam.
So, und jetzt kann man sich auf der Seite anschauen, so was ist alles drin.
Also Stadtrat ist dann irgendwie Q3154693 und so weiter.
Die ganzen Parteien sind alle drin. SPD hat Q49768 und CDU.
Die kann man sich alle anschauen in Wikidata. Und das stimmt jetzt mittlerweile auch alles.
So, und jetzt bekomme ich aber einigermaßen regelmäßig, nicht oft,
aber regelmäßig die Frage, tollen Dienst, den du gebaut hast,
aber warum bin ich denn da nicht drin?
Ich bin doch auch Politiker hier, SPD, und bin doch ganz aktiv im Fee-Diverse.
Und warum wird das hier nicht gewürdigt?
Dann ist halt immer meine Standardantwort. Ja, schau mal da in die Doku rein,
die direkt in der App drin integriert ist, weil du halt einen Account auf Wikidata brauchst.
Ja, wie geht denn das? Kannst du mich da reinschreiben?
Dann sage ich ja, nee, eigentlich ist das jetzt auch nicht mein Job.
Das ist eher so ein Proof of Concept Ding hier und vielleicht solltest du selber
schauen, wie du dich als Person dort rein modellierst. So und genau die Frage
wollte ich jetzt einfach mal mitbringen.
Also erstens, was ist denn eigentlich der Threshold, ab wo man sich selber als
Person in Wikidata eintragen sollte, wenn man noch nicht schon drin steht über irgendeine...
Datenimport-Geschichte. Das wäre das Erste, was ich gerne wüsste.
Reicht es da, Lokalpolitikerin zu sein?
Oder seid ihr völlig fein damit, dass da einfach jeder Mann sich rein modelliert,
der meint, er, sie sei wichtig?
Also in der deutschsprachigen Wikipedia gibt es diese berühmt-berüchtigten Relevanzkriterien.
Da kann man lange drüber reden.
Oft ist das so, das Erste, was Leute erleben, wenn sie Wikipedia editieren,
ist nicht relevant. Und dann sind sie frustriert und dampfen wieder ab.
Bei Wikidata ist das ein bisschen anders. Also erstmal ist es viel, viel größer.
Das, was potenziell relevant sein könnte, wenn es für irgendeine Art von Wikipedia-Projekt
sinnvoll sein kann, dann kann man da ein Datenobjekt für anlegen.
oder wenn es sinnvoll ist, um eine Reihe zu vervollständigen.
Also die Eltern von Douglas Adams sind nicht relevant für irgendeine Wikipedia,
aber um den Standbaum von Douglas Adams zu machen, sind sie halt auch drin in Wikidata.
Und so würde ich das dann auch sehen. Also es gibt nirgendwo eine Regel, wo drin steht,
ab der und der Bedeutungstiefe ist dann kommunal kommunal und sonst was,
das gibt es so nicht festgeschrieben.
Ich würde aber sagen, das ist durchaus vertretbar, dann so ein Objekt anzulegen.
Da sollte man aber vorgucken, ist das nicht vielleicht schon angelegt?
Denn es gibt gerade bei diesen politisch aktiven Menschen gibt es eine Menge
Leute, die da ständig Daten nachpflegen.
Und sobald ...
irgendwo eine Wahl ist, laufen die Daten-Uploads auf Wikidata heiß,
weil jeder möchte halt die Reihe wieder verständigt haben, auf jeden Fall.
Was häufiger fehlt, ist, dass dann dieses Datenobjekt dann vielleicht keine
Mastodan-Adresse eingetragen hat. Das muss man einfach nachtragen.
Genau, aber das ist ja der einfachere Fall, sagen wir mal. Das fand ich dann eher so trivial.
Okay, das heißt, du wolltest also sagen, wenn ich mir hier so die Liste angucke,
also klar, Mitglied des Europäischen Parlaments und Mitglied eines Landtags,
da würde ich mal sagen, klar ist das irgendwie relevant für Wikidata.
Das sollte auch schon alles erfasst sein, ja.
So, und,
Stadtrat, Bezirksverordneter, Kreisrat, so, da würdest du auch schon sagen,
ja, das kann man schon machen.
Ja.
Kann man schon machen. Okay.
Im Zweifelsfalle wird man dann einfach angesprochen und dann versucht man gemeinsam
irgendwie eine Lösung zu machen.
Das ist halt ein Community-Projekt.
Ja.
Okay, so, also, sagen wir mal so, check, ja, bist irgendwie relevant genug als
Politiker, nicht nur Schatzmeister im Ortsverein hinter Tupfigen.
Was ist dann jetzt die Klickstrecke, die man dann da jetzt gehen würde?
Ich weiß, es gibt YouTube-Videos und die verlinke ich dann auch immer,
aber damit gewinnst du dann irgendwie auch wieder keinen Blumentopf.
Na, als erstes gehst du auf Wikidata.org.
Mach mal, Tim.
Ja.
Wir machen jetzt mal so richtig Live-Clicking hier.
Genau, betreutes Klicken.
Und beschreiben aber auch, was wir sehen, damit es nicht wieder Ärger gibt.
Wir sehen dann so eine typisch fetzig, modern gestaltete Wikimedia-Seite.
Im diskreten Charme der späten Nullerjahre.
Ich finde das gut.
Ich finde es auch gut. Also mich spricht das an, also mehr als irgendwelche
runden Ecken bei Looking Glass.
Vor allem lustig ist ja, ist das eigentlich Absicht, dass das Wikidata-Logo
links diesen Barcode umgekehrt hat zu diesem Logo,
was es jetzt für kleine Klimakatastrophe gibt mit diesen Bars,
die eigentlich links die kalten Jahre und rechts die roten Jahre sind?
Es sind die Farben, die bei allen Wikimedia-Logos benutzt wurden.
Es gab einen Wettbewerb zu dem Logo und das sieht aus wie ein Barcode,
aber eigentlich ist es ein Morse-Code für das Wort Wiki.
Ja, okay, und die Farben ist, also ihr wart früher da, als die,
also du weißt, welches Logo ich meine?
Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst. Diese Global Warming Stripes heißt das, glaube ich, ne?
Genau. Das ist ja quasi das, nur umgedreht.
Nee, und da geht's auch, glaube ich, irgendwie von blau zu rot und da gibt's auch kein grün dabei.
Und das ist auch alles ein bisschen mehr...
Hat damit nichts zu tun.
Okay, gut, dann hat mich das gerade nur getriggert.
So, und jetzt sind wir auf der Seite.
Wenn wir ganz oben gucken, in der tatsächlich allerersten Zeile,
dann sehen wir da Englisch.
Und das ist das Einzige, was du machen kannst. Weil wir verkaufen keine Anzeigen
und wir tracken den User nicht über 10.000 Strecken,
Sondern wenn der anonym vorbeikommt, dann ist er anonym.
Und das heißt, wir können auch nicht sowas speichern wie, dieser anonyme User
möchte gerne Deutsch und der andere anonyme User, von dem wir nichts wissen,
der möchte gerne Englisch.
Das heißt, du musst dich auch wirklich, wenn du das Interface auf Deutsch umstellen
müsstest, musst du dich einloggen.
Würden wir jetzt nicht als erstes aber den Schritt noch gehen, bin ich schon drin?
Genau. Also entweder hast du schon einen Account und Ich meine jetzt nicht.
Also ob man selber schon ein Datenpunkt ist in der Wikidata, das meinte ich.
Weil dann muss man eventuell ja gar nichts anlegen, wenn man doch schon drin
ist. Also sprich, würde man nicht erstmal oben die Suche nehmen?
Das ist ja auch dieser scheiß E-Mail-Anmeld-Kack. Das nervt so dermaßen. Was soll denn das?
Warum? Es wird langsam alles unsicherer.
Dadurch wird es sicherer?
Es ist ein weiterer Faktor.
Ja, man kann nichts mehr ohne Mail-Client benutzen. Das ist irgendwie nervig.
Tja, wenn die Leute nicht ihre Passworte wiederverwenden würden.
Ja, dann würde sie zumindest Passkeys unterstützen hier. Das ist komisch ein Mail-Kram.
Genau, also eine Möglichkeit wäre zuerst mal gucken, bin ich überhaupt da.
Also neben dem Wikidata-Logo in der allerobersten Zeile,
neben der Sprachauswahl, die du auf eine andere Sprache umstellen kannst,
wenn du eingeloggt bist und jetzt
sonst auf Englisch steht, da ist so eine Lupe ganz oben und in der Lupe,
kannst du eingeben deinen Namen, den du suchst.
Hast du mal einen Politiker, der sich beschwert hat?
Wir können auch Tim einfach mal suchen.
Tim Pritlaff hat natürlich schon lange, lange, lange Tim Pritlaff und darunter
ist eine einzeilige Beschreibung Deutscher Podcaster und Medienkünstler.
Also geht besser, aber geht auch schlimmer, oder?
Bei mir steht German Opinion Journalist. Da frag ich mich schon, wo das herkommt.
Das frag ich mich tatsächlich auch.
Also ich bin sicherlich sehr opinionated, das möchte ich nicht abstreiten.
Finde ich aber gar nicht so schlecht, die Beschreibung. Ich bin nicht drin.
Sehr gut.
Ja, ich bin drin und auf Niederländisch werde ich als deutscher Esperantist
bezeichnet, was jetzt auch irgendwie nur eine ganz winzige Facette meines Daseins abbildet.
Ja, es ist schon lustig, was hier alles über mich festgehalten wird.
Genau.
Ich bin gut durchforscht. Sogar mein mittlerweile eigentlich nicht mehr existenter Name ist drin.
Bei mir auch. Ich bin unter meinem Ehrennamen noch drin.
Ah, guck an. Kannst du gleich mal ändern.
Ansonsten sind meine Daten auch ganz gut.
Mit Bibliotheksdirektor und so Dann guckt man halt ich würde jetzt einfach stumpf
auf STRG F drücken und nach Mastodon suchen bei dem.
Was bei mir jetzt hier.
Ja, ob dann dein Mastodon-Account eingetragen ist Sicherheit.
Webseiten.
Genau, such doch einfach mal in der Webseite nach Mastodon.
Genau, meine beiden stehen hier schön drin.
Genau, und dann siehst du halt auch schon, genau, ist eingetragen,
wie viele hast du denn und wann ist das abgefragt worden.
Du kannst das alles wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr genau dann eintragen.
Aber wieso steht die denn dreimal drin?
Jeweils zu anderen Zeitpunkten abgefragt und mit, du siehst auch,
wie viele Follower du auf Mastodon hast.
Also das Neueste ist dann April 20...
Ach echt? Das ist die Followerzahl.
Die Anzahl der Follower steht dann auch daneben.
Die habe ich bei mir nicht drin stehen übrigens.
Hast du Follower?
Scheinbar nicht.
Okay.
Genau und du siehst dann... Ach, wir können da sehr in die Details Ah.
Nee, das ist eine andere Sektion. Okay, da stehen sie schon drin.
Achso, hier geht es auch um Anzahl der Follower.
Genau, unten gibt es nochmal die reinen Accounts.
Ich verstehe, ich bin nämlich auch gerade bei dieser...
Machst du doch eine Adresse, genau.
Genau, also ich glaube, das ist, das kann man ja vielleicht nochmal erklären,
also generell was ist schon angedeutet, also dieser RDF-Resource-Description-Format,
das ist ja sozusagen so ein,
ja, eine Datenbank mit Aussagelogik.
ist ein La La La.
Genau, genau.
Sehr gut. Also das ist auch sehr, also Wissenschaftler absolut auf den Punkt.
Und lalala sind da so die Fachbegriffe.
Das habe ich total drauf, das Besteck. Ich bin eigentlich Ehrenwissenschaftler.
So, und jetzt sieht man hier aber schon überall sowohl einen Bearbeiten-Stift
als auch einen Wert hinzufügen-Plus-Button, obwohl Tim gerade noch gar nicht eingeloggt ist.
Doch, ich bin eingeloggt.
Okay. Also ich bin nicht eingeloggt und sehe es trotzdem. Das heißt also...
Du kannst auch anonym unter deiner IP-Adresse editieren, ist die Frage, ob du das machen willst.
Ich würde sagen, eher nicht. Also warum will man seine IP-Adresse dann in den
Logfiles hinterlassen?
Schöner ist es doch, wenn man sich einen Account macht, dann kann man das auch
sofort mit seinem Namen sozusagen oder mit dem gewählten Namen verbinden.
und dann haben Leute auch eine Möglichkeit, dich anzusprechen,
können sagen, hey, vielen Dank für deinen Edit, aber wir haben hier so ein Projekt.
Es gibt ein Projekt, das heißt Every Politician und das versucht weltweit alle
Politiker abzuklären und die unter anderem überlegen sich auch,
wie so eine Modellierung von so Politikern aussahen könnte.
Ich habe hier IDs, von denen wusste ich gar nicht, dass die existieren.
Ich habe offensichtlich eine Music-Brains-Künstlerkennung,
eine Podchaser-Uhrheberkennung noch nie gehört.
Was in einer Welt ist eine Prabuk-Kennung.
keine Ahnung. Soundcloud Profilkennung? Oh Mann.
Alle meine Social Media Accounts überall. Also ich bin hier irgendwie komplett gestrippt.
Du hast ein offenes Buch.
Aber gut, das war schon immer mein Prinzip im Umgang mit dem Internet.
Ich dachte mir, bevor das irgendwie andere schreiben, schreibe ich das lieber alles selber rein.
Bin ich bisher noch ganz gut mitgefahren.
Was ist ein...
Warum ich im ARZ-Wiki einen Eintrag habe, das ARZ ist einfach, weißt du was das ist?
Es muss eine Variante vom Arabischen sein oder es ist eine ganz andere Sprache?
Es ist eindeutig arabische Schrift, da steht ja auch Tim Pridler auf Arabisch.
Die Schrift ist arabisch, aber es ist nicht.
Was ist denn die ARZ-Wikipedia-Wikipedia?
Gucken wir mal.
Natürlich, das ist ägyptisches Arabisch.
Ägyptisches Arabisch.
Ja.
Okay, steht hier selber auf der Seite nicht drauf, was es ist.
Aber doch hier ägyptische Wikipedia-Portale.
Warum auch immer meine Seite ist.
Vor allem mit Pretloff.
Nein, nein, das ist jetzt hier die Übersetzung vom Safari. Das Original ist
halt auf Arabisch, das ist ja der Punkt.
Achso, ja, da steht es ja dann.
Aber das weiß ich zumindest, wie ich mich auf Arabisch schreibe,
das war mir bisher auch noch nicht klar.
Okay, gut, sehr schön, nicht so wichtig. Auf jeden Fall, so kann man Sachen nachschlagen.
Ja, es war schon immer auch mein Traum, den ich bis heute irgendwie leider noch
nicht umgesetzt habe, auch mal diese ganzen Shownotes im Prinzip alle über Wikidata,
abzuwickeln, weil das Das Schöne ist, man kann dann halt einfach beliebige Metadaten
und daraus wiederum beliebige Meta-Meta-Meta-Daten herausfinden und so würde
ich eigentlich ganz gerne mal meine Shownotes organisieren,
aber ich rede da schon lange davon, aber bisher habe ich nicht liefern können.
Aber das ist halt so, glaube ich, muss man Wikidata auch verstehen,
dass das einfach, man kommt so vom Hölzchen aufs Stöckchen.
Also du kannst einfach irgendeinen Q-Nummer-Lalala haben und dann kannst du
die Wikidata auf jeden Fall fragen, was ist das?
Und dann gibt es halt eine, sowieso ist ein und dann weißt du schon mal,
ist das hier ein Gebäude, eine Stadt, eine Person, ein Konzept,
ist es eine Wissenschaft, ist es irgendwas?
und kannst das sofort in übergeordnete Glossare einsortieren und darüber natürlich
deine ganzen Daten viel besser auffindbar machen.
Und metersprachig. Also es funktioniert mit den ganzen fast 400 Sprachen,
in denen es auch die Wikimedia-Projekte gibt.
Das heißt, du trägst es einmal ein und jemand in Indien kann es dann in seiner
Sprache dann auch abrufen.
Und das ist sozusagen, also bevor wir alle irgendwie dieses Paper gelesen haben,
Attention is all you need und dann Generative Pre-Trained Transformers auf den
Markt kamen und wir alle LLMs benutzen,
hätte man sowas als eigentlich auch unter KI eingeordnet.
Das ist auch etwas, was so in der Frühzeit so als KI-Anwendung drin war,
dass man eine Knowledge Base schafft,
dass man dem Computer stückchenweise in Maschinen lesbar erklärt,
wie die Welt so funktioniert.
So ein Weltmodellierungsansatz.
Genau, das nennt man symbolische KI und das ist im Moment gerade total out.
Alle jungen, hippen TikTok-KI-Forscher,
die würden symbolische KI nicht mal mit der Kneifzange anfassen,
weil das ist irgendwie Opas KI und das geht gar nicht.
Ich glaube, dass das irgendwann nochmal zurückkommt. Also ich glaube,
dass so die Verknüpfung aus neuronalen Netzen und Knowledge Bases,
dass das tatsächlich der Punkt sein könnte, wo man nochmal ganz interessante Sachen hinkriegt.
Und es gibt auch Sachen, da brauchst du kein LLM für und da brauchst du nicht
irgendwie ein Rechenzentrum, was Wasser und Strom verbraucht,
sondern das sind alles Dinge, die sind schon gut studiert.
Natürliche Sprachgenerierung. Also irgendwie Texte hinkriegen mit Lücken und
dann irgendwie ein Grammatikmodell draufkriegen.
Klar kannst du das auch mit dem LLM generieren, aber da kannst du auch entsprechende
Grammatikformate einfach in den Computer reinschmeißen und dann vielleicht Wikidata
noch als Backend dahinter und dann kannst du dir auch natürlich sprachliche Texte erzeugen.
Da gibt es ein Projekt, das nennt sich Wikifunctions.
Wikifunctions ist so das neueste Kind in der Wiki-Familie und Wikifunctions
ist ein Wiki, wo man Funktionen ablegen kann.
Hauptsächlich Funktionen, um natürliche Sprache zu generieren.
Also zum Beispiel, ja, wir haben da eine Funktion.
Um, ja, da sind viele mathematische Funktionen drin, aber es sind auch viele,
wo man natürliche Sprache machen kann. Wenn du mal ein bisschen nach oben scrollst,
genau, und dann müsste eigentlich...
Da in diesem einem Fenster Get Started und der letzte Punkt ist Catalog of Available Functions.
Da siehst du, was es alles schon so an Funktionen gibt.
Das Ganze ist jetzt wirklich hier bleeding edge, weil selbst die Hardcore-Wiki-Fans,
die wissen oft gar nicht, dass Wikifunctions existiert.
Oder sie haben davon gehört und haben gesagt, das ist mir irgendwie zu schwer
und das verstehe ich noch nicht. Aber das wird ein weiterer Baustein sein in
einem Projekt, das nennen wir Abstract Wikipedia.
Und Abstract Wikipedia wird, wenn es in der Sprache keinen Artikel zu dem Thema
gibt, dann nimm die Funktionen von Wikifunctions,
nimm die Daten von Wikidata und
dann erzeuge einfach den entsprechenden Wikipedia-Artikel aus den beiden.
Und dann hat plötzlich eine westafrikanische Sprache, die einfach low resource
ist, hat dann auf jeden Fall schon mal so einen Grundstock einer Enzyklopädie.
Zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte dieser Sprache.
Würdest du jetzt sagen, das ist jetzt die primäre Motivation gewesen für Wikifunctions
oder ist das jetzt nur so ein….
Es ist eine, also diese Idee von Abstract Wikipedia brauchte neben Wikidata
auch dieses Wikifunctions, aber du kannst das natürlich auch benutzen,
um im herkömmlichen Wikipedia-Artikel einfach zu sagen,
die und die Person ist jetzt so und so viele Jahre alt.
Das musst du dann halt nicht reinschreiben und jedes Jahr einen Zähler hochsetzen,
sondern setzt du einfach einen Verweis zu Wikifunctions rein.
Und es ist nicht im Source-Code von Media-Wiki in der Software,
sondern es ist sozusagen eine abstrakt formulierte Funktion quasi aus einer
Datenbank, die dann genommen und als solche angewendet wird.
Genau. Also du kannst in Wikifunctions kannst du auf drei verschiedene Arten
diese Funktionen implementieren.
Du kannst es in Python schreiben, du kannst es in JavaScript schreiben und du
kannst es als Komposition machen.
Die Komposition ist, dass du Funktionen
miteinander verschachtelst auf der Grundlage des Lambda-Kalküls.
Dass du aus der einen etwas reinkommst und dann das in eine andere Funktion rein tust. Ja, genau.
Also hier haben wir jetzt irgendwie für National Language Operations.
Ich habe mich da letzte Weihnachten mal hingesetzt und habe gesagt,
ich spreche Esperanto und das ist ja eine konstruierte Sprache,
das heißt es gibt keine Ausnahmefälle.
Dann mache ich mal Funktionen, um alle möglichen grammatischen Formen eines
Esperanto-Wortes zu erzeugen.
Das hast du hier angelegt, was wir jetzt gerade sehen. Okay,
was könnten wir uns mal hier anschauen?
Esperanto Verb Stem, writes the stem of an Esperanto Verb, okay,
also wie man das deklariert.
Ja, das ist irgendwie, genau, also da haben wir jetzt das Verb Labori und der Stamm davon ist Labor.
Und wenn du da drauf, da gibt es dann Esperanto-Verbstem-Python-Implementation. Das ist super billig.
Also da wird der letzte Affix, also der Suffix, wird herausgefunden und dann
wird das Wort ohne den Suffix zurückgegeben. Und dann hat man den Stamm.
Heißt das jetzt, dass Python jetzt so ein bisschen die Default-Language ist?
Nee, du kannst das auch in JavaScript machen Oder du kannst es halt,
wie gesagt, in so einer Art Lisp,
wo du dann die verschiedenen Wikifunctions-Dinger hintereinander chanest und
dann mit verschiedenen Operationen nach diesem Landmark-Kalkül miteinander verbindest,
kannst du das dann auch machen und dann ist es eigentlich egal,
ob die Implementation jetzt in Python gemacht ist, in Java, vielleicht werden
sie dann auch was anderes machen.
Also vielleicht gibt es dann auch irgendwie als Implementationssprache jetzt
noch Lua oder Rast oder hast du nicht gesehen dazu.
Es ist aber alles egal, weil das musst du nicht wissen, wenn du es anwendest.
Es gibt auch mehrere Sachen, wo es mehrere Implementationen gibt und dann entscheidet
Wikifunctions immer, welche Funktion gerade am besten läuft,
welche sich am besten cachen lässt und welche am schnellsten ist.
Was war das für eine Lisp-Variante jetzt?
Ich glaube, die Sprache hat keinen wirklichen Namen, sondern es wäre Wikifunctions Composition.
Also sozusagen eine Wikifunctions lokaler Lisp-Dialekt, der sozusagen wäre das
dann nicht eigentlich die erste Adresse, in der man irgendwie Dinge...
Das benutzen mittlerweile sehr, sehr viele, ja.
Ah ja, okay.
Kann man eine Unit-Test schreiben? Ja.
Wird man auch sehr stark zu angehalten, dass jede Funktion halt immer einen Test haben muss.
mindestens genau hier ist und test und dann sage ich ja ich übergebe die funktion
das und ich möchte dann dass das dabei rauskommt sehr gut.
Cool.
Cool, ne?
Ich finde das cool.
Und für deutsche Wikipedia, englische Wikipedia ist das alles nicht so richtig relevant.
Aber die Welt ist rund und bunt.
Und wir sehen das schon, dass dieser Anglozentrismus ganz schöne Schäden anrichtet.
Also gerade in Afrika und in Indien, da ist es dann im Kopf von jungen Leuten
oft so, Englisch ist die Sprache, die ich auf der Uni spreche.
Wenn ich was wissen will, suche ich auf Englisch.
Die Leute kommen zum Teil gar nicht auf die Idee, in der Sprache,
die sie zu Hause sprechen, nach Wissen zu suchen.
Und das ist dann die Schlange, die sich selber in den Schwanz beißt.
Das heißt, es gibt dann auch weniger Texte online in dieser Sprache.
Und das heißt, das wird dann auch immer weniger relevant für die Online-Sichtbarkeit.
Diesen Sommer war diese Weltkonferenz von Wikimedia in Nairobi, in Kenia.
Und da habe ich mich vorher halt mit der Sprache Swahili beschäftigt,
weil ich immer schon mal eine Bantu-Sprache lernen wollte.
Und ja, ich konnte dann halt auch irgendwie ein paar Phrasen sagen und wo ich
herkomme und was ich mache und so.
Aber natürlich war ich irgendwie weit davon entfernt, fließend in Swahili zu
sein. Aber das ist eine Sprache, die sprechen mehr Leute als Deutsch.
Und es ist eine absolute Low-Resource-Sprache, was maschinelle Verarbeitung angeht.
Es gibt fast gar nichts.
Und alle Leute, die da irgendwie sich mit Machine Learning und Natural Language
Processing und so beschäftigen, die machen das alle in Englisch.
Und die machen das nicht in einer Sprache, die immerhin die größte Bantu-Sprache ist.
Das heißt, das ist auf jeden Fall ein Punkt, wo wir so den Angriff von KI auf
die Wikimedia-Projekte jetzt schon deutlich merken.
Wir sehen eine Menge Anglozentrismus und auch immer weniger Wünsche,
dann tatsächlich in lokalen Sprachen Inhalte zu haben.
Wir sehen auch manchmal sowas wie, ja es gab eine grönländische Wikipedia,
grönländisch, halt eine nordamerikanische indigene Sprache, die von ein paar
zehntausend Leuten gesprochen wird.
Es ist jetzt nicht eine winzige Sprache, aber es ist auch keine große Sprache.
Und da war einfach über die letzten fünf Jahre oder so, waren da wirklich nur
eine Handvoll von Leuten, die an dieser Wikipedia da mitgearbeitet haben.
Der meiste Teil davon war mit einem ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz schlechten,
ganz frühen maschinellen Übersetzungsprogramm gefüttert und es war einfach sinnlos.
Also kein Sprecher des Grönländischen konnte aus diesen Artikeln überhaupt einen
Sinn erkennen. Und da war dann diese...
von Maschinen vollgefüllte Wikipedia da und die war einfach nicht mehr sinnvoll.
Deswegen wurde sie jetzt vor ein paar Monaten abgeschaltet, weil man gesagt
hat, das bringt so nichts.
Das ist keine gute Repräsentation der grönländischen Sprache und das hilft auch der Community nicht.
Und da haben Leute einfach gesagt, wieso, ich mache euch mal was Schönes.
Ich paste mal den englischen Wikipedia-Artikel in diese maschinelle Übersetzung
nach Grönländisch, habe selber keine Ahnung, wie die Sprache funktioniert und
paste es da in die Wikipedia rein.
Also lieb gemeint ist nicht immer gut gemacht und das sieht man hier auch.
Und sehr, sehr viele Leute sagen dann auch irgendwie, ich will auch unbedingt
dieser Wikipedia helfen und am besten mache ich das ja, indem ich ChatGPT sage,
schreib mir mal einen Artikel zu dem Thema und lass es wie Wikipedia klingen.
Als ob das sozusagen auch so ein eigener Style wäre.
Bekannter von mir und ich glaube auch von dir Tim, der Matthias Schindler,
der auch so eine Urgestein von Wikimedia und so, hat auch den Verein mitgegründet.
Und der hatte im letzten Winter so eine Idee und zwar hat er auch die Wunderwelt
des Vibe-Codings entdeckt und plötzlich konnte er all diese kleinen Spezialprogramme,
die er immer schon mal haben wollte,
konnte er dann auch selber schreiben, ohne dass er irgendwie Leuten wie mir
auf den Sack gehen musste und denen gesagt hat, ja, programmierst du mir mal
hier dieses spezielle Problem, was nur ich habe?
konnte er das dann einfach mal selber machen.
Und war da auch sehr begeistert. Und er hat sich überlegt, ich hole mir mal
den Dump von der gesamten Wikipedia,
Und überprüfe mal die ganzen ISBN, die da drin sind. International Standard
Book Number, jedes Buch hat eine ISBN.
Und was die wenigsten wissen ist, dass die letzte Stelle so eine Prüfziffer ist.
Das heißt, du weißt eigentlich immer, ist das überhaupt eine korrekte ISBN,
indem du dir die Prüfziffer anguckst.
Dafür hat man sie.
Genau. Und dann hat er sich halt den Dampf geholt, hat gedacht,
ich erwarte jetzt zwei Dinge.
Also einmal erwarte ich so Sachen wie Zahlendreher und dann kann ich das irgendwie
sehr schnell korrigieren und es gibt so eine kleine Handvoll,
da weißt du wahrscheinlich als Bibliotheker mehr, kleine Handvoll von ISBN,
wo die Verlage selber das System von ISBN nicht verstanden haben und sozusagen
inkorrekte ISBN vergeben haben, die aber dann auch in den entsprechenden Katalogen als ja,
stimmt eigentlich nicht, ist aber in dem Fall okay.
Ist aber halt mal so aufgedruckt.
Genau, ist halt so aufgedruckt. So, das hat er erwartet, dass man das findet
und dass man ganz, ganz viele Zahlendreher findet, die man halt dann korrigieren kann.
Was er gefunden hat, war Tausende, Tausende von ISBN,
die überhaupt nicht stimmten, mit Titeln, die nicht online aufhandbar sind,
geschrieben von Autoren,
die vielleicht mal was zu dem Thema veröffentlicht haben, aber sicherlich nicht dieses Werk.
Und er hat dann plötzlich gemerkt, okay, das sind die Fußnoten,
das sind die Referenzen.
Das ist halluziniertes KI-Zeug.
Und das heißt, die Wissensproduktion steht steht eigentlich auf ganz schön tönernen Füßen.
Wie viele Jahre wird das dauern, bis wir das alles aufgeräumt haben? Und wer macht denn das?
Es ist auch so, dass es superschnell und einfach ist, so einen KI-Text mit mehr
oder weniger hallazionierten Fakten zu erzeugen und dann in die Wikipedia einfach reinzupasten.
Aber es ist super aufwendig und schwierig, dann für andere Leute wirklich jeden
Satz, jeden Fakt zu überprüfen. Und da wird einfach, also die eine Seite skaliert
einfach viel, viel besser.
Und die Community hat vielleicht auch anderes zu tun und denkt sich dann halt
irgendwie, lassen wir es einfach.
Und ist das dann einfach so ein Ökosystem, so ein Tümpel, der dann irgendwann
umkippt und dann hat keiner mehr Bock drauf? und ja, das ist einer der großen
Probleme, vor dem wir gerade stehen.
Also dieses KI-Dings, das wird nicht weggehen, aber wir haben gleichzeitig.
Da noch so ein paar Probleme. Was auf jeden Fall klar ist, ist,
dass bei dieser generativen KI das Wikimedia-Content da so zum,
das ist ja das Grundnahrungsmittel sozusagen. sagen.
Es gibt, glaube ich, kein Sprachmodell, was nicht mit Wikipedia oder anderen
Wikimedia-Inhalten trainiert worden ist.
Oft auch mehrfach. Und gleichzeitig diese ganzen KI-Crawler,
die hauen schon richtig rein.
Also es gibt so Zahlen, dass so 60 bis 70 Prozent aller Zugriffe im Moment auf
die Wikipedia von KI-Crawlern passieren.
Das ist alles Traffic, das jemand zahlen muss. Das ist, gerade wenn es dann
halt auf spendenbasiert, das machen willst.
Frisst es die Spenden auf.
Ja, schwierig. Und dann halt die Frage, also so, wir sind alte Männer,
wir haben noch irgendwie Sachen in eine Webseite eingegeben und haben danach gesucht, aber,
Auf einer kleinen Konferenz zum Thema KI und Wikimedia, wo ich vor zwei Wochen
in Lausanne in der Schweiz war, da hat eine Teilnehmerin gesagt,
also ich würde wetten in fünf Jahren, benutze keiner mehr Wikipedia.
Das wird einfach nicht das Portal sein, wo man sein Wissen sucht,
sondern da stellt man seine Fragen dann direkt an Siri, an ChetGDP, sonst was.
Und was bedeutet das? Also klar, viel weniger Leute sehen eine Spendenbanne,
aber wir machen es ja nicht, um Spenden zu generieren, aber viel weniger Leute sehen den Edit-Button.
Wenn sie halt irgendwie was falsch finden,
dann können sie bei Wikipedia auf den Edit-Button drücken, theoretisch und können
das dann verändern und dann ist es auch gleich dabei oder zumindest ist es der erste Schritt,
dass du dann halt auch irgendwie Teil dieses digitalen Ehrenamts wirst und das
wirst du halt nicht, wenn dein Zugang zum Wissen einfach darin besteht,
dass du eine Maschine was fragt und eine Maschine gibt dir was zurück.
Das, was mich richtig gecatcht hat, war der Titel von dieser Konferenz, dieser Minirunde.
Das war Collective Intelligence versus Artificial Intelligence.
Und darauf läuft es dann am Schluss hinaus.
Also kollektive Intelligenz haben wir jetzt irgendwie ganz gut hingekriegt.
Also manchmal nervt es, weil die Leute halt ein anstrengendes Sozialverhalten
haben, aber am Ende sind wir zusammen alle schlauer als jeder Einzelne von uns.
Artificial Intelligence fängt jetzt gerade an. Es wäre schade,
wenn das eine das andere ersetzen würde. Ich bin so...
Aus Hippie-Gründen eher Team Collective Intelligence.
Ja, ich glaube, das sind wir hier alle. Ja, also die Gefahr,
die ist real, würde ich sagen.
Und die ist, glaube ich, gar nicht erst in zehn Jahren real,
sondern die ist meiner Meinung nach auch jetzt schon real.
Du hast halt bei Google mittlerweile als erstes diese Zusammenfassung,
was auch immer das sein soll.
Der Wahrheitsgehalt davon ist highly doubtful.
Also ich habe da auch schon sehr oft schlicht einfach die falsche Antwort gehabt.
Mit anderen Worten, wir sind jetzt sehr viel mehr mit falschen Informationen konfrontiert.
Das mag noch zu ertragen sein in dem Moment, wo es nachprüfbar falsch ist,
aber es gibt ja auch viel, das ist überhaupt in dem Sinne gar nicht klar zu bewerten.
Da ist dann schon die Tonalität auch relevant und solange es auch nur technische Unfälle sind.
Kann man sagen, okay, das kriegen wir noch irgendwie gefixt,
aber wir sehen ja jetzt auch,
dass es jetzt ein zunehmendes Maße Druck gibt bei denen, die das Geld haben,
um solche Sachen einfach mal selber zu finanzieren, dass sie im Zweifelsfall
alles in Bewegung setzen müssen.
um so ein Poisoning durchzuführen, also diese ganzen von dir erwähnten generierten
wissenschaftlichen Artikel.
Ich meine, was ist die Motivation, das da reinzubringen? Also woher kommt das?
Was hat jetzt die Leute angetrieben, so einen Quatsch überhaupt erstmal zu erzeugen und einzufügen?
Also eine Regel bei Wikipedia ist, geh von guten Absichten aus.
Vielleicht wollen sie einfach nur helfen. Also eine andere Möglichkeit wäre
natürlich, dass man versucht ein Narrativ zu flippen und wir wissen ja irgendwie,
weiß ich nicht, es gibt mehrere schadliche Akteure,
die gerade heftig dran arbeiten, irgendwelche Narrative zu setzen und wenn man
es dann maschinell automatisieren kann, dann ist es umso schöner.
Wahrscheinlich liegt es an beiden, an naiven Leuten, die gerne helfen wollen
und an bösartigen Leuten, die gerne ihren eigenen Punkt machen wollen.
Genau und das ist natürlich ein Problem, weil wir darüber natürlich in Gefahr
laufen, vielleicht so...
Die letzte Bastion der Wahrheit, ist das jetzt ein bisschen zu sehr übertrieben?
Also vielleicht schiebe ich da jetzt auch zu viel auf Wikipedia,
aber im Prinzip ist es ja schon so,
dass das Wikipedia-Projekt auch für so Vertrauen steht.
Man vertraut dem Inhalt, da steht es mal drin,
wie es wirklich ist und so weiter, weil wer vertraut schon noch überhaupt irgendeiner
Quelle und gerade wenn man sich so Propaganda anschaut, vor allem natürlich
die russische Propaganda,
wie die arbeitet und was so deren Zielsetzungen sind,
dann ist es ja immer das Auflösen von Vertrauen.
Du vertraust einfach, also alles ist falsch, vertraue nichts mehr,
glaub nur noch dem, was am lautesten in dich reinbrüllt und das war's.
Und dann gibt es halt irgendwie gar keine Instanz mehr und damit bist du potenziell
gegen alles aufhetzbar.
Und das ist so eigentlich das Spiel, was getrieben wird.
Also Wahrheit finde ich da auch nicht einen guten oder hilfreichen Begriff.
Also ich würde sagen, nehmen wir mal Wissen.
Und Wissensproduktion bedeutet, dass man sich irgendwie der Wahrheit annähert.
Das Wissen kann dann auch irgendwann später unwahr werden.
Ich habe wie viele in der Schule im Biologieunterricht gelernt,
dass dieses Zungenrollen, dass das ein genetisches Merkmal ist und dass das
von den Eltern weitervererbt wird und dass es ein gutes Beispiel ist für männliche
Vererbungslehre. Das ist mittlerweile...
Von der gesamten Biologie-Genetik-Community ist das sowas von debunked,
aber es wird immer noch weitererzählt.
Also Tatsache ist, es gibt Leute, die können das, es gibt Leute, die können das nicht.
Viele von denen, die es nicht können, können es durch Übung lernen,
die Zunge zu rollen. Aber es ist nicht, wo man sagen könnte,
da gibt es jetzt einen genetischen Marker und der wird von Vater und Mutter vererbt.
Da gab es dramatische Szenen, dass dann Leute gesagt haben, ich kann die Zunge
nicht rollen, aber meine Eltern können es, ist meine Mutter fremdgegangen oder bin ich adoptiert?
Ach herrje.
Ja, also das war mal eine Wahrheit.
Aber mittlerweile sind wir halt irgendwie, mittlerweile hat die Wissenschaft
dann gesagt, Ja gut, müssen wir revidieren, jetzt gibt es eine andere Wahrheit.
Aber diese Wissensproduktion, dass du einfach im öffentlichen Raum alles zusammenträgst, guckst und so.
Und was ist das Beste, was wir im Moment gerade an Wissen haben?
Und das ist eben nicht, indem du die nächste wahrscheinliche Vollendung von
einem Satz auswürfelst mit dem LLM, sondern das ist auch ganz schön viel menschliche
Diskussion und Debatte.
Die wissenschaftliche Methode als solche steht ja auch ganz schön unter Beschuss
durch dieses Poisoning von erfundenen Papers und angeblichen Behauptungen.
und auch da sind teilweise die Motivationen, sowas zu machen,
glaube ich, sehr vielfältig.
Es hat was mit Fame zu tun und seine eigene Bedeutung hochzuschießen und dabei
aber dieses ganze wissenschaftliche Prinzip der gegenseitigen Kontrolle so ein bisschen aufzulösen.
Und ich frage mich halt jetzt wirklich, wie resilient sind eigentlich so unsere...
Wie resilient ist so die Gesamtkultur der Wissenschaft gegenüber diesem Phänomen,
dass jetzt so beliebige Behauptungen sehr günstig erzeugt werden können.
Was AI derzeit eigentlich so gefährlich macht, ist, dass es,
abgesehen jetzt von den Milliarden Investitionen, die da derzeit reingemacht
werden und verbrannt werden,
dass diese Tools ja jetzt sagen wir mal für die Endanwender vergleichsweise
günstig sind und deswegen auch so populär sind.
Es skaliert halt.
Es skaliert. Vielleicht hört es irgendwie auch auf zu skalieren,
wenn diese ganzen Zukunftsversprechen dann so ein bisschen zerplatzen und die
Gelder nicht mehr so fließen,
weil die Investoren ihren Revenue nicht sehen.
dann wird es sich sicherlich nochmal ein bisschen anders verhalten,
weil auf einmal die Dinge ihren wahren Preis bekommen.
Auf der anderen Seite wissen wir ja aber auch, was die technologische Entwicklung
zu leisten in der Lage ist.
Kann sehr gut sein, dass das in zehn Jahren alles Pipifax ist und die neuronalen
CPUs sind schnell genug und Training ist jetzt irgendwie auch kein Problem mehr
und das verbraucht auch irgendwie alles nicht mehr nennenswert Strom oder zumindest nicht in einem Maße,
dass man es nicht mehr finanziert und bereitgestellt bekommt.
Und dann ist halt die Frage, wie,
entwickelt eigentlich die Gesellschaft überhaupt noch ein resilientes Modell,
wo das eigene Wissen überhaupt noch erhalten werden kann, weil das ist ja letztlich
auch in einem Gesamtinteresse, dass wir uns nicht.
Total verblöden durch solche Incentives für Einzelne, also dass so einzelne
Akteure, seien es reiche Leute,
seien es Leute, die der Meinung sind, sie müssten jetzt irgendwie berühmter
sein als sie sind oder halt auch Scammer, die einfach nur Geld verdienen wollen,
dass das sozusagen das gesamte Wissensmodell der Welt und letzten Endes ja auch
die Speicherung dieses Wissens attackiert.
Lustigerweise haben die Leute, die die AI-Modelle trainieren, auch dieses Problem.
Weil wenn der ganze AI-Slop ins nächste Modell wieder reingekippt wird,
wird es ja nicht mehr besser.
Urobus-Effekt, also Urobus ist diese mythologische Schlange,
die sich in der eigenen Schwanz beißt und genau, das ist also wenn Chat BSE,
Habsburg-Effekt habe ich auch schon gehört Auch nicht schlecht, dicke.
Lippe sage ich.
Nur Wenn AI halt seinen eigenen Slop frisst das ist nicht unbedingt das was wir haben wollen,
so und es ist auch super einfach da irgendwie in eine ganz düstere Stimmung
zu kommen und wir sind auch auf jeden Fall
in einem der spannendsten Gesellschaftsexperimente überhaupt gerade drin,
aber dann bin ich auch noch Nerd und irgendwie will es mir dann doch nicht irgendwie,
passen, dass ich sage so und ich ziehe jetzt in eine Hütte auf einer einsamen
Insel und will mit diesem ganzen KI Zeug nichts zu tun haben,
Ich glaube nämlich wirklich, dass es Wissen gibt...
Dass wir mit KI backern können. Also vor allen Dingen Dinge,
von denen wir nicht wussten, dass wir sie wussten.
Dinge, wo Pattern gematcht werden, wo in dieser ganzen Infosphäre,
die wir als Gesellschaft haben, als Menschheit in den letzten 100.000 Jahren angesammelt haben,
wo wir einfach die Verknüpfungen noch nicht sehen und wo wir dann einfach mit
Werkzeugen wie neuronalen Netzen dann halt dahinter gehen können.
Das heißt, was wir dann auch bei Wikimedia machen ist, dass wir nicht sagen,
KI ist eBay und nur was im Brockhaus steht ist richtiges Wissen oder was in
der Wikipedia steht ist richtiges Wissen,
sondern wir sehen das schon, dass das auch eine Möglichkeit wäre neues Wissen
zu generieren und mit neuem Wissen zu arbeiten.
Wir haben die Wikidata-Grundlage dann in so eine Vektordatenbank umgewandelt.
Also es läuft alles unter dem Begriff Wikidata-Embedding-Projekt.
Das ist nicht so der ketschigste Titel, den man sich ausdenken kann.
ist auch im Moment erst mal so ein erstes Experiment und ist seit ein paar Wochen,
ich glaube im Oktober war das oder Ende September ist das an den Start gegangen,
das ist mehr so ein Proof of Concept.
Aber wofür es halt wirklich gedacht ist genau solche Anwendungen wie du sie
schon beschrieben hast, also Retrieval Augmented Generation RAG, dass man,
mit Wikidata sprechen kann und sagt, liebes Wikidata sag mir doch mal was Und
das funktioniert in so einer Vektordatenbank.
Also ein Vektor ist ein mathematisches Objekt, was eine Parallelverschiebung
im enddimensionalen Raum beschreibt.
Das heißt, ich kann dann auch sehen, ich habe in dieser Infosphäre in der Summe
des menschlichen Wissens, habe ich dann einen Wissensdatenpunkt.
Honig und der Wissensdatenpunkt Biene ist da näher dran als Einfamilienhaus.
Und das heißt, ich kann dann an der Wissensnähe dieser Vektoren auch dann schon
mal bestimmte Schlüsse machen, die ich so mit Sparkle irgendwie nicht erkennen kann.
Wofür ist das gut? Das ist zum Beispiel gut für Named Entity Recognition,
also NER. wenn ich solche Sachen machen will wie Namen, Länder.
Firmennamen oder sowas rausnehme.
Also angenommen die demokratische Partei in den USA
veröffentliche ich jetzt einfach mal ein paar Gigabyte E-Mails von Epstein und
die gesamte Datenjournalismusbande der ganzen Welt ist jetzt dabei mit Grab
irgendwelche interessanten Sachen in diesen Datenfundus zu machen.
Wenn ich jetzt darauf gehe und sage, hier, sprich mal mit Wikidata und zieh
mir die interessanten Named Entities raus,
dann sehe ich zumindest hier, wo spricht er über Personen, wo spricht er über
Firmen und so weiter und kann da irgendwie viel besser in diesem ganzen Wiesenwust drin vorwerken.
Das Ganze wird dann noch über so eine offene Schnittstelle, Open Source Implementation
und offenes Protokoll, MCP nennt sich das,
Model Context Protocol, das ist was, was Anthropic entwickelt hat,
wo eigentlich LLMs mit anderen Endstücken sprechen können und dann hast du halt,
Wikidata als Endstück in deinem LLM-Workflow.
Das gibt es schon oder?
Ja, das gibt es schon.
Es gibt schon Wikidata-MCP, okay, cool.
Und das sind so die Experimente, die wir gerade machen. Und da müssen wir halt gerade gucken,
das wird auf jeden Fall für so Sachen wie Fragen beantworten,
also Question Answering heißt das in der KI,
wird das auf jeden Fall eine gute Sache sein und es ist vielleicht auch dann
eine sinnvollere Sache, als wenn ich das einfach in ChatGPT so raus reingebe und ChatGPT,
gibt mir dann Antwort, die grammatisch und stilistisch wahrscheinlich ist,
aber die nicht unbedingt sich,
an der Wahrheit oder an dem Stand des menschlichen Wissens orientiert.
Weil da müsste man dann vielleicht mit sowas wie einer Vektordatenbank von Wikidata sprechen.
Cool. mcp für wikidata das ist ja geil das muss immer ausprobieren.
Ja, aber ich meine, wir haben ja vorhin schon gesagt, okay, es gibt so diesen
LLM-Approach, dieser probabilistische Kram und dann gibt es irgendwie so diese
harte Faktenwelt einer Datenbank.
Die Verbindung ist ja jetzt in dem Sinne auch nichts Neues. Also MCP ist das
gute Beispiel und generell ist ja so Tool-Use glaube ich auch genau das,
was meiner Auffassung nach in den nächsten Monaten,
also das läuft jetzt schon seit einer Weile, aber im Prinzip in diesem Jahr
hat sich gezeigt, dass so Tool-Use das ist, mit dem man diese Systeme deutlich verbessern kann.
Die sind ja noch nicht bulletproof und die sind auch nicht frei von Halluzinationen
und Erfindungen und Ungenauigkeit,
aber man benutzt die Dinger dann halt mehr, wie es so schön heißt, agentic.
Also man benutzt eigentlich die LLM mehr als unmittelbares Human Interface,
um einfach schneller, einfacher beschreiben zu können, was man haben will und
das System muss dann nur klug genug sein, zu sagen so, ah okay, darum geht es also,
dann benutze ich hier dieses Tool und das ist ja das, was MCP bereitstellt und
in dem Fall dann halt eben Wikidata,
um irgendwie Fakten rauszubekommen und dann wird es eben auch schon wieder alles nützlicher.
Genau und da wird im nächsten Jahr wird es dann noch ein bisschen mehr von Wikimedia zu dem Thema geben.
Da wird gerade hinter den Kulissen ganz intensiv dran gearbeitet.
Aber was ganz klar ist, wir sind da so die einzigen oder eine der wenigen Stellen,
wo wir nicht irgendwie ein Produkt verkaufen wollen, sondern wir wollen einfach
mehr Menschen mehr Zugang zu mehr Wissen geben.
und haben dann auch so Ansprüche wie, ja, es gibt sowas wie planetare Grenzen, wie gehen wir damit um?
Und es gibt Ungerechtigkeit in der Welt, nicht alle Regionen sind gleich reich
und nicht alle Menschen haben irgendwie die gleichen Sachen.
Wie können wir das ausgleichen?
Das sind irgendwie für uns so die interessanten Fragen und das ist sowas,
was die KI-Industrie zumindest irgendwie erstmal nicht interessiert oder zumindest
das nicht als Hauptfokus hat.
Also wird auch gerne mal was mit Greenwashing und Openwashing gemacht,
aber im Grunde sind wir da mit den Wikimedia-Projekten ziemlich alleine mit.
Wir wollen mehr Menschen mehr Zugang zu mehr Wissen geben und,
Wir können natürlich auch KI nicht ignorieren.
Ist dieses Projekt, dieses Embedding-Projekt, ist das auch wieder so Wikimedia
Deutschland oder ist das eher so eine globale Geschichte?
Ja, das ist von Wikimedia Deutschland.
Also was so Wikidata-Kram betrifft, ist hier einfach mal the place.
Das Projekt wird in Deutschland entwickelt und gepflegt und auch diese Sachen,
dass wir jetzt nachdenken über, wie können wir das mit der Welt der KI verheiraten.
und zwar in einer sinnvollen Art, die auch irgendwie mit unseren Werken übereinstimmt.
Das wird auch alles in Deutschland gemacht und wie gesagt, schau mal nächstes
Jahr nochmal vorbei, dann kann man da auch ein bisschen konkreter sagen, wie es da weitergeht.
Was auf jeden Fall für uns ein großes Problem ist, unser Standardzugang ist,
wir machen immer alles oben.
Also vor 25 Jahren haben wir die ganzen Open Source-Initiative und Wikimedia
und Creative Commons und sowas, die haben wir alle gegründet.
Und eigentlich müssten die ja jetzt perfekt dastehen, um zu sagen, wir...
Wir verteidigen jetzt das offene Internet, aber die stehen alle wie so ein Reh
im Scheinwerfer und haben überhaupt keine Ahnung,
was das jetzt für ein Güterzug ist, der auf sich zurollt mit den Open-Airs und Kugels dieser Welt.
Und das ist alles richtig schwierig, was da gerade passiert.
Und unsere Herangehensweise mit, wir machen das alles Open Source und unter
freien Lizenzen, das funktioniert nicht.
Also es gibt keine Open Source AI in dem Sinne bei diesen generativen Sachen.
Du kannst das Modell freigeben, du kannst die Gewichte freigeben,
du kannst das Tooling drumherum in Open Source machen.
Aber so wie diese Dinger sind, kannst du es nicht einfach in deinen Editor aufrufen
und sagen, guck mal, das ist die Tiefenstruktur, wenn ich an der Stelle was
ändere, dann kommt das mal raus.
Das ist nicht mehr Open Source in dem Sinne, das ist etwas anderes.
Und da sind wir irgendwie noch dabei und müssen das irgendwie definieren.
Es gibt ein super cooles Paper von so einem Think Tank Open Future.
Die haben ein Paper gemacht und nennen das Public AI und die sagen,
wir müssen einfach bei AI über einen sogenannten Stack sprechen.
Es gibt einmal den Compute-Stack.
Das ist das, wo kein Wikimedia der Welt und keine Stabi oder sowas sagen kann.
Und morgen konkurrieren wir einfach mit OpenAI, weil das sind einfach Milliarden
Summen, die man dann aus dem Stand bringen müsste.
die kannst du einfach nicht aufbringen. Also da ist das Spielfeld einfach nicht
für alle gleich gemacht.
Wir können uns nicht entscheiden, mit Open AI auf der Compute-Ebene zu konkurrieren.
Dann gibt es irgendwie diesen Model-Bereich. Es gibt ein paar freie Modelle.
Wie kann man die irgendwie dann Open Source-mäßig verwalten und gemeinsam bearbeiten.
Da ist auch noch nicht das letzte Wort gesprochen. Was wir, glaube ich,
ganz gut hingekriegt haben, ist dieser Datenbereich im Stack.
Dass wir irgendwie uns bei Wikimedia dann halt mit der Kuratierung von hochqualitativen
Daten beschäftigen werden und die auch selbstverständlich allen frei zur Verfügung
stellen und nicht irgendwie nur gegen Lizenzkosten an die und die Firma.
Und bist du da irgendwie Und,
optimistisch, dass das irgendwie gelingen kann, da eine Alternative zu bieten,
die irgendwie da einen Pfad in die Zukunft zeigt?
Ah, optimistisch ist so ein großes Wort und seit 2020 auch nicht mehr so richtig en vogue, ne?
Seit 2020.
Seit 2016, okay.
Ach, du meinst ja diese goldenen 20er, ja? Da muss ich mich ja immer wieder,
entschuldigen, dass ich das mal pro Post habe.
Also, ja, ich habe immer Hoffnung, weil ohne geht es ja gar nicht.
Und ich finde das alle sehr aufregend gerade.
Und bei mir drehen da die Rädchen im Gehirn gerade permanent. So.
Ja.
Schauen wir mal.
am Schluss gewonnen hat.
Wir lassen das jetzt mal offen.
Ja, ich mag da in der Tat dein Mindset zu sagen, so das ist jetzt nicht alles
schon irgendwie, der Drops ist nicht gelutscht, sondern so man hat noch einen Gestaltungsraum.
Und wenn man laut und gut vernetzt ist und gute Ideen hat und irgendwie zeigen
kann, guck mal XY wäre doch vielleicht auch eine gute Idee.
So, das ist nicht von vornherein verloren.
Also ich meine, guck dir an, hier morgen, ist irgendwie deutsch-französischer Digitalgipfel.
Seid ihr da von Wikimedia aus mit am Start?
Da taucht die Zivilgesellschaft gar nicht auf.
Weil Zivilgesellschaft braucht man irgendwie nicht zur digitalen Souveränität.
Und wir finden das ein bisschen frech, also Wikimedia Deutschland.
Also nicht nur unverschämt, sondern auch richtig frech. Weil,
Wikipedia und seit ein paar Monaten auch Wikidata, ist jetzt durch eine Initiative,
die die UN unterstützt, als digitales Gut eingestuft worden.
Public Digital Good oder sowas heißt das.
Und das heißt also, die UN sieht uns als ein Baustein für das,
was man da als digitale Souveränität bezeichnen könnte.
Aber dieser europäische Digitalgipfel,
Weiß ich nicht. Die möchten dann lieber mit Unternehmer sprechen oder so?
Also ich bin ja Teil dieser Safe Social Erstunterzeichner.
Da ist also seit Wochen auch Thema, wo genau ist hier die Zivilgesellschaft
und ist mal irgendwie gemeinnützige Organisationen und Bibliotheken dauernd auch nicht auf.
Das ist echt eine reine Wirtschaftsgeschichte, die da morgen abläuft.
Also nicht morgen, sondern heute, muss man jetzt mittlerweile sagen.
Man könnte also so richtig, also dieser Begriff digitale Souveränität,
da kann man lange drüber reden, da ist auch viel Euronationalismus dabei und
hast du nicht gesehen, aber ja,
es ist ein Problem, wenn wir von chinesischen und amerikanischen Produkten abhängig
sind und China und Amerika sagen,
so und jetzt schalten wir das bei euch mal aus, das geht so nicht,
da muss man sich das überlegen.
Man könnte es sofort mit Open Source lösen, das Problem. Mhm.
Tja, aber wir leben halt in einer Welt, wo viele Leute sagen,
ja, als Geschäftsführer kaufe ich dann mal lieber Microsoft.
Da ist noch niemand gefeuert worden, wenn er Microsoft gekauft hat.
Genau und dann kommen die Anwälte und alles wird gut. Letzte Woche habe ich
eine Keynote gehalten auf so einem etwas längeren Format auch zum Thema digitale
Souveränität und ich war die Closing Keynote und vor mir waren wirklich fünf
Speaker dran von sogenannten Hyperscalern,
der Begriff war mir jetzt auch noch gar nicht so bekannt und deren Kernbotschaft war,
hey digitale Souveränität kriegt ihr nur in unserer Cloud.
Moment, also,
ich habe Fragen. Ja, es ist schon, mal gucken, wie das ganze Spiel so alles ausgeht.
Aber wer aufhört zu kämpfen, hat schon verloren. Das kann es nicht sein.
Und es ist nicht so, dass gerade irgendwie die EU und auch Deutschland da komplett zahnlos wären.
Was das Rechtssystem angeht, vielleicht ist das ein oder andere da doch noch zu hoffen.
Ich sage jetzt mal Amen hier bei dieser Sendung.
Wir haben die vier Stunden durch und müssen jetzt auch mal langsam in die Haier.
Gerne.
Jens, das war super. Vielen Dank, dass du da warst.
Hat mich auch gefreut. Endlich konnte ich mir so richtig leerreden.
Wir können uns auch noch mal gerne zum Co-Spielen treffen.
Das machen wir auf jeden Fall. Da möchte ich mich nicht aufgeben.
Wir teilen die Leidenschaft für den Zeichentrickfilm K-Pop Demon Hunters,
den wir eigentlich auch noch mal ansprechen wollten.
Den wollten wir heute noch besprechen.
Das macht er dann mal unter euch und dann berichtet er das nächste Mal.
Gut. Ich würde sagen, das war's. Dann spielen wir noch mal hier unser schönes, kleines Outro ein.
Ja, Freakshow 299. Schon einiges zusammengekommen.
Und wir wünschen euch jetzt noch einen schönen Tag, schöne Woche und so weiter.
Wir kommen noch mal dieses Jahr zu euch und dann könnt ihr wieder ein bisschen
zuhören und sagen, bis dann, tschüss, bis bald, ciao.
Tschüss, ciao.